Õpetaja: Hea küll, las ta siis rekordib. Ee, vaatan, et vähemalt siis. Ee, mikrofon on õige. Hästi,
Õpetaja: No näete, olemegi jõudnud siia esimese nädala lõppu. Arvestades seda, et kolm nädalat on niukest, nagu kuidagi kiirelt
Õpetaja: Täna kindlasti siis. Ee, mm.
Õpetaja: Proovime anda üsna palju hagu Selle poega. Võibolla siis nii palju võiks eilsest natukene. Ee, midagi.
Õpetaja: Nagu riik app. Ida
Õpetaja: on see, et. Ee, kuidas see poe töötab? Tegemist on Siis Single Page Application. Iga see tähendab seda, et meil on ainult üks,
Õpetaja: mis asi
Õpetaja: üks ja dünaamiliselt see pannakse lihtsalt kokku, et Sa nagu linnulennult pannakse kokku, Et mis see sisu on? Ja mis selle eelis on? Siis? See Kas keegi saab siia ukse kinni panna et mis selle eelis nagu on, on see, et, ee,
Õpetaja: mm,
Õpetaja: ee, et siis kui ee, seal lehel, toimuvad mingisugused, muuda muutused, isegi niimoodi, et lausa andmeid tuuakse kuskilt Back endist uuesti. Ära. Ee, siis, ee. See leht niiöelda uueneb osaliselt ja see annab siis ee nendele
Õpetaja: Ee Application It Application It. Selle eelise, et Ee refresh itakse ainult väikest osa.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis Ee Facebookis. Nagu Hea näide Scroll Id Voli laul Teatud arv. Mingi postitusi. Kõik ei laetu korraga alla. Noh, ei saagi. Vaata, see on endast niikuinii Vaata lõputu Scroll, onju?
Õpetaja: Ma ei, tea, Kas on võimalik, mi üldse? Ma ei viitsiks proovida Seda, et kui sa kogu aeg Scrolliks Scrolliks lõpp tuleb ka kunagi
Õpetaja: võibolla
Õpetaja: Brauser nagu Annab otsad. Võibolla või mida iganes, aga. Noh, sisuliselt siis see mõte ongi. Jah, see, et, ee, üks sõna, mida ma pole veel tegelikult väga öelnud, et kogu see ülesehitus on tehtud reaktiivsusele.
Õpetaja: Ee, et ma reageerin millelegi. Ja mida me, Jah, et ee,
Õpetaja: jah, ee, isegi see Teine niiöelda Suur tuntud raamistik annab lausa niukest nime peaga Onju, et reageeri
Õpetaja: Ee, ta ta siis põhimõtteliselt niimoodi
Õpetaja: üsna hästi ise oskab ee Siis dünaamiliselt ee, veebi veebilehel niiöelda kuvada asju vastavalt meie soovile. Aga niimoodi, et, ee, hästi palju on nagu kuidagi siis nagu kuidagi automatiseeritud ära, et me ei pea nagu palju progema. Progemise mõttes.
Õpetaja: Ta saab aru, mida me tahame teha ja ta taustal ise teeb nagu mingi Monster Raske koodi valmis. Nagu Mis siis? Seal Browser is toimetab? Ee ja tegutseb,
Õpetaja: et umbes kuidagi niimoodi no vastukaaluks, siis ee, siis jah, Et Siis ka siuksed lehed. Noh, vanasti. Kõik lehed olid niimoodi. Kui sa läksid ühelt lehelt teisele, siis tegelikult sa läksid uuele Html ile,
Õpetaja: Isegi mina mäletan mingi väga, väga vanadest aegadest. Kuidagi mingi mingi niuke programm oli nagu Triin Viiver I, Kes see nagu täna ma mõtleks, Tast natukene nagu ide. See oli nagu mingi niukene asi. Nagu. Või mingi, et. Et pane siia pilt, Vaata, genereerid sulle sinna meil koodi Ja
Õpetaja: sa ütlesid, et okei ma tahan nüüd uut lehte. Siis ta tegi uue lehe ja siis said seda linkida. Ja esialgsed katsetused. Tegin kunagi Mingi kodulehe. Isegi tüdrukule. Mingi roosa värk oli
Õpetaja: paar, sai sinna tehtud ja veidi aega ta oli. Ja siis lõpuks nagu hapus kuhugi,
Õpetaja: Ee, nii et ee, Vahva tehnoloogia On see mulle isiklikult meeldib. Ma ei ole selles mõttes ee
Õpetaja: taustalt frontend, arendaja, Kõik, mis ma olen õppinud. Olen ise õppinud. Ee, oskused nagu ikka on, et ajas lähevad järjest paremaks järjest paremini. Saad keerulistest konseptsioonidest aru, mis enam üldse ei tundu keerulised. Kuna sa saad aru, et seal taga on nagu mingi loogika? No see on jälle see neuronite värk. Vaata, see on mingi Peaasi, et
Õpetaja: käivad mingisugused klõpsud ära. Saad aru, See käib niimoodi. Ja siis nagu pärast hiljem on kuidagi hästi. Raske mõelda seda, vaata, et, Oi, see on väga keeruline.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui sa saad aru sellest mustrist, süsteemist ja loogikast,
Õpetaja: No siis kõik tundubki nagu, et see on väga loogiline. Ja ma saan sellest mõttest aru, kuidas see töötab. Ja see enam nii keeruline ei tundugi,
Õpetaja: et siis on nagu põhimõtteliselt lõpuks jääb Ainult süntaks veel. Nagu seda, et Kas ma oskaks peast nagu täiesti asju kirjutada? Ee, see lähenemine, mida meie siin kursusel kasutame,
Õpetaja: lähenemine. Ee, Seda ma kindlasti juba päris hästi oskaks ka peast kirjutada. Pole Probleemi
Õpetaja: Composition api. Mis on siis nagu mingi uuem kirjaviis? See tundub mulle Praegult, ee mõttes keeruline Never, ma oskaks seda kirjutada, aga ma paneks oma pea pakule, et ütleks, et kui ma, noh, piisavalt palju seda Nagu arendaks küll, siis lõpuks hakkab ka. Isegi see süntaks hakkab meelde jääma.
Õpetaja: Või võibolla siis, ee, väikene nagu enne, kui edasi liigume, et Tõesti, et, ee,
Õpetaja: et ee, Tegelikult ei olegi nii tähtis, tõesti, mis? Tuleb lihtsalt ka, et me me ei pea teadma. Vaata seda süntaksit Nagu peast. Eriti nüüd, kus see Ai, mis need ootused juunioritel on? Kõik kasutavad ai niikuinii. Süntaksiga. Saab niikuinii tema väga hästi hakkama, et Pigem on ikkagi võimalikult tähtis. Saada asjadest aru,
Õpetaja: et ee, kuidas asjad käivad. Ma ei Mõtlexit,
Õpetaja: mis on nagu loogika, mis on nagu eesmärk, Mingisugusel, ee, mingisugusel funktsionaalsusel või asjal Või mingi lähenemisviisil. Kuidas ta töötab? Aa, ja nii edasi
Õpetaja: Ee, et siis ühel hetkel. Noh, mis on Kõige raskem. Ee, asi Kogu selle ai majanduse juures on see, et. Aga kuidas. Ma valideerin. Ee, see. No Ütleme, kui ma olen uus Arendaja. Ee, kuidas ma valideerin see, mida ma nagu, mida, Mis on Cloud või kes iganes mulle välja annab, et see on nagu okei, On ju,
Õpetaja: ee, et see on see keeruline asi, et. Noh, tee mingi koodi töötab. Noh, ma ei tea siis, nagu justkui võiks mõelda, et on Fine on ju aga tegelikult Kas on ikka Fine On ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, siin Ikkagi Ma tõesti. Ei näe mingit muud asja, kui Ee, et põhimõtteliselt. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, tõesti. Siis nagu igast reast. Ma ei mõtle nagu lihtsalt koodireast, vaid ma mõtlen igast reast kui kontseptsioonist sa Saad aru, mida see teeb?
Õpetaja: Mitte nagu, et, ee, Ainult nagu see, et. Okei, ma kasutan mingisugust. Ma ei tea, tata bloki või mida iganes, onju? Ma saan aru, kuidas ta mingisugune. Nagu, Kuidas ta siin konkreetselt siin kontekstis midagi nagu teeb. Ja toimetab vaid ma nagu tean, Kuidas see asi üldse toimib? Mis võimalused veel siin on?
Õpetaja: Mismoodi saab seda asja Kasutada erineval viisil, mis üks või teine asi tähendab ja nii edasi ja nii edasi, edasi,
Õpetaja: et ee, et see on ainukene moodus, kuidas ma näen, kuidas on siis võimalik, nagu,
Õpetaja: ee, vähemalt praegusel ajal ja siin lähitulevikus niiöelda juunioritel niiöelda hakkama saada on see, et, ee, nad peavad lihtsalt siis ee tegema endale asju, nagu üsna nagu selgeks,
Õpetaja: et siis ikkagi aru saada ja siis hakata ka leidma neid kohti, kus ee, kus tundub, et ee, see lahendus, mis niiöelda, võibolla Ee, teile esialgselt tehakse, et võibolla seal on ikka mingid nüansid, mida teie, nagu, ee, ka nüüd juba teate ja mõtlete ja ja saate aru, et võibolla võiks paremini teha. Ma toon näite näiteks ka
Õpetaja: Mm. Eile küsin. Ee. Eile küsin nagu
Õpetaja: ee. Vaatasin siis oma projektis ühte koodilõiku, mis ee mulle niiöelda Cloud oli teinud.
Õpetaja: Ja ma tegelikult lihtsalt peas mäletasin esiteks, et mul, oli noh, sarnane lähenemine ühes teises kohas on juba
Õpetaja: ja. Ja ma üritasin saada aru, see oli. Me räägime kuskil
Õpetaja: seitsmest koodireast põhimõtteliselt, ja mul oli tõesti raskusi aru saada, et Ee, et. Aga et et mida või mismoodi see täpselt toimib, onju? Et Seal, oli niukseid nüansse,
Õpetaja: ma suhtlesin ja arutasin ja ma sain nagu aru. Vaata, Ja siis ma hakkasin pakkuma talle seda lähenemist, et. Aga Davai, et Noh, Iff lause sees, kui sul on If lause sees mingisugune ee, võrdlus
Õpetaja: ja. Ja selles mõttes isegi see ei pruugi olla. Nagu mingi pikk võrdlus et seal on mingi palju hände ja Hoore on ju? Seal on lihtsalt mingi võrdlus.
Õpetaja: Aa, kui seal on mingi palju hände ja hoore. Vaata, sa vaatad peale, siis on niimoodi, Kui sa midagi aru ei saa, on hästi lihtne. Tee sellest asjast eraldi meetod.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta võtab mingi sisend, sa paned, et panen näiteks Seda, et, ee, et võibolla ta kontrollib, et kas kasutajal on olemas juba
Õpetaja: Aa, mingisugune profiilipilt või või mingisugune asi. Vaata, sul on mingisugused Andmed, mille pealt ta tahab mingit otsust teha. Vaata, et seal on mingi geoorid ja võrdub ja ei võrdu. Sa saad selle väga palju lihtsamaks teha. Sulgude sees on Lihtsalt kutsutakse välja mingi meetod,
Õpetaja: mis nagu tagastab mingid buljoonid. Vaata, Noh, ütleme sama asi. Vaata, võibolla seal ei Vaata ainult seda. Vaata, et sul on mingi vanus. Võibolla mingi kuupäevi. Võibolla vaadatakse mingeid kategooriaid asju, Saate aru? Siin on palju asju, mida võrrelda, on ju. Kui sa vaatad kuskil seal ifi sees mingisuguseid tingimusi, siis mina ei saa, aru, mis siin tajub.
Õpetaja: Sa saad sellest meetodi,
Õpetaja: Sa saad selle nime panna. Ja nüüd sa loed hoopis teistmoodi. Vaata, no siin bloki sees. Midagi toimub onju
Õpetaja: Ee. Ja mina, nagu siis Vaata seda, et äkki teeks nagu selle kuus, kuus, Seitse koodirida. Mis seal on, et et tükid eks
Õpetaja: paneks nagu üks meetod, et ühestatakse meetodid teisest meetodit ja siis tema hakkas nagu mulle jaurama. Vaata, et, no jaa. Vaata, et tegelikult sa teed siin meetodid juurde, et siin on Nüüd selge. Niigi on ju? Ma mõtlesin. Et. No jah, sul on. Jah, selge. Võibolla tegelikult see ei olnud nagu nii nagu kohe, Selge, kui Vaata, asi on see ka. Vaata, et kui sul on kontekst,
Õpetaja: sa sa ise oled selle koodi kirjutanud.
Õpetaja: Sa ise oled selle loogika üles ehitanud. Sa tead, mis siin. Toimub Vaata, sa oled nagu pikalt toimetanud. Siis võivad kõik asjad tunduda väga, lihtsalt
Õpetaja: aga kuidagi proovige panna ennast sellesse võtmesse. Aga mis siis, kui mina? Nagu alati mõtlen Niimoodi Ma absoluutselt. Alati mõtlen niimoodi Koodi. Loetavuse osas Mõtlen seda,
Õpetaja: et Ma proovin panna ennast sellisse positsiooni, et ma mõtlen, et ma ei tea sellest asjast siin mitte midagi, mitte midagi ei tea, nagu põhimõtteliselt Tulen peale esimest korda loen
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma vaatan sinna ette nagu selle koodi sellise pilguga, siis ma vaatan nagu, et noh, tegelikult ma Tõesti natuke keeruline asi. Mida, üldse? Nagu peast teha. Et
Õpetaja: et mul vahel ikka küsitakse alati seda, et
Õpetaja: mis sa arvad? Vaata, et, ee, Mingi täiesti uus asi. Tundmatu asi vaata. Ja siis, mis sa arvad? Vaata, et et kui keeruline see asi, näiteks õpilastel, on
Õpetaja: hästi keeruline küsimus alati. Vaata, nagu et kui raske see on.
Õpetaja: No kuidas kuidas ma seda saan nüüd hinnata? Kui see kõik on väga lihtne, vaata, on, ju aga.
Õpetaja: Aga nagu ma. Ei. Ma ei ole nagu ise. Nagu ma ütlengi, enda jaoks on hästi raske mõelda, et ku, kui Sa tahad nagu päris vastust ka veel nagu anda tõesti. Vaata, kas kas tegelt on nagu raske või see tegelikult on ka tehtav või Arusaadav või kui raske see on. Vaata, kui kaua aega läheb, on ka teine niuke asi, mis kunagi ei oska vastata.
Õpetaja: Ja. Ja kui Ma näen niukest koodi. Ikkagi, kuidagi peab proovima sellesse pihku panna. Vaata, kui see tundub ikkagi niimoodi, et et forilne ka, et kui keegi Tuleks siia ja vaataks neid seitset. Rida vaatab, kas ta tegelt saaks aru.
Õpetaja: Ja kui sa ikka tunned, et nagu see vastus on, ei Vaata, siis sa peaksid mõtlema, et. Noh, kuidas seda parandada.
Õpetaja: Ja siis, ee. Cloud pakkus ka, mulle, et sa tahad seda hakkida eraldi meetoditeks, aga Siis tekib siia juurde mingi kaks, kolm meetodit. Vaata, onju. Ee, väiksed koodilõigud. Lihtsalt ee, et nagu Milleks? See Et sa siin kordagi ei kasuta. Vaata seda, et see, et et siin lehes Ei, sa ei kasuta seda funktsionaalsust uuesti, sest sisu oleks kohe, kui hakkab tublikaat koodi tekkima.
Õpetaja: Nagu et kirjuta täpselt sama reakoodi ja uuesti uuesti. Samas failis ka või isegi tegelt eraldi. Vaata, siis peaks hakkama mõtlema. On see. Vaata, et. Oot, oot oot, oot, Vaata, Onju et, ee. Noh, ma ei kirjuta kogu aeg koodi uuesti. Tee lihtsalt üks nimeline meetod, Mida saad siis käivitada Teeme? Klotse. Taaskasutatud klotse. Vaata, onju, mida saab nagu uuesti kasutada.
Õpetaja: Ja siis see pikk asi oli, see Pani mind üldse mõtlema vaatad? Okei, tal oli õigus, et selles konkreetses vaates
Õpetaja: Aa, seda tõesti. Tegelikult nagu mitte, kuidagi ei ei taaskasuta nagu vaata, et Noh, see seitse koodirida seal uuesti kuskilt ei tule. Aa, tema arvates ee. Meetodite tegemine oli, sest et ta arvas, et see kood on piisavalt selge, aga minu hinnangul ei olnud see nii.
Õpetaja: Ja. Aga siis see pani mind lihtsalt mõtlema. Vaata, onju, et. Okei, aga tegelikult tegelikult üldse See kood, mis ma praegu olen siin kirjutanud. Ma tean, et mul on ühes teises teises failis Ühes teises vaates on tegelikult täpselt need sama seitse rida koodi
Õpetaja: Ja siis ma hakkasin mõtlema, et. Ee, et kui siin on okei, kui me teeme tõesti niimoodi, et siin on Nagu natukene niukene Noh, seitse koodirida on natuke keerulised, et kui ma isegi neid ära ei hagi, onju
Õpetaja: aga siis ma hakkasin mõtlema, et et. Ee Okei, Ma prooviks ikkagi mõelda mingi väga hea meetodi kogu sellele kupatusele, Aga mul. Ma tabasin ennast mõttel. Vaata sellest, et Asi, mida tema ikkagi läbi ei hammustanud. Et mul tegelikult on ju kuskil veel ee, seitse rida seda sama koodi ja ma peaksin üldse selle asja nagu tõstma kuhugi kolmandasse kohta,
Õpetaja: kus mõlemad kohad saavad seda kasutada.
Õpetaja: Tema ei tulnud selle peale, aga mina ka kohe ei tulnud selle peale, kuigi. Noh, ma ve? Ma teadsin nagu veits. Nagu mõttes. Nagu Trigerdas, et. Oota aga,
Õpetaja: ee, et seal, on see et ühes Teises kohas oli ka. Ma juba selle koodi Olin oma mõttes nagu ära Review tand varasemalt ja ma olin nagu leppinud sellega, et eks ta natukene segane. Ole minu jaoks kui nagu peale vaadata, Aga see näitab seda. Vaata veel, et tegelikult siin on veel ikkagi kohti
Õpetaja: ja Eriti juurde tegemisel. Nagu näha,
Õpetaja: kui sa teed Jupiti asju juurde
Õpetaja: Ee, tal ei ole seda konteksti. Vaata, et, oh, ma enne tegin niimoodi,
Õpetaja: et kui sa mingi oma token itega hulluks ei taha minna. Vaata, onju kogu projekt. Ära vaata. Ja, noh, vaata igat koodirida ja nüüd Teeme mingi uue koodi. Vaata, see see juba võtab. Token Eid päris projektis.
Õpetaja: Noh, sul tuleb sinna mingi sadu faile. Vaata, see ei ole Nagu realistlik. Vaata, et, noh, see ei ole nagu praktiline, et siin on ikkagi kohti. Tegelikult, kus ma nagu näen, et kui sa hakkad nagu neid üldiseid printsiipe tabama. Vaata seda näiteks, et
Õpetaja: ma siiamaani ka tegelikult mõtlen, et, ee, mina endiselt arvan et ma, tegelikult teen ikkagi selle hästi natukene juppideks, et ma temaga alati ei pea nõustuma ka. Ee,
Õpetaja: on, ee, selline. Ma korra tahan rääkida seda ka. Vaata, et Minu jaoks loetavus on ee. Kuningas.
Õpetaja: Aa, Clean Code ütleb igasuguseid vahvaid mõtteid.
Õpetaja: Ee, räägime meetodi nimedest. Näiteks meetodi nimi peab olema võimalikult lühike,
Õpetaja: Okei, võimalikult lühike davai. Ma üritan selle kirja. Meetodi nimi peab võimalikult täpne
Õpetaja: meetode. Ee, tegelikult. Ei tohiks teha rohkem üht kui ühte asja korraga.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et justkui meetodi nimes kunagi ei saaks Isegi olla nagu Andy. Vaata
Õpetaja: Tee seda ja tee midagi teist, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga, Ee, kui kui neid kõike neid asju nagu vaadata nagu Aa, niimoodi eraldi seisvalt, siis seal on nagu mingisugused väiksed käärid.
Õpetaja: Kirjuta või et Nagu selles mõttes, et ee. Meetodi nimi peaks olema võimalik lühikene. Aa, Ta peaks olema võimalikult täpne,
Õpetaja: aga hästi keeruline ongi. Vaata hästi, lühikeselt kirjutada nagu midagi, mis kohe nagu annab
Õpetaja: kahe kolme sõnaga Nagu pildi ette mis teeb. No vahel ma. Need lihtsamad asjad on niimoodi, aga Vahel tegelikult sa tunned, et kurat, see meetodi nimi on nagu natukene pikk. Aga kui ma teen selle lühemaks, Kui ma teen selle lühemaks, Vaata siis siis ta tegelt ikkagi kaotab. Ära selle teravuse, mis ma tunnen, et selles kohas on vaja. Vaata
Õpetaja: ja noh, mingid muud reeglid, Ka siis mina olen selles mõttes enda jaoks. Olen teinud selle selgeks seda. Vaata, et minu jaoks tegelikult koodi loetavus, on siis kõige tähtsam asi,
Õpetaja: siis ma võtan puhtalt otsuse sellest, mis ma tunnen, et aitab kõige paremini Ee, võõral inimesele mõista, mis siin toimub,
Õpetaja: Et, Ee, need On need asjad, mida ma arvan Ka mida mida teie peate kuidagi ühel või teisel viisil hakkama, Vaikselt nagu, ee, nagu ka omandama, sest et. Noh, seda se sellest on ka artikleid olnud. Vaata, et. Oi, oi, oi, tuleb. Ja võtab nagu tööd. Ära vaata, onju, et nüüd Parim asi, mida sa saad teha, on see.
Õpetaja: Sa õpid tundma neid A ja asju
Õpetaja: väga põhjalikult, et kuidas nad töötavad, mis nad mismoodi Nad töötavad Ja kõige tähtsam on see, et kus nad ei ole veel nii head
Õpetaja: ja siis leidma need kohad. Vaata, et mina täidan need lüngad. Järelikult sa oled endiselt vajalik. Sellepärast. Ai
Õpetaja: vaid, on need lüngad. Ta ei tee veel seda hästi, et ee,
Õpetaja: umbes kuidagi niimoodi Te peate siis ka ee proovima mõelda.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, ma arvan, et tänast Aa, päeva võiks alustada niimoodi, et ee esiteks
Õpetaja: peaks natukene tegema siin korda, et siin on mingisugused asjad, mis? Ee, minul Vähemalt ee. Vääriksid kustutamist.
Õpetaja: Ee, customer. Chase on On mul screenshare peal, ka eks Ei ole, Ee. Paneme Screenshare I peale.
Õpetaja: Ma kustutan ära need indeksfaili. Tingim. Ei, mitte indeksfaili. Hinnakiri.
Õpetaja: Customer Chase on ja tingimused, et see Indeks ainult jääb
Õpetaja: Siis mis ma veel korda teen, on? Ma just tahaks saada lahti sellest. Ee, mul on õpetaja V. Kaks jäänud selle Haru nimeks
Õpetaja: tahaks nagu kuidagi puhtalt. Ee, lehelt alustada,
Õpetaja: nagu et see nimi oleks natukene viisakam.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis kohe ma näitan midagi mida ma Lubasin. Ee, lubasin ka Rihole, et ma kindlalt näitan talle.
Õpetaja: Ei, sest mul on meeles meie väike konvo.
Õpetaja: Ahah, ühe nüüd indeksfaili. Ma tegin Siis Kui te hakkate ima, siis vahepeal intellige ka. Viskab paremale nurka. Vaata, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ee, sul on mingi kood, mingi kole või midagi Väga halvasti, on ju? Te peate jälgima, et. Noh, tegelikult ka juhtuks. Nagu te võite mõttes nagu kuidas ajab lahti pole onju, et te Võite mõttes arvutada asja ära aga tegelikult ei ole. Sest et ta korraks trigerdab millegagi ja ütleb, et Kuule, oled sa kindel Ja siis, Noh, okei, nii ee, siis. Ee. Ma teen veel selle indeksi. Saate meile ka selles mõttes
Õpetaja: val korda, et ma taastan ta tegelikult täpselt Nii nagu ta algselt oli.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis minu mõistest realt Neliteist Kuni body Lõpuni välja siia
Õpetaja: et, jääks niimoodi ja. Siin on kaks rida Mis on välja kommenteeritud, ah?
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, miks te ei taha neid siin niimoodi käsitsi
Õpetaja: ei taha üldse kuidagi ära kommenteerida ja ma Võtan siis vanakooli kommentaari. Kustutamine.
Õpetaja: Ee ja Script I tag I. Tõmban kokku ja kustutan kogu kõike ära, sest seda pole vaja
Õpetaja: aa umbes Selline peaks ta lõpuks Aa välja nägema.
Õpetaja: Ee, huvitav, et ta ei taha panna neid Child ideks nagu normaalselt.
Õpetaja: No okei, las ta siis olla nii. Ma ei viitsi ka niimoodi võidelda temaga
Õpetaja: korra Hästi, kiirelt. Ee, Kes tahab tuleb järgi? Kas te tahate lihtsalt võtta? Lihtsalt selle aru, mis mul on, onju? Nii on lihtsam, on ju? Aga andke mulle. Võimalus. Ma kavatsen saada sellest Ee, õpetaja v kahest lahti.
Õpetaja: Ee, Mis ma teen Selleks on see. Ee. Teen veel ühe Commit I.
Õpetaja: Ma ise korra vaatan. Siis teeme kõik korraga, onju? Ee, tulete kõik järgi. Ma vaatan korra, et miuke see oli, et kas mul on midagi siin
Õpetaja: Ee, väga valesti või lasteaia Ma ei taha sellepärast, et Meil on õppematerjalid toks.
Õpetaja: Need lähevad kaotsi.
Õpetaja: Neid ei ole seal.
Õpetaja: Ee, et neid ma ei tahaks ära kaotada.
Õpetaja: Jah, Käib ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, Võibolla ma. Korra. Ee. Kas mul Linter on siin peal installitud? Võibolla peame selle tegema. Juurde. Panema. Ma korra vaatan ühte asja
Õpetaja: konfigi mõttes tundub olevat. Okei? Ee, vaatame korra. Kas ta seal ütleb, et seda saab jooksutada
Õpetaja: mingi. Ma ei jooksut seda tihti käsitsi, et ma ei tea, Mis on, ma korra vaatan? Ee, ma lihtsalt. Ee,
Õpetaja: see on siis see, vaata, et ta Niukene standard, mis defineerib ära üsna hästi ja Avascriptis, et kuidas asjad peavad olema.
Õpetaja: Ja kui sa jooksutad niukest käsku, nagu siis ta vaatab igalt poolt üle, kas kõik klapib, Aga ma ei ole kindel, kas ta töötab ilma types. Grip Ita. Ma vaatan, mis ta ütleb.
Õpetaja: Ühesõnaga, et tema mõt. Tema arvates kõik on nagu mõttes korrektne. Kuskil midagi katki pole Ja ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Nii nii et selles mõttes mingeid muudatusi alati saab vaadata ka kas toimus mingeid Muudatusi mitte.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis. Minu mõte on see, et. Ee, ma kustutan Ära selle õpetaja. Siit
Õpetaja: ma kustutan ära siit, mis mul on veel Kogemata siin näidistena jäänud
Õpetaja: ee. Kustutan ka selle õpetaja sealt. Ee, kitar vist ära.
Õpetaja: Kuidagi läks valesti. Ma tahtsin check out i peale minna. Olin see õpe Õpetaja V. Kaks oli mul. Koguaeg, onju
Õpetaja: nii ee. Tahaks lahti saada nendest teistest delete. Tracking Branch Jah, mhmh
Õpetaja: nii. Ee. Selle ka ta lahti saada.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: mis mul on plaan. Ma nüüd muudan ära. Selle Endal rename iga ee. Mis on Probleemid on hästi lihtne, kui see asi on lokalis.
Õpetaja: Ee, Kui on juba asi pilves, siis on haru, raskem nagu ee ümber nimetada.
Õpetaja: Ee, et ma tegin Niimoodi ma kustutasin selle Õpetaja V kaks ka pilvest ära, et seda pole.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd ma saan rahulikult teha reename ja ma jätan selle Niimoodi
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd ma push in välja. Ja kui seal oleks juba õpetaja ees praegult, siis ta ei saa nagu tema jaoks on tal On mingid Id D või asjad ka seal taga, et ta saaks aru, et need ei ole need samad. Vaata, et sa üritad suruda Mingit muud nagu tema, mõistes teistsugust haru sama. Nimega õpetaja pilve kus, oleks juba ees nagu õpetaja
Õpetaja: ee. Siis Ee, siis Ta hakkaks sellega Kindlasti jonnima.
Õpetaja: Aga ma ettenägelikud. Lihtsalt Kustutasin sealt kõik ära.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd on mul see haru nimi korras. Ma mõtlen, kas te võite järgi tulla.
Õpetaja: Ma korra panen serveri Käima. Vaatan, mis seis on.
Õpetaja: Ee, ärge veel tehke seda. Et. Ee. Kui praegu tuleb veel midagi välja, mis Mulle ei meeldi,
Õpetaja: mis on katki. Siis ma teeks selle pigem korda Ja siis ütleks teile
Õpetaja: noh. Luxabot right.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, davai, ee, Tehke Fetch.
Õpetaja: Noh, ennem tehke veel mingi Mida iganes,
Õpetaja: mis oli. Öelge mulle see järjekord. Mis kõigepealt Callback Page.
Õpetaja: Jah, Checkout New Branch, onju jah, See mõte on õige. Vaata, et lihtsalt uus haru õpetaja pealt.
Õpetaja: Ee, väike präänika.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: ee. Nädalavahetusel ma teen. Mul on plaanis Niukene skill teha, aga ma ei taha lihtsalt klassi ajaga selleks kulutada. Aga ma räägin sellest mõttest teile, et siis teate,
Õpetaja: minul on plaanis teha Niukene, Aa, asi, et Ee,
Õpetaja: Aa, Skill I nimi on Rainile järgi.
Õpetaja: Ja mis ta Siis teeb, on see, et ega selles mõttes Cloud saab ju käivitada mistahes programmi, käske,
Õpetaja: kaasa arvatud käsud.
Õpetaja: Ma võib öelda, et näiteks mina. Enam Ei, Ma ei viitsigi üldse enam oma projektitöös teha, Kui mitte harusid
Õpetaja: Käsitsi ei viitsi.
Õpetaja: No nüüd mul juba lihtsalt skill tehtud selle jaoks, et et ole hea,
Õpetaja: et ee, tee haru tee komiit. Mul on isegi ühes jorus. Näed, kuna ma teen taski kaupa taski nimes. Saad haru nime.
Õpetaja: Push ise ära tee, kuna mul Review Tajat ei ole, siis ma. Ma teen Bullrequesti kaudu. Aga ma ütlen, ee, et ee tee kohe merge need kokku. Kustuta ära Harupilvest
Õpetaja: Ee, minema kustutaja. Lokaalselt ka. Põhimõtteliselt mul on. Niimoodi Ma saan taski kaupa teha, justkui selles mõttes, nagu päris arendus ee, välja arvatud seda, et siis tegelikult taga ei ole.
Õpetaja: Ja väga mugav on nagu teeb ära. Ja nüüd eeldus on see, et teil on siis millegiga käivitada, ka
Õpetaja: Ee, ehk siis selles mõttes, et ma teen selle skill I ära Rainile järgi. Mis siis hakkaks toimuma? Ja niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta siis kõigepealt. Ee, vaataks seda.
Õpetaja: Ee, et ee. Kas ta, ee. Kõigepealt ta võtab üldse teie enda haru nime.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et tal on vaja teada teie nime. Ju Noh, me ei tee ju personaalseid.
Õpetaja: Ta võtab praegusest harust. Ee, teie haru nime Sealt ta saab kätte, näiteks. No ma toon See Arturiga näite. Artur Feb. Ee. Mingi Feb. Üks Midagi taolist. See on taaski number.
Õpetaja: Näiteks Ta võtab selle ära, siis ta teab. Vaata, et okei, selle mustri järgi tegemist on. Artur peab olema igal juhul eesliide,
Õpetaja: sest et uus aru vaade, jah, siis mis ta teeks, on See, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ee. Ta läheks kuskile Masteri peale. Näiteks korraks ära.
Õpetaja: Ee, et vabastada lihtsalt see haru, mis on nüüd siis läheb liitimisele
Õpetaja: Selle haru kustutab just ära. See nimi on Tal olemas harunimi. Ta ju võtab selle hetkel kustutab selle vana haru ära ja siis ta läheb ja otsib õpetaja Haru.
Õpetaja: Siis ta vaatab, kas ta leiab Õpetaja Haru. Üks on mul master, aga ma selgita seda. Skill i pannakse Seda, et mitte see õpetaja Master, vaid Minul saab ka olema Õpetaja Sidekriips Feb. Üks midagi taolist peatavatest aru, et minul on arendusharu, Teeme seda sama asja,
Õpetaja: siis ta võtab sellest uue haru. Vanaasi on juba kõik ära kustutatud. Võtab uue haru, teeb checkout. I Ee paneb ilusti teie enda nimelise nime sinna asemele ja teeb uue
Õpetaja: uue haru. Ja tuletegi järgi. Saate aru, väga kiirelt. Saate nagu tulla järgi, aga see Siis loomulikult eeldab seda, et. Noh, mina teen seal igal juhul Ee. Teen seda Cloud is.
Õpetaja: Kas te tahate seda kasutada? Siis teil on ka vaja, Cloud I.
Õpetaja: Aga võibolla ongi aeg nädalavahetusel Cloud endale auto. Nagu ära installida. Käsi püsti, kes kavatseb sel nädalavahetusel ära installida.
Õpetaja: No Väga hea, ee. Sellepärast, et see on ka nüüd teie võimalus siis hakata õppima ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis, ee. Kuna me alustame puhtalt lehelt, siis Ma näitan teile ka seda protsessi.
Õpetaja: Ee, ka seda protsessi näitan teile. Ma panen kõik Closul. Closul Tabs.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd ma hästi natukene flirdin mõttega, et. Ee, meil tegelt. Teil kõigil on vees sell olemas, onju?
Õpetaja: Kuidas me saame teada, et tehke terminal korra lahti ja kui te Tulete selle noolekese peale? Kas teil on see upuntu?
Õpetaja: Okei, Fair Enough. Tehke oma puntu lahti.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, kas. Ee. See asi avaneb mountiga selles projektis. Võibolla peab veidi ootama,
Õpetaja: aga lõpus peaks tulema midagi taolist ta lihtsalt kasutajanimeks. Ma ütlesin mingi taolist. Pange, onju? Siis on midagi taolist veel seal,
Õpetaja: aga see see selleks. Vaata, see versiooni nimi on Savi,
Õpetaja: aga aga käsu rida tuli. Kui te nüüd kirjutate. Claudia, ma ei tea vist, Version on vist sellel. Ma pakun.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis kellaks on meil planeeritud? Paus. Ee, Mis kell teeme pausis? Ma Annan liisile teada Midagi
Õpetaja: Saaksime selleks?
Õpetaja: Jah, kolmteist viisteist.
Õpetaja: Kell üks sobib. Lõunapaus. Täna saame,
Õpetaja: saab. Töötab seal või? Tähendab Kui juba. Siis teeme siis juba kolmteist Viisteist ja tagasi kell kaks
Õpetaja: sobib. Siis sa ei kaota. Saad ka nagu süüa ka, on ju? Aga ma korra ütleks siis selle, mis, Ma ütlesime. Kümme. Kolmkümmend. Vä
Õpetaja: mhmh.
Õpetaja: Nii, kümme. Kolmkümmend, Kui te. Kirjutasite cloud version. Kas teil. Tuli Midagi ette no see? Versiooni number ei pea kattuma. Vaata aga, idee järgi tuli
Õpetaja: nii. Väga hea, et. Ee. Selles mõttes on kõik hästi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Aa. Ma ikkagi sooviksin ka niukest asja, et ee, et ma korra panen chat.
Õpetaja: Mulle meeldib. Ee, ma praegu ei kuuluta Kuigi ma nii kriitiline see hetkel ei olegi.
Õpetaja: Ee, Please, give Cloud, kohe. Cloud E. Cloud.
Õpetaja: Mpm installer. Miks ma seda install? Cloud Code.
Õpetaja: Ee, Võtan nüüd ametlikult lehed selle käsu, Kõik start
Õpetaja: Ei taha seda ei taha. Ei taha Kus on Ee, mõnusam asi
Õpetaja: ei ole. Siin Siis ma ikkagi vaatan korra vanast Chat ist üldse Ee,
Õpetaja: kujutame ka ära.
Õpetaja: Noh, see vestlus on meil varem olnud juba.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma pean meenutama, millega saab ilusti. See
Õpetaja: Tehke kir. Pange Windowsi nuppu, kui te kirjutate.
Õpetaja: See tuleb kitiga kaasa. Kas teil on siuke asi olemas?
Õpetaja: Tavaliselt ootame vahepeal ka läbi.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis ee.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd, Ee, nüüd Tehke korra. Slack, lahti.
Õpetaja: Käsi püsti, kellel ei ole veel Slaki arvutis, vaid on läbi. Browser I.
Õpetaja: No jaa, niukest inimest läheme.
Õpetaja: Minge nüüd. Ee. Sinna. Slaki. Korra ja võtke see käsk.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma räägin, mida see teeb.
Õpetaja: Algselt oli, niimoodi et läbi ainult oli tõesti võimalik seda Cloud I installida.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on mingisugune uus variant, et ta põhimõtteliselt Install Ib. Selle Windows Isse, aga mitte päris Seal taga On midagi veel.
Õpetaja: Ee, ja selline Instal nagu toetab. Ee,
Õpetaja: mingisuguseid. Aa, nad ise ütlevad, et see toetab mingisuguseid funktsionaalsust, aga mitte päris kõike, Võibolla, aga nüüd on. Kain ta natukene nagu kahtepidi. Vaata, et see Cloud, mis on seal. Ee, seal Linuxis
Õpetaja: teeb mõningaid asju päris hästi Siiamaani Ma olen toimetanud peaaegu eranditult selle Selle Cloudiga, mis läheb üldse mitte? Ma ei ole näinud takistusi ja jällegi mõned asjad seal töötavad paremini,
Õpetaja: et nagu mingisugune. Natukene. Nagu Miks ta olukord on, et me saame nagu vajadusel siis Switch Ida ja kasutada, et kas, ta jookseb Windows või ta jookseb. Vaata aga, meil on Cloud Mõlemas olemas. See installib teile nüüd. Cloud I Lööge, see käsk läbi onju? See installib Teil, Cloud I ja siis põhimõtteliselt Command
Õpetaja: ee terminali. Oota, teeme katse. Kes praegu keegi veel ei ole jõudnud seda vajutada. Keegi teist.
Õpetaja: Kõik Vajutasid juba. Okei, väga hea. Ee, ole hea korra. Mine. Command Prompt ja ta tegore nagu samamoodi. Üks terminal lahti, Command Prompt
Õpetaja: ja kirjuta. Ma lihtsalt tahan näha, kuidas ta nüüd näitab, Kui sa paned siia Cloud Version,
Õpetaja: mis ta ütleb sulle, kas ta ütleb või midagi taolist ütleb, onju
Õpetaja: nii? Ee, ehk siis nüüd. Kui te nüüd installite selle ära
Õpetaja: siis peaks näitama ka seda, et ka Windows is läbi on võimalik. Saada Cloud I. Need on nüüd erinevad. Instantsid selles mõttes. Üks on nagu selles virtuaalses serveris Ee Cloud, mis on teine, on nagu päris Windows.
Õpetaja: Ja ma ütlen, ka et ma ei ole ma. Ma. Mul on tundunud, et enamus asjad töötavad siin väga hästi ja mingid asjad Just töötavad siin. Mis? Selles teises nagu ei tööta. Ee, need mõned kultuurid.
Õpetaja: Ja siin on üks kindel fetuur, mida ma kõige rohkem Nagu tahaks, et te saaksite ka tööle, kui vajab.
Õpetaja: Ee, kas te Installisite ära või? Ta teeb seal midagi veel?
Õpetaja: Kui kellegil on lõpuks läbi, siis tehke samamoodi. Tehke lihtsalt. Aa, Võibolla vaja. Art ja restart I, et teil ei ole niikuinii Cloud Coodi kohe. Vaja, Aa, et Te saate proovida seda sama asja, et kui te võtate
Õpetaja: kuidas
Õpetaja: praegu ei tööta. Ma arvan, et siin on arvuti restart ka potentsiaalselt vaja. Ee, aga ärge seda praegu tehke.
Õpetaja: Vot videos.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, mis asja nüüd tahate teha ka päris tavalise terminali lahti? Lihtsalt, ee. Ja proovida sealt,
Õpetaja: Ah kurat, on Näiteks Cloud ise. Ma ei soovi kindlasti
Õpetaja: nii Spash I ja sealt instalida jah,
Õpetaja: kui mingi Warning on siis või ignoring, Aga ma korra piilun.
Õpetaja: Jah, no päeva lõpuks on see, et ma ütlen, et vahetunni ajal võite proovida arutelile restartida ja ma, arvan, et Seal on see konks. Ma ei ole kindel. Ma ei ole kindel, aga kas ta installib igal juhul ära nii või naa,
Õpetaja: aga liigume nüüd korra edasi sellepärast, et te niikuinii seda ei kasuta. Praegult, onju ja. Ja muretseda pole vaja. Vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga ma lihtsalt tahtsin Teil, Noh, teil vees sellis on niikuinii juba olemas. Te kõik saate teha, lahti kenasti terminali võtta selle ja seal töötab ju, kui Cloud Version tuli ette, et teil on üks versioon, kus töötab Siin ei ole mingisuguseid vahesid selles mõttes.
Õpetaja: Aga mis vahe? Nagu, mis te nagu Järgmisena peate tegema. See on siis lihtsalt õpetus selleks päevaks. Kui te olete kodus, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, on siis? Ee,
Õpetaja: ma olen. Ma panen korra praegult kõik kinni, muidu mul läheb siin nii palju. Neid on ees.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma korra vaatan. Ee, teen korra. Lihtsalt ühe väikse liigutuse.
Õpetaja: Ma Võtan selle Cloud Code endale Siia, ette. Cloud. Cloud Cloud. Nii, ee, mi. Mida ma teen nüüd?
Õpetaja: Ee, et ma saaks teha loo kinni.
Õpetaja: Nii Ee, kujutame ette, et ma olen projekti lahti teinud. Ee, kas siis Wsl või mis iganes, onju ma kirjutan, siis te see on nii? See on teie alg algpunkt. Vaata, on see, et te olete väl. Te olete nagu.
Õpetaja: Kas ta nüüd logis mind üldse välja Vä Jah, et ma login sisse, Cloud. Nüüd hakkab niimoodi Nagu peale esimest korda, kui teil on päriselt Cloud olemas. No te saate praegu ka ka proovida. Justkui Vaata, Cloud on teil olemas? Ega teil login Ei tööta? Kui teil pole It, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, esimesel korral ta Siis küsib ka, et Ee. Kuidas sa tahad seda näha? Tark mode? Loomulikult
Õpetaja: näed. Nüüd ongi see, et ma kuna ma ei ole sisse logitud, siis ta ütleb, et kuule, sa ei saa seda ennem kasutada. Kui sul on üks nendest plaanidest.
Õpetaja: Ee, või siis, noh, ma ei tea, mis nad ülejäänud on Aga loomulikult see pro on siis see Kakskümmend kaks Euri koos maksuga.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: siis peale seda, mis ta teeb, Ta avab siis päriselt veebibrauseri Seal on juba mõistlik et, olete juba sisse logitud avada Sinna cloud. Punkt ai.
Õpetaja: Teete. Subscription I Logite Ennast sisse soovitan Kasutada. Google. Seda Sain inni. Vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja ta küsib lihtsalt, et. Kas sa oled nõus? Ee, seda Connect Ima,
Õpetaja: oota Rais. Ja ma nüüd pean saama ühe mingisuguse koodi. Minu meelest vähemalt vanasti see nii oli, kui sa pole muutunud, ah, isegi veel lihtsamaks on. Läinud Vahel on niimoodi, et Ee, ta viib sinna lehele ja annab mingisuguse pika. Mingisuguse koodijada, mida pead Copy Based Ima Vaata,
Õpetaja: vahel ta kuidagi. Sa oled juba sisse logitud. Aga ta kuidagi kaotab ära. Nagu selle Või see aegub. See login.
Õpetaja: Praegu ei pidanud midagi tegema, Ju Näed, Rain tüür? Sellepärast, et Brauseris. Ma olin juba sisse logitud.
Õpetaja: Ja kui tuleb mingit midagi muud, siis lihtsalt Teed Follow the Instructions
Õpetaja: ta. Ta viskab siia konsooli. Vaata mingisuguse lingi. Ee, ütleb, et Pane ava selle ka. Brauser. Teed Browseri lahti ja siis seal tuleb ette Mingisugune kood. Mida, Mida tema siis justkui küsib sealt? Vaata, et anna mulle ja ongi Connected. Üldiselt sellega ei ole nagu mingisuguseid probleeme
Õpetaja: nii Ja siis on kõik. Põhimõtteliselt oletegi. Oletegi sees, Kui subscription on tehtud
Õpetaja: ja ma teen siis nädalavahetusel selle selle Skill I, teen ka ära, et siis, need, kes tahavad, saavad seda kasutada.
Õpetaja: Ee, nii, ee, kõik on olemas. Mina nüüd tahan lihtsalt Cloud Ita, et ta teeks meile materjale.
Õpetaja: Skill loo uus õppematerjal.
Õpetaja: Millisel teemal soovid uut materjali?
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: voe aa, Ma panen spa ja voe kuue. Kolm.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: räägi, Ee,
Õpetaja: ma Ütlen mind hästi. Üli nagu. Mis? Ee, mis asjad need on? Ma panen niimoodi. Ma tahan, et hästi üldiselt teeks, mis asjad. Need on,
Õpetaja: Jah, vaata, mis ta räägib, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, single Page Application stiil, on selge? Noh,
Õpetaja: et siis teile ka meelde tuletuks, et et kui te Olete minuga samal joonel. Nüüd te olete samal joonel, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ma Tegin ju bussi ka, on ju? Teil on ju. Kui te vaatate Indeks saate meeldi, siis ta peaks nägema Niukene Normaalne välja nagu. Mitte väga suur
Õpetaja: senikaua, kuni tema seda teeb, siis ma natukene räägin,
Õpetaja: Kui Te vaatate indeks Html I. Siis arvestage, et see ongi nüüd see oranž.
Õpetaja: See on kogu kogu leht. Toob sul kogu leht. Vahet pole, Mis vaatel oled?
Õpetaja: Kui Me Vaatame? Body osa on nagu. Üsna nagu tühi
Õpetaja: Siin on ainult mingi divid. Ee, äpp on nii äpp
Õpetaja: ja Siis on mingi script. Mingi mis iganes
Õpetaja: see osa nüüd põhimõtteliselt viitab, et kogu see body osa tuleb nüüd siuksest failist nagu upvoe Näete seda. Siin.
Õpetaja: Ja ühtlasi ta viitab. Aa, kus on ka ühtteist kirjas?
Õpetaja: Ee, siin sellest ma räägin natukene hiljem, aga põhiliselt me tahame hakata rääkima. Nagu sellest
Õpetaja: Ehk siis, ee. See tähendab niimoodi. Et. Ee, kui me jätame selle siia niimoodi vasakule poole.
Õpetaja: See on kogu lehekülg, aga Nüüd ta ütleb, et palun, saa sina ülejäänud osa failist nimega Up.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Mis on siin tähtis, et, ee, meil on siin selline asi Nagu templeid.
Õpetaja: Aa, mis ta skripti Ana üles saab, onju? Mulle küll ei meeldi niisugune asi.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma teeks ühe muudatuse. Te võiksite ka selle teha. Tehke see hapua lahti
Õpetaja: ja tõstame script i bloki hoopis template alla
Õpetaja: Ja näete siin all see ülevalt. Kolm rida vist oli. Leidsite. Ma tegin. Ma võtan sammud tagasi. Endal
Õpetaja: näete seda osa. Control X on ju?
Õpetaja: Control Iks, Võta siit ära
Õpetaja: ja tule. Tulge otsige, Kui see template teab, te võite selle template korra kinni tõmmata.
Õpetaja: Kui sa vaatad templet, võiks olla nagu esimene rida,
Õpetaja: siis võibolla üks rida vahet ja.
Õpetaja: Ja see script siia panna. Ja see Style Block Style Block on niimoodi. Kuhu saab panna, saab põhimõtteliselt Css sätteid teha ja Siis need kohalduvad ainult sellele komponendile.
Õpetaja: Aga me tahame kasutada globaalseid kompo Ee Css Sätteid et igal pool, et meil ei ole nagu styleblokki vaja.
Õpetaja: Stai Bloki saab vastutused ära, eks?
Õpetaja: Ja et lõppkokkuvõttes teil peaks olema Niimoodi
Õpetaja: Ma teeks. Ee, selle teeks nagu veits. Ee, teistmoodi Nii,
Õpetaja: No mina hakkan rääkima. Kõigepealt Template Template Block
Õpetaja: on see osa, kuhu läheb Hdml?
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt, nagu me ennem tegime Body. Vaata, oli Body sees toimetas. Me kirjutasime. Vaatame veel koodi.
Õpetaja: Siin Selles templeti sees ei saa kirjutada. Jaavascript I.
Õpetaja: See on puhtalt mõeldud Ee, selles mõttes see on Puhtalt mõeldud. Ee, siis Html i jaoks.
Õpetaja: Et siia tuleb siis input. Siia tuleb. Ee, Div siia. Tuleb. Mida iganes neid need käivad siia,
Õpetaja: Siis Aa, script. I hakkab tulema. Java script. Ee, räägime sellest natukene hiljem.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Ee, mõned asjad.
Õpetaja: See selline element nagu template see on Voe enda oma.
Õpetaja: See on vahe enda oma. Ee, See tähendab seda, et seda Html is ei ole nagu lõpp Html is.
Õpetaja: Kui tema Paneb põhimõtteliselt kokku kogu lehe, et, ee. Näed, et põhimõtteliselt kõik see kõik osa genereeritakse siia Body vahele, Põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: tema esimese raksuna tuleb siia Ja vaatab, et. Hei, mis templeid peaks siia asemele tulema, Ma võiks? Nagu mõttes Ma võin seda korra teha. Vaata, ma teen komite ära, Siis on, ee. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: võtan korra Working progress. Üks commit
Õpetaja: ilma sisulise infota, et seda te võite ka enda praegult mõelda. Niimoodi ärge kaasa Tehke et kõik, mis on siin,
Õpetaja: on tegelikult justkui siin.
Õpetaja: Kas te saate mõttest aru nii Väga hea?
Õpetaja: Okei.
Õpetaja: Me oleme korra selle kinni. Keskendume sellele.
Õpetaja: Kui me hakkame seda vaatama, siis. Ee. Siin on mõned reeglid.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui lõpus see. Kogu see asi pannakse kokku niiöelda. Ee, Kui see lõpuks see läheb sinna. Aa, oota, Ma tegin tegelikult natukene valesti. Jah, Source Code Mõttes.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma teen korra uuesti selle indeks Html I lahti. Ee, source mõttes tõesti. Me võiksime justkui mõelda. Vaata, et tõstetakse see kogu blokk
Õpetaja: siia selle divid äpp asemele, Aga nagu lõppversioonis.
Õpetaja: Mis meil on, siis Tegelikult võetakse ainult see vaheline osa,
Õpetaja: et kuskil Html is lõpptulemuses nagu need, nagu kustutatakse ära,
Õpetaja: kas see on Selge või on arusaadavam, kuidas?
Õpetaja: Ei, see on? Kõik. Ei, siin ongi. Siin ongi link. See ongi link. See. See ongi link. Vaata et Hei, siia tuleb
Õpetaja: praegult faili Up Voe asjad selle, okei?
Õpetaja: Ei, no praegult. See on see. See osa. Siin on hästi erandlik olukord üldse Vaata, et kuskil rohkem sellist süntaksit enam me ei näe. See on lihtsalt nagu see stardipauk. Põhimõtteliselt edaspidi on natukene teine süsteem, Sellest saate varsti juba aru. Ma kohe räägin ka.
Õpetaja: Näe, aga mis ma tahan Nagu aru. Saate aru, et. Et see, iga kord kui te mõtlete seda templeit. Siis lihtsalt mõelge seda, et seda lõppkoolis ei ole.
Õpetaja: Need on nähtamatud.
Õpetaja: Need on selles mõttes meile jäetud võimalused. Me saame igast asju teha. Me saame mujal ka templateid kasutada, aga lihtsalt igas. Igas vaates või vaatekomponendis. Esimene template on siis põhimõtteliselt see renderdatav osa, see On kõige tähtsam asi, et siia Java Script ei kirjuta. Siia ei saa kirjutada. Javascript I. Javascripti jaoks on. Näete, siin Script. Aeg
Õpetaja: saab halb mujal kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Template osa on nähtav osa. See on põhiline asi
Õpetaja: ja ma ütlen, et põhimõtteliselt nagu lõppkoodi mõttes, võib justkui mõelda nagu Umbes niimoodi, et see osa siit.
Õpetaja: Oota, Üks asi. Jäi vaheta ära. See osa siit kanda tuleb siia asemele.
Õpetaja: No kui me, mõtleme, et Kuidas seda asja kokku paneb?
Õpetaja: Dünaamilised. Okei,
Õpetaja: no nüüd ongi lihtsam roll. Back ida.
Õpetaja: Nii, okei, väga hea.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd kui me hakkame siit ülevalt tulema vaatama. Nüüd siin see asi. Siin on. Navigation part.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on võetud niuksest kohast Ja nüüd see on kaastegemise koht
Õpetaja: Pange Googlesse. Niisugune sõna nagu Bood Strap. Cs. Ss
Õpetaja: ka Lihtsalt peaks tegelikult viima vaikimisi sellele lehele. Aga see Ccss aitab teda.
Õpetaja: Mis asi on Bootstrap, Sss.
Õpetaja: Kõige populaarsem hate. Meil Css ja Javascript Library hinde.
Õpetaja: Mis ta sinna seal reklaamilehel tahaks öelda? Kindlasti In the world vaata midagi taolist, millega on tegemist.
Õpetaja: No vaade. See on vaatamise koht Praegu selle. Oota selle lehe. Te võite ühe asja. Muidugi, ei, pärast teeb Ee, Tulge, olge lihtsalt korra vaatamise režiimis.
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen Button,
Õpetaja: siis siin on erinevad nupud, mis on juba ära lahendatud, et kui tuleb peale, Kuidas ta niimoodi highlight Ib? Erinevad värvid. Näete niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ma lähen siia alla. Näiteks, et on niuksed lingid.
Õpetaja: Minu lemmikud on niuksed, kuna kuidagi Visuaalselt on kohe näha, kui peale lähed.
Õpetaja: Suured patonid, Väiksed patonid, suured koerad, väiksed koerad. Okei, te ei tea seda laulu niikuinii,
Õpetaja: et ee, See raamistik on näiteks, et kui ma soovin
Õpetaja: mõnda tabelit näiteks kasutada. Mäletate, kui me tegime oma tabelit? Siis alguses polnud isegi mingeid raame Ega midagi.
Õpetaja: Siit saab põhimõtteliselt võtta niukseid valmis. Css lahendusi. Kogu see Css on meil juba praegu arvutisse siin arvutisse. Vabandust, projekti ära installitud, Kui vaadata korra paket Station It,
Õpetaja: siis ma näitan kohe. See.
Õpetaja: See.
Õpetaja: Need kaks rida on seotud.
Õpetaja: Meil on olemas need Cs säted, mida me millele me saame viidata? Et siis kuidas see töötab? On see Võibolla see patal korra on lihtsam näide sellepärast, et see on hästi Visuaalne.
Õpetaja: Ma küsin teie käest, et kui mina sooviksin niukest Aa rohelist nuppu.
Õpetaja: Missuguse Html Näidise rea. Ma peaksid siit ee alt kopeerima. Endale.
Õpetaja: Jah, nüüd ma saaksin seda copida. Aga tegelikult, mis mind huvitab, on ainult see osa siin.
Õpetaja: Näete Anna Sellele Patonile palun.
Õpetaja: Patoni et ta, üldse On Button
Õpetaja: üldse, et tal on nagu ümarad ääred randid varjud, mida iganes,
Õpetaja: Ja siis. See järgmine. See on nüüd kaskaadimine, Vaata, me Seda ei jõudnudki kahjuks vaadata, et tühikuga eraldada. Sa saad laps. Sa saad nii palju, viiteid panna erinevatele stiilidele. Sa Mixid ja Matchid kokku, See ütleb, et anna talle funktsionaalsus, kujundus ja kõik Mingi muu on ju, et Niukene ilus ja lahe onju. See ütleb, et põhimõtteliselt sa Ütled, et see oleks roheline.
Õpetaja: Mõtle selge, ma toon ühe teise näite ka. Mis on ka veel nagu sama lihtne, nagu aru saada Alert.
Õpetaja: Vaatan, kas siin on nupp. Ka. Ballert on. See tuleb ette kuskile saate aru,
Õpetaja: Noh, väike alert. Lihtsalt kuskil. Keegi tahab sisse logida
Õpetaja: või midagi valesti ütleb, et täida kõik väljad või mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Siin on samamoodi. Palun väga
Õpetaja: üks lihtne alert. Sinine punane mis iganes kui mina Tahaksin siukest alerti saada. Mis oleks Punane Simple Tanger Alert.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis? Ma siit kop ima peaksin.
Õpetaja: Neljana, onju Jah, et siis niimoodi saate ma tast. Aru
Õpetaja: See on juba varasemalt ära lahendatud.
Õpetaja: Ee, see tähendab seda. Kus te näete üldse seda? Hiljem Ka niukest. Mõned teised tehnoloogiad Samamoodi kasutavad ideeliselt, et see on
Õpetaja: jälle mingi boot. Seal mõte on see, et sa oled hästi kiirelt kuidagi mingi standardlahendustega liikvele ja saad mingi lahendusi kasutada nagu mingi klotse ja asju ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Aa, see on põhimõtteliselt siis selle mõte. Aa, seda on siis väga mõnus kasutada, et saada kiirelt midagi püsti ja hakkad toimetama. Sest et sa ei pea hakkama seal mingi kujunduslikke asju mõtlema nagu vaata, on ju siin. On lahendused nii stiilidele kui ka layout, idele ja muudele asjadele.
Õpetaja: Miks ma sellele viitasin, on seda, et, ee, siis ee, navigatsiooni baar Kui Te panete oma serveri käima,
Õpetaja: te panete oma serveri käima ja tulete lehele. Te peaksite midagi taolist nägema.
Õpetaja: Ee, vanasti tuli vaikimisi navigatsiooni Menüü. Aa, vabandust, Aa. Kui te teete uue projekti, See on käsu, real üks käsk. Lihtsalt voe mingi projekti nimi ette ja teeb kõik Nagu algseadistused asjad ära. Projekt on nagu
Õpetaja: siis seal. Enam ei ole. Navigatsiooni menüüd. Vanasti Nendel näites oli ka juba navigatsiooni menüü. Mina siis Seekord võtsin ise. Lihtsalt. Ee. Põhimõtteliselt ütles, et anna mulle mingi mingi navigation.
Õpetaja: Ee, mingid sätted. Ee. Pane korra navigation.
Õpetaja: Äkki midagi taolist Näete? Seda. Siin
Õpetaja: Noh, see on see sama vaata põhimõtteliselt ainult, et minul on ta must,
Õpetaja: on nii, No siin on kuskil näide arvatavasti ka, et kui tahad värvi muuta või midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Noh, on nii.
Õpetaja: Ma võtsin midagi taolist,
Õpetaja: et et te saaksite aru, et see on nagu, sealt tulnud. Näed, see on kõik, et sealt Highlight Id, siis ta nagu ilusti varjutab. Ja mis iganes saate ma saan aru,
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd Niukene asi on väga mõnus kasutada mingi kooliprojektid sõpte projektis alguseks. Admin pool
Õpetaja: Aa, Miks võibolla mitte, nagu ei ole nagu nii fun. Seda kasutada Mingis. Aa ütleme niimoodi lahedas. Aa, veebilehel
Õpetaja: mis? Mis probleem selle kasutamisega on?
Õpetaja: Jah, ta näeb nagu ta näeb nagu iga teine leht Nagu ma ilmselt siis vaata, onju? Või? Noh, aga siis ongi täpselt see, et, noh, mis on nagu, tähtis. Vaata, onju ja keegi ei Ütle, et ei saa seda ka pärast nagu ise. Nagu tuunida. Mäletate, Cssi saab nagu Overwrightida.
Õpetaja: Saad oma oma klass ja muu, et see Võib ka olla lähtepunkt, et et sa saad selle põhiasja paika. Vaata ja sa saad. Seda värve asja ikkagi nagu et enamus, ikkagi suudavad lõpus sellest, nagu teha midagi. Noh, teistsugust, kes tahavad. Vaata, onju midagi ägedat, aga sellega saab hästi kiirelt liikuda. Edasi, see on see, pluss
Õpetaja: On veel, ee, natuke teistsuguse lähenemisega sarnane. Näiteks
Õpetaja: seal on natuke teistsugune süsteem, et sa ei ütle, et Nagu Patt on ja patt, onju, Aga seal on nagu mingisugused seadistused. Et anna mulle siin kumevus ja anna mulle mingid varjundid ja midagi taolist, vaata onju? Natuke Rohkem custom, Aga Ei, ole enam nii loetav. Me kasutame oma projektidest. Kasutage ka, sest et sellega saab teha kiiret.
Õpetaja: Ja see ma ütlengi, et see ei tähenda nüüd niimoodi, et ei saa üldse lehele oma näost anda. Kui sa. Paned ikka ägedad mingid taustapildid ja asjad ja nagu mõtled Läbi oma asjadega
Õpetaja: Mul on. Mul on. Mul on alati siin gruppides olnud alati mingi meeskond, kes paneb nagu, väga palju rõhku disainile, nagu visuaalsele disainile. Ja siis ongi vahel niimoodi, et keegi on olnud meeskonnas, kes lihtsalt tunneb nii huvi Kunstiline Anne vaata, on kellegil, nagu ta oskab kuidagi mõelda. Mina ei oska. See on üks asi, mida ma ei oska teha.
Õpetaja: Ma ei oska teha nagu midagi ägedat, nagu, nagu Ilusat nagu. Nagu mingi kihvt, et mingi mingi lahedad värvid ja mingi kuidagi nagu mõnus disain. Nagu seda mina, näiteks ei oska,
Õpetaja: sest et See on kunstiline pool. Vaata, mul ei ole nagu niukest
Õpetaja: Ee, oskust. Aga see on siis põhimõtteliselt üks kõige lihtsamaid mooduseid ja me kasutame läbi kogu aeg.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, et panna favorid siia alla, Siis läheme juba põhimõtteliselt sellele lehele, mida ta võibolla kõige tihedamalt. Ee, hakkate sa komponent Mida te hakkad kasutama?
Õpetaja: Kirjutage siia sisse. Greet Searching Mis on Greed?
Õpetaja: Ruudustik.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, siia. Me hakkame kõige rohkem tulema, Seega see on See koht, kus on siis Ee, mis teil versiooni number on? Ta võib mulle panna automaatselt midagi, mis on mälus. Sama väga hea, siis Näete, mul juba näitab, et ta ei luba isegi veel ad ida. Seda vaid ütleb. Näete seda Shirt I siin. Jah,
Õpetaja: ee, et pange see endale, Palun, ära. Te tulete siia uuesti ja uuesti ja just siia. Sellesse eksemplisse tulen ma kõige rohkem
Õpetaja: Pange see niimoodi ära. Vajutage Seda pange ka endale ka bookmarks baari peale üldse. Soovitan, et teil lõpuks oleks. Sama setup. Vaata, et teil on kaheksakümmend Üks
Õpetaja: ee, üks teine link, mille te saate hiljem ja Bootstrap. Vaid padlet võiks ka olla Nii,
Õpetaja: mida see meile pakub, on see, et, ee,
Õpetaja: me saame teha layout. I
Õpetaja: Me saame teha Aa, layout. I Selles mõttes, niimoodi et me saame öelda. Me saame suht lihtsa vaeva, Vaatame korra seda koodi, Sest see näide on üks rida. Kolm veergu.
Õpetaja: Näete, Div Row, mis lõppeb siin Tema Sees on üks kolumn.
Õpetaja: Teine kolumn. Neljas kolumn.
Õpetaja: Vabandust, neljas. Ma nagu oma väike tipp. Vaata, tal Kuidagi on Üheksaga on error. Praegu hetkel ütleb seitse, kaheksa, kaheksa, kümme
Õpetaja: ee, tabab nii Ee, et meil on nagu Row. Ja mis on täiesti tavaline Div muidu. Aga mis tal siin sees Classis on?
Õpetaja: Rau, Täiesti tavaline, nähtamatu tüüv. Aga Glass Kolm
Õpetaja: Call call. Saate setup ist aru?
Õpetaja: Sellega on väga mugav manageerida oma ee lehekülje üldist layout. I
Õpetaja: Noh, sellega saaks isegi tabelit teha. Ida järgi vaata, kui tahad.
Õpetaja: Ja. No siin on näited ka, et kui tuled alla, et soovid mingit niukest asja teha Ja,
Õpetaja: noh,
Õpetaja: mingid erinevad näited on siin ka. Saad siin mingi asju natukene mängida? Vahet pole, sellega On võimalik teha nagu enda lehekülje. Niuke Ruudustik Layout,
Õpetaja: Et nagu, noh, kuidas? Sa nagu soovid, et asjad oleksid
Õpetaja: Ee, sisse on ehitatud mingi Mobile friend lines ka
Õpetaja: selles mõttes, et Ta suht hästi, nagu mis iganes tal näeb nagu suurel ekraanil välja. Kui te koguaeg kasutate, siis nad näevad ka suht okeid,
Õpetaja: ee, mobiilis välja.
Õpetaja: Ee, tuletan meelde. Me ei ole Mobile First Arendusega ei tegele siin. See on eraldi kursus.
Õpetaja: Noh, see on nagu värk. Vaata siis Kui tahad. Ee, hästi mobiilisõbralik, siis seal ikka. Pead juba natuke rohkem panema. Igasuguseid ekraani vahemikke.
Õpetaja: No kuidas sellest aru saada? No kui ma Teen kasvõi selle sama lehe siit lahti. Inspektiga
Õpetaja: Näete üleval Siin Ee Dimensions Responsive. Kui ma panen näiteks iphone kaksteist pro
Õpetaja: siis tal on Mingi kindel ekraani laius.
Õpetaja: Kui ma võtaks Ee, ipad Pro
Õpetaja: on juba teistsugune. Ühtlasi saab orientatsiooni ka muuta, onju,
Õpetaja: et kuidas need, asjad käivad Css ides. Tegelikult on niuksed. Vahemikud. Taastub Mingi, kaks, kolm vahemikku.
Õpetaja: Kõik ekraanid, mis on vähemalt laius. Tuhat Kakskümmend neli. Ee pikslit on ju Siis kehtivad mingid niuksed säted,
Õpetaja: et see on nagu kuidagi ära automatiseeritud. Ee. Neti. Ma ütlen, et Boks töötab ta ka enamvähem päris hästi,
Õpetaja: Okei, hakkab olema põhiline koht, kuhu me tuleme. Hetkel me tegelikult ei olegi midagi. Kuidas me tuleme? Iga kord on see, et me tuleme Kopime Põmm,
Õpetaja: mis annab meile lihtsalt teksti.
Õpetaja: Need neid varjundeid asju pole. Vaata, saate aru On ju, et nagu see, on siin tehtud, et Me saaksime lihtsalt aru. Tegelt on lihtsalt tekst. Kolum, kolum, Kolum. Kui me võtaks selle koodi.
Õpetaja: No ma võin võtta korra selle koodi
Õpetaja: ee, Kui ma valid kogu teksti, siis kasutab seda nuppu. Parem copy. See on vaatamise koht. Korra ma tulen, võtan selle template.
Õpetaja: Ee, kogu see Osa lihtsalt
Õpetaja: kogu värgi. Lihtsalt, Noh, paneme niimoodi korraks. Ma tulen vaatan seda lehekülge. Siis on kolum. Kolum, kolum,
Õpetaja: et see on mõtteline nagu Selles mõttes. Ja siis ma saan igasuguseid asju teha, et kustutan siit ühe kolumni ära nagu, Noh, siis on nii,
Õpetaja: tahan teha, et on Kaks raud ajal on kolm kolumit.
Õpetaja: Noh, saate aru, see on lihtsalt nagu.
Õpetaja: Ja see. See tähendab seda, et alati Niukene siin on Niuke, Pea nagu div konteiner. Siis peab tulema Ja siis tuleb koll. Ja nüüd on nagu enda fantaasia. Kuidas soovid neid asju sättida?
Õpetaja: Küsimusi
Õpetaja: ei, No praat ei ole, sest seda praegu ei ole, mees.
Õpetaja: Ja kui sa ongi see, et kui ma tahaksin, et siin on mul tuleb Mingisugune tabel või? Tuleb ee, mingi pilt või? Noh, kõige jaoks on ka teed Elemente. Topid siia. Vaata, onju? Tuleb See teksti paragrahv või
Õpetaja: Ja nii edasi. Laiused, asjad. Ee, kuidas neid asju, nagu saab Timmida Siis kui me hakkame päris ee seda tegema, et siis, ee, siis Näitan kõike. Vaata, et kuidas. Nagu
Õpetaja: et vaikimisi kõik on. Ee, ütleme. Nii, et asjad on kas keskel või vasakul? Vaata siis siin kõike saab Timmida.
Õpetaja: Meil tuleb ka Niukene süsteem, et kogu maksta saadav laius.
Õpetaja: Kogu mu maks saadav laius. Vaata, on ütleme nagu sellel lehel. Ahah, Okei, üks asi, mida võiks veel ära teha. Keegi oleks klassiruumist välja. Ma räägin,
Õpetaja: ma praet ei tee. Tuletan mulle meelde. Voe dev tools,
Õpetaja: Kuidas siis teha midagi, et sa tahad? Väärtus tuleb kusagil mujal.
Õpetaja: Ei saa nagu seda sulle praegu rääkida ja kui sinna veel natuke. Läheb Maad
Õpetaja: ee. Saad, et ta mõtled seda, et ei ole.
Õpetaja: No jah, mis, Ee veebileht see oleks. Vaata, kui ei. No mingid asjad on Okei ju, vaata, mingid. Noh, mingid pealkirjad, laibed Ja asjad. Vaata aga nagu, et, noh, tabeliandmed peavad ikkagi ju kuskilt tulema, nagu onju ja Ei, seda ühesõnaga kahjuks kokku ei saa võtta praegult järgneva päeva jooksul. Äkki.
Õpetaja: Aa, juba varsti. Juba varsti juba Varsti Ee, Okei,
Õpetaja: nii ma Roll Back in selle ka endal. Kas ikka saab ka roll? Back Ida vist. Ee,
Õpetaja: näe seda üldse. Siin on kusjuures Ma ei julgeks seda muidugi kasutada,
Õpetaja: Nii et on see navigatsioon mul tagasi. See Mis siin ees on? On ee. Mingisugune voe enda näide, mis tulebki? Kui Sa teed uue projekti. Kahjuks ma ütlen, Nagu ma ütlesin, Topari pole. Nii, et uus näide on niimoodi et menu on siin vasakul üldse. Nad on vaikimises seda teinud. See mulle üldse endale ei meeldi.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui just ei sooviks teha Kuidagi imelik näide on neil, mis tuleb Algselt veits oli nagu Timmimist.
Õpetaja: Nii kui see nüüd onju, siis hakkame vaatama Nagu, et, ee, Kui siin on esimene asi, on rooterlink
Õpetaja: ja Pank. Ee, nelikümmend.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate, kus see mul siin lehel on?
Õpetaja: No see siin. Ju Siis tuleb. Ee, mingi. Oota, ma vaatan, mis ta siin siis tegelikult. Aa,
Õpetaja: aa, okei, ee. See on nupp, mis ei ole hetkel nähtaval
Õpetaja: seda. Näete. Vana hea hamburger, Dave Tools, Nii kõik Oleme klassiruumis,
Õpetaja: kui mina praegult. Aa, vajutan. Inspekt, teie võite ka vajutada,
Õpetaja: kellel on siin Kõik, Valge ärge elage niimoodi. Pange nüüd ausõna, Siin on mõistlik meie. Leht saab olema valdavalt valge
Õpetaja: Ee On Mõistlikum panna see ee. Tiimina kuidas seda. Saab teha
Õpetaja: ee kuskilt. Ee nagu. Asi Teil on auto või? Light? Vaata siis vastavalt sellele. Mina panen kohe targiks. Ära. Vaata, soovitan teil ka panna.
Õpetaja: Oo, ma paneks korra. Language Paneks hoopis
Õpetaja: uk English, sest et kuupäev on äkki siis kuskil ka teistsugune. Ma ei tea, ma ei tea, mis see muudab savi, Nii saite targiks ära
Õpetaja: kui saanud, siis Ega see mingi maailma lõpp pole.
Õpetaja: Kui te vaatate Siin üleval on mingisugused ee asjad Mingid erinevad Tööriistad. Järjekorda saab tõsta. Nii et selles mõttes nad ei pruugi olla. Samas järjekorras. Aga mida teil kindlasti ei ole, on selline asi
Õpetaja: see Nüüd on Wedev tools.
Õpetaja: Seda tuleb Chrome Extension Ina peale installida.
Õpetaja: Mis te selleks teete?
Õpetaja: Kirjutate Chrome ei pea isegi Extensions kirjutama. Ta tavaliselt vist lubab, aga on mõistlik panna chrome. Extensions
Õpetaja: Ee. Nüüd, ma. Läksin vastse kohta chrome. Web Store On vist see koht kus, saab asju
Õpetaja: See Search on extensions. Selle peale peab minema Lõppkokkuvõttes Te soovite leida seda Extensionsit
Õpetaja: ja siit Searchist?
Õpetaja: Ma ise otsin kõigepealt üles kas ma Dev tuus.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on see.
Õpetaja: Sa nüüd. Ee, siin on kahjuks mingi ka mingi legasi ja beetad. Vaata, et saaks mingi mõnusalt siin, Ee, see, millel ei ole mitte mingisugust Aa juljat ümber ja on neli koma. Üks ja neli koma. Üks on hetkel.
Õpetaja: See on siis See, mida te soovite.
Õpetaja: Vaata, kas siin palju download on ka olnud? Siin. Pole kirjas hiljem kasutajad,
Õpetaja: mil? No minul ei näita, sest mul Install vist vä teil Näitab. Vä.
Õpetaja: Siin samas peale vajutades vä.
Õpetaja: Jah, Ilmselt see on õige.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan korra midagi muud. Vaatame näiteks seda Legacet
Õpetaja: sada tuhat. See on ka vahel kusjuures, kus saada vaadata nagu. Mis on õige asi.
Õpetaja: Seda, mida kolm inimest on download. Ind ei ole õige asi. See, mida on kümme miljonit näiteks. Ta download ind Siis. Ta tundub et, mida enamus nagu download i Arv Ja siis Ta oli just innovatsiooniline.
Õpetaja: Võibolla. Või äkki on mingisugune asi, mis ei ole teinud. Ja seal on mingisugune häkk sees, mis varastab teie krüptoraha ära, kui seda peaks olema. Minul ei ole niikuinii. Nii et
Õpetaja: on mingid, kus osadel on populaarsensuur?
Õpetaja: Kas käsi püsti, Kellel on krüptoraha?
Õpetaja: Ei, Ei, See okei ka. Kui kunagi oli. Kas oli Bitcoin ja müüsid ära siis, kui sada Eurot. Okei, palju sul oli? Bitcoini
Õpetaja: veel on Bitcoini. Mingi tuhatööst, mis tegid rahast. Ära räägi Bitcoin.
Õpetaja: Ee, see mul oli. Nüüd mul on müüsin
Õpetaja: ma siit ja päris kaua, aga ma oleks ka. Näed, tubli
Õpetaja: Jah, ikka tuleb meelde. See vend, kes pizza eest maksis? Kakssada, kolmsada. Ja siis see vend, kes prügimäel, nagu otsib oma seda drive siiamaani enam ei otsi. Ta on see alla. Ta ei viitsinud võidelda enam sellega vist,
Õpetaja: kuidas, Kuidas ka La.
Õpetaja: Võimalik? Jajah, Sest et, ee, ka mingi maailmakuulus Case on samamoodi. Vaata, et kolmt on Vaata, kaks. On ära tehtud ja mingi tohutud inimesed palgatud. Vaata, Kes nagu
Õpetaja: saavad nagu mingi fee. Vaata, kui nad suudavad selle lahti äkkida. Good Luck.
Õpetaja: Ee, Noh, saab ikka tunda rikastele inimestele nagu kaasa Vaata, et nagu ei lähe hästi.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on ikka teeb. Paneb silma särama, et näed. Polegi ainuke õnnetu hing.
Õpetaja: Aa, kui teil on see ära installitud. Võibolla peate Browser I korra kinni panema. Võibolla mitte, kui nüüd on see. Vaata, Te peate tulema nüüd päris lehele. See Ei, tööta igal pool. See töötab ainult Aa, sellisel lehel, kus on voelokaalne server,
Õpetaja: et kui te tulete Localost kaheksakümmend kaheksakümmend üks ja teete Parema klõpsu ja inspekt.
Õpetaja: Te kohe seda voed siin ei näe.
Õpetaja: Tirige see asi nagu nii laiaks, kui saate korraks.
Õpetaja: Ja ta on arvatavasti siin kuskil lõpus.
Õpetaja: Kui ei näe lõpus, Aga näete neid noolekesi, siis siit saate näha ja tirida samamoodi asju kuidagi, no kõige lihtsam on Nagu teha
Õpetaja: tirida niimoodi laiaks ja. Ja tõmmata Tõmmake ka ta kohe esimeseks.
Õpetaja: Fun Story Ee. Noh, ma ei mäleta, millal ma selle avastasin, Tuh, alguses ikka avastasin mingi esimese teise grupi jooksul. Pigem, võibolla teise või kolmanda juures. Ma ei mäleta, mul Ükskord oli mingi random mingi Viies või kuues grupp oli niimoodi. Ma ei olnud ise ka nii palju seda kasutanud.
Õpetaja: Kursus oli põhimõtteliselt läbi ja siis tuli meelde, et Aa by the way Niuke Vaba. Otsus millega, näeb kõike mis, toimub
Õpetaja: ee. Seal, Sees kõigile Meeldib nagu mis. Sa meile seda varem jäänud Mul endal läks ka, mees,
Õpetaja: aga. No nüüd ma olen nagu nii harjunud, et ma. Ei, Kuidas ma panen tootlus
Õpetaja: Ta ongi, see see Tab, mis me siin näeme. See on
Õpetaja: nagu tavakasutaja. Ei tule nagu mingi mässama, et. Oo, mis network. Liiklus mul käib ja mis mul siin konsoolis ikka Näitab. Vaata, kas on mingi viga Ja bla blabla. Arendajad kasutavad seda sisse. Ehitatud. Jumal tänatud,
Õpetaja: aga sa oled. On sul Lokalus kaheksakümmend Kaheksakümmend Üks On sul server püst. Üldse Saad oma arutega kooliharjutiga kooli,
Õpetaja: mis? Ma ei tea, me seda kohe kasutame niikuinii ei Hakka, et selles mõttes nagu ära praad Pead vaeva päris ka kodus. Saad nagu pusida. Vaata, onju või Kui läheb vaja
Õpetaja: nii, ärme nüüd Kuuluta aega. Las ta on olemas. Me. Ma. Kuidas kasutame ja nii edasi Näitan siis, kui on, muutub teema kohaseks niikuinii.
Õpetaja: Ee, aitäh meeldetuletuse eest. Ma seda palusin. Kus me nüüd enne jäime?
Õpetaja: Või nii üldse
Õpetaja: me enne seda Bitcoin ist oleme juba edasi liikunud. Aa me jõime selle ruuterlingi juurde Button I juurde, et see Button on. See on siis see,
Õpetaja: saate aru, on ju? Kui ma lihtsalt tahaks nagu, noh, Ma ju räägin ju seda. Tead, me peame igast reast koodist aru saama. Nüüd, kuidas me Linki Html is teeme ei ole kunagi teinud Ruuter Link on nii?
Õpetaja: Kui te vaatate. Näiteks. Aa, Midagi, mis on näiteks tavaline element ja vaatate midagi, mis on, siin, mis on nagu Mingisugune erinevus, mis siin võiks silma paista nende kahe vahel
Õpetaja: See, noh, versus.
Õpetaja: No see sama patt on, Ma arvan, kogu aeg tuleb ette, mis? Siin, nagu kahel
Õpetaja: värve. No see on meil värv. On meil Rainbow.
Õpetaja: Ei, ma mõtlen, ma mõtlen. Vot täpselt.
Õpetaja: Case I mõtlen, mis Ma see mis ma mõtlen, Case, mis on silmapaistev. Ja vaadake kõik Html I tägid, mis on Html standardis, on väikeste tähtedega
Õpetaja: ja ja Camel. Case ei tehta. Kui üldse, siis.
Õpetaja: Ee, eks ma mõtlen, mul ei tule praegu meeldegi ühtegi elementi, mis oleks liitsõnaga Aga põhiline asi on see
Õpetaja: suure tähega Algab. Ja Camel. Case, vaadake. See asi siin. Routerlink
Õpetaja: Ee on tegelikult nüüd voe. Komponent. Voe Enda komponent
Õpetaja: tuleb kaasa Igaühele ma vajutan kliki. Aa, siis ta kuhugi ei vii. Aga ta tegelikult sisuliselt. Ee, on. Voe asi.
Õpetaja: Me saaksime põhimõtteliselt sama asja teha. Ka niimoodi.
Õpetaja: No mitte päris. Mitte päris vaata, aga te saate aru. Vaata, me html is on A on ju link,
Õpetaja: aga see on Nüüd voe spetsiifiline link, mis mängib selle tehnoloogiaga niimoodi kenasti kokku
Õpetaja: Nüüd edaspidi Kui ka. Meie teeme mingisuguseid komponente, siis meie enda tehtud komponendid on samamoodi. Ee, Camel. Case. Kahe küüruga. Ehk hakkab suure tähega Niimoodi te saate Kohe
Õpetaja: Teil jäävad niimoodi. Te näete silmaga kohe ära, Vaata, Et mis on poe? Komponendid. Vahet pole, kas meie enda omad või mingid sisseehitatud komponendid. Neid väga Palju pole. Mida me kasutaksime,
Õpetaja: seda tegelikult saab kirjutada ka minu meelest täiesti vabalt ka niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ja ta endiselt töötab. No ma proovin.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma korra pean kuhugi minema, et Ee, tulla tagasi.
Õpetaja: Ta töötab mulle isiklikult. Tegelikult meeldis see vanaviis rohkem, aga kuna ta lihtsalt. Ee, nüüd selle näidisena tuleb niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Noh Võibolla ma, Oot, me seda üldse ei jõudnudki vaadata. Mis meil üldse kirjutati? Vaatame korra selle ka üldse ära. Kus see üldse on?
Õpetaja: Kommitsin ära. Äkki Juba vä, mäletad Me ju? Tellisime, et palun materjali, Kus on poematerjal ei olegi
Õpetaja: ma Roll Back Isin. Ära selle vä sissejuhatus, Ee, palun Uuesti uuesti Kogemata roll. Packi siin.
Õpetaja: Aa, sama materjal. Ah jah,
Õpetaja: samad asjad. Samad asjad. Ee, samad sama teema.
Õpetaja: Sa tegid juba materjali valmis, Aga ma kogemata.
Õpetaja: Kust uut asin ära?
Õpetaja: Ah,
Õpetaja: ma ei julge seda öelda. Ee, ma olen näinud seda ma ikka eriti aegajalt kaasa ma Ei, ma ei teema kaupa. Ma ei taha Cloud I asju vaadata, sest seda informatsiooni on seal nii palju niikuinii. Vaata, ma ei tahaks viskama.
Õpetaja: Aga siin seal olen sattunud küll ja olen näinud seda. Vaata, kus ee. Mingisugune tüüp nagu arendas mingisugust asja.
Õpetaja: Mingisugust Noh, rakendust või Mida iganes Pluginat mõnevõrda helde arendas, nagu ja toimetas seal oma projekti kallal.
Õpetaja: Ja ta kirjutas ja kirjutas et põhimõtteliselt, et Cloud Saatis ta Põhimõtteliselt pikalt juba Nagu
Õpetaja: et ta oli timminud seal mingit asja. Vaata ja siis lõpuks Cloud juba vastas talle. Vaata seda, et nüüd sa Nagu sisuliselt. Vaata, et sa nagu üritad. Nagu mingi liiga hullult siin mingisugust asja nagu teha. Vaata, et sul on töötav nagu asi olemas, Nagu et lõpeta see nagu timmimine nagu et
Õpetaja: laut sai pahaseks nagu peale, et nagu, et isegi tema lõpus viskab kopa ette nagu et Sa ei hull, Lihtsalt on see hull.
Õpetaja: Vaene Cloud.
Õpetaja: Ee, jah.
Õpetaja: No see teeb siis uuesti.
Õpetaja: Noh, Nüüd peaks ruttu tulema. Tal on sul info olemas juba. Ja
Õpetaja: Ee, ma panen ruttu. Panen. Ee,
Õpetaja: Ee, Tirin ta siia ja vaatame ka, mis ta siis kirjutas üldse on
Õpetaja: selle ka. Ee, kolm. Mis? Nad on? Veebirakendus, mis laob Brauserisse ainult ühe korra ja seejärel uuendab lehte dünaamilist, ilma, et lehekülg uuesti laetakse päris Hästi ütleb, et ta ei keskendugi failile nii väga nagu mina.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt öeldes kasutajad klikib nupu, siis muutub Aga Browser ei tee uut päringut serverile ka kord
Õpetaja: Traditsioonileht versus spa. Kasutaja klikib. Brauser saadab päringu serverile. Server saadab täiesti uue Htm I lehe faili Brauser laeb kogu lehe uuesti. Kasutaja näeb uut lehte koos vilkumisega.
Õpetaja: Kasuta Single Page Application. Kasutaja klikib ja Avascrip uuendab ainult vajaliku osa Lehest url muutub Url muutub Näiteks tehingu profiil kasutaja näpuud. Vaata kohe ilma vilkumiseta.
Õpetaja: Analoogia televisioon, mees. Youtube Okei. Huvitav traditsioon. Leht on Nagu teler, iga kanali vahetamine uus Saade laeb algusest peale.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma kutsun seda lineaartelevisiooniks.
Õpetaja: Mul on naisel üks sõbranna, kes on nagu siiamaani, nagu vahepeal oma mingi oma tüübiga Kellega ta läks, lahku Võibolla sellepärast läksid lahku, et neil oli lineaartelevisioon.
Õpetaja: Vahel kirjutas, et et täna tuleb mingi hea film.
Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: Ja siis Nagu kirjutasin ka isegi järelvaatamist. Ei ole ju. Vaata järelvaatamist Ei ole,
Õpetaja: et nagu. Kuulge, reklaamid ja asjad. Ai, meile nii, meeldi me läheme, Teeme mingit võileiba.
Õpetaja: Seda oli näha, et nad teavad võile reklaamipausil.
Õpetaja: Traditsioonileht on nagu siis teleriga kanale vahet uus saade laeb algusest peale Single Page Application on ka Youtube. Sa vahetad videot, aga rakendus ise jääb samaks. Laeb ainult uus videosisu. Tegelt ongi nii onju
Õpetaja: millal kasutadespead panga Rakendus, Kus on palju vaateid? Jah, sobib. Blogi, mida otsingumootorid leiavad? Keeruline vajab midagi taolist. Okei, siin on mingid sellised dünaamilised probleemid, ka
Õpetaja: et Kui sa tahad, et ta oleks eraldi tehtud. Ahhaa, Booking Tuhat Kolm Sellepärast tahabki. Tegelikult ma. Arvan,
Õpetaja: Nad soovivad oma search engine, vaata,
Õpetaja: ma Otsin nagu mingit hotelli. Booking pakub seda hotelli midagi taolist. Ma hakkan
Õpetaja: lihtne kontakti. Vorm Aa üle pingutatud. Mida iganes Kuue kolm on raamistik, Millega ehitatakse siukseid rakendusi.
Õpetaja: See aitab sul jagada lehe komponentideks väikesteks korduvkasutajateks tükkideks hoida andmeid ja vaata et sünkroonis automaatselt reaktiivsust hallata navigeerimust ühel Lehel vaire. See on tegelikult ainult üks leht. Vaata ühistud andmeid. Ee, Okei, see on nüüd seda. Me kasutame ka vist seekord
Õpetaja: Aa, ma Ei tea, kuidas ma selles kasutame, aga mõtleme analoogia. Lego,
Õpetaja: Htmlss ja Scripto legoklotsid. Vae kogu Lego komplekt,
Õpetaja: kus klotsid sobivad kokku loogilisel viisil Ja on eelnevalt sorteeritud.
Õpetaja: Ee, põhilised mõtted.
Õpetaja: Komponent. Oota, kui ma korra tahan vaadata hästi kiirelt alla, Mis siin on? Aa,
Õpetaja: ee, jah, okei, Päris lõpuni me ei pane. Vaata Vaatame veel seda ka.
Õpetaja: Komponent on omaette tükk kasutajaliide, Sest nagu üks klots. Ee, okei, ee, ta natuke paneb siin takseid, Mis on juba? Ma ütlen, et selles mõttes mulle ei ole mõtet vaadata.
Õpetaja: Saite mõttes aru, mis asi on single Page Application. No kui ei saanud ennem, siis nüüd saab aru ja võib kodus ka uurida. Pärast
Õpetaja: Ee, hakkame siis kuskilt pihta. Läheme siis siia. Aa, oota. Selgitamise asi, et ma pole jõudnud sellest navigatsiooni menüüst kaugemale. Saime siis aru. Vaata, et. Ee. See on voe enda. Asi.
Õpetaja: See on tavaline. Baton, Siin on Div. Siin on mõned. Kogu see asi praegult siin on Aa navigatsiooni menüü.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd kui me vaatame, meil on navigatsiooni menüü. Aga Siis on küsimus. Nagu. Aga kus kuradi kohas? Kogu see Staff tuleb? Kus see? See on ju Htmel ja on ju sisu ja struktuur,
Õpetaja: et kui vaatan siia, nagu peaksin kilomeetrite viisi olema. Kuskil peaks olema vähemalt sõna. Tooling,
Õpetaja: Ma ütlesin siit Control F Siit failist Control F on failist otsimine.
Õpetaja: Tuuling on Punane ei leia.
Õpetaja: Ilmselt siin pole,
Õpetaja: et kui kogu see osa põhimõtteliselt, mis on siin Templeti Vahel läheb meil sinna sellesse indeks. Atml I.
Õpetaja: Ainult see navigatsiooni menüü osa on sisuliselt, mis tuleb sellest klotsist. Vaadake, kust nüüd, mis Siit välja jääb.
Õpetaja: Pruuterview.
Õpetaja: Rooterview on nüüd see, et. Kuule, anna mulle järgmine, klots. Järgmine komponent. Vastavalt ruudile.
Õpetaja: Mis Ruutu on seda vaadet näita See on. Jälle. See on nüüd ee, voe, enda komponent. Rooterview.
Õpetaja: Kui mina lähen kaldkriips. About
Õpetaja: näen ma niukest asja. Sobib. Vaatamise koht
Õpetaja: see ongi see. Vaata, et kas navigatsiooni menüü on endiselt nähtav on.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et kõik mis ma näen, tuleb ju loomulikult hapus by Default vaikimisi. Ja nüüd on siin niukene asi, et rooterview järgi, et vastavalt rajale näidatakse mulle mingisugust klotsi. See on ise ära automatiseeritud, me Ei, pea ridagi koode kirjutama, niukest lahendust saada.
Õpetaja: Noh, mõned erinevad koodi peab ikka kirjutama.
Õpetaja: Kui ma teen praegu siin paar tublid kaarti vaatame, Mul on siin praegu sisse sõna. Ja mingi suvaline nikoonikene on siin.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate, mis juhtub, kui ma teen niimoodi seitse?
Õpetaja: Vastavalt rajale, laetakse mingi komponent, mis hetkel on ainult niukse suhte lakoonilise sisuga tühjus. Peaaegu seda tuleb uuesti uuesti. Uuesti, Saate aru?
Õpetaja: Ma saan kust iganes kasutada. Seda
Õpetaja: Noh, Teeme. Mingi pulli. Aa,
Õpetaja: noh, saate mõttest aru Sa pead igal pool kasutada Igal pool, kust iganes saad seda kasutada. Ma Ei, ma ei Projektis Ei, kasuta seda rohkem kui ainult seesama koht, mis siin on. Muidugi Loomulikult, aga kui tahaks
Õpetaja: vastavalt teekonnale, uva mulle Mingeid komponente.
Õpetaja: Kui ma korra teen inspekti lahti ja tulen siia voesse,
Õpetaja: siis tema näitab, et. Ee. Sul on Rooterview. Kus on mingid lingid
Õpetaja: Ruterview. Teist korda näete About About
Õpetaja: Ja siis on päriselt see paut. Mis on siis see osa, nagu
Õpetaja: see on siin ka on topelt niimoodi, et umbes niimoodi see töötab.
Õpetaja: Okei, aga meil Loomulikult ongi ainult set. Aga meil on loomulikult see ainult ühe korra vaja ongi, aga Teil on vaja nüüd aru saada, et. Oot, oot, oot, oot, oot, aga
Õpetaja: Aga kuidas see nüüd siis töötab? Et siin on see About, Et mis? Mis moodi see asi käib?
Õpetaja: Kui Ma otsin seda teksti. Lihtsalt üle Projekti Control Shift, F,
Õpetaja: siis me leiame, et meil on Niukene Fail nagu About View.
Õpetaja: Kui me teeme oma failihalduri siit lahti, tõmbame muud asjad kokku.
Õpetaja: Ee, teete lahti ja vaatate Siit Views,
Õpetaja: siin on praegult About View ja Homeview, on? Nii? Vaatame seda About View D. Sellepärast, et ta on nagu üsna Niukene lihtsakene teine,
Õpetaja: Kui me Tuleme, avame.
Õpetaja: Miks ta nii teeb? Mulle ei meeldi see. Mulle ei meeldi see setup. Ma ei saa aru, miks siin on samamoodi see.
Õpetaja: See niikuinii läheb prügihästi. Selles mõttes ma ei muretse.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma ise tõstan praegu selle skrip I alla. Ärge tee sellepärast muretsege.
Õpetaja: Peaks arhitektuuriliselt alati all olema.
Õpetaja: Tead, ma ei ole saanud sellest aru. Aa, küsime seda pärast. Tähendab, küsime seda kohe. Vaata,
Õpetaja: mulle meeldib, et template osa on üleval.
Õpetaja: Seal. Vist sisuliselt Vahet pole,
Õpetaja: ee. Sisulist Vahet ei ole. Selles mõttes ta kuvab ikka ainult templateid. Templetis käib Html. Scriptis käib,
Õpetaja: Noh, jamas käib põhimõtteliselt.
Õpetaja: Ja minu jaoks on ikkagi. See. Vaata, et üks vaade on mingi kindel vaade, mis? Kus on mingi visuaal, et Ma tahan esimesena kohe näha seda
Õpetaja: visuaali ja vanasti. See kogu aeg on niimoodi. Olnud Ja selles mõttes, et mina ühtegi juhist ette ei andnud, kui ma hakkasin enda projekti tegema ja Cloud on teinud mulle ka, et templeid on üleval ja Scripto on all
Õpetaja: siin. Ee, se Selles mõttes nii öelda. Miks Minu õpetus? Kindlasti ma soovin sada protsenti, et on niimoodi ja küsime selle kohta ka. Vaata, küsime selle küsimuse Ära siis nagu, onju.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd ma kasutan seda võimalust, et ma highlightin selle teksti
Õpetaja: Ütlen lihtsalt natukene ette ka. Vaata Cloud Ile, et, Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, milline Ma küsin, milline milline on tava Tava Voe kolmes.
Õpetaja: Aa, aa, gript
Õpetaja: ja templeid.
Õpetaja: Templeid. Ee, blokkida järjekorra osas,
Õpetaja: Sest et Ma olen näinud, et kui sa teed uue template, siis ta tõesti teeb, niimoodi et hoopis ülesse templeti alla. Aga nagu minu jaoks, ei Tundu see üldse nagu kuidagi meeldiv.
Õpetaja: Ta räägib nagu nii. Vaatame korra
Õpetaja: nii ennem ja Temple enne template. Miks
Õpetaja: näete nüüd, ta räägib ka Sellest oli templeid sageli ees, sest loogika oli eraldi ja nii edasi, et siin. On. Ma ütlen, et siin on kaks lähenemiston api on nagu Ee, niiöelda uuem, aga see on. Ma ütlen, seal on hästi palju abstraktsiooni nagu mina, seda nagu sealt ei õpi nagu neid asju selgeks.
Õpetaja: Ee, Minu jaoks on niimoodi loogiline. Ee, minu projektis sa isegi kusjuures on? Ma olen öelnud, Kasuta Komposition. Api D on template Block ikka üleval.
Õpetaja: Sest et ma. Ma. Kui ma tulen siia faili, siis ma tahan tegelikult seda visuaalset poolt kohe nagu aru saada, et see on.
Õpetaja: Tavaliselt isegi on mul mingi. Igal ühel on mingi päis. Vaata, et sa oled mingi selles vaates,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, nüüd on üks asi ka. Vaata, et selles mõttes, et ee,
Õpetaja: kuskil ei ole kirjas, et sa pead tegema kõike asju täpselt nii, nagu on mingisugune tava sellepärast, et tegelikult projekti meeskonnas Tavaliselt elbitakse ka asju.
Õpetaja: Meie teeme asju nii,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, mina. Mina ei teeks seda. Mulle ei meeldiks seda ja Ma ütlen ka, et see ei tundu loogiline minu jaoks. Nagu üldse. Ma saan aru, mis. Mis ta mõte on. See vaata, et et Kui sa. Kui sa vaataksid nagu andmeid ja asju, vaata, siis sa kaina nagu tahaksid. Kuna see visuaalne pool sõltub ee, andmetest, vaata, nagu On ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, siis. Ee, siis, ee, et kaine. Võibolla tahad nagu sellest enne pildi saada ette ja siis nagu vaatad. Et Okei, mis ma nüüd siis visuaalis nagu nägema pean,
Õpetaja: Aga minu jaoks Ei, Cloud Il võib olla. Või sa vabandad. See võibki nii. Olla vaata
Õpetaja: aga. No küsime. Vaata aga, kas on ka oht teha templeid enne ja siis.
Õpetaja: No tehniliselt vahet pole niikuinii. Vaata,
Õpetaja: ei, ei, hoia, jah,
Õpetaja: okei,
Õpetaja: Kas ta kuidagi jälitab Ee kasutajat ka? Kas ta kuidagi jäljendab ise ka kasutajat? Sest et ee, siin ta kasutas ka natuke inglise keelt Ja Siis Eesti keelt, nagu siin enam
Õpetaja: No Tundub küll, hea, et ta midagi jälgib ja ta näeb, et ma olen. See.
Õpetaja: See oli Naljakas, tahad, Made My Day?
Õpetaja: Hea küll, ee. Ja ütleme niimoodi, et Mind ei. Huvita seal. Isegi Isegi ma ei hakkaks elu sees tegema oma projekti ümber ja harjuma. Võibolla kunagi järgmine projekt või kuskil. Ma osalen ma sellega ümber. Aga mina ei taha. Minu jaoks on see Mina lähen vaatele. Ma tahan lihtsalt näha, mis mul seal toimub.
Õpetaja: Ma saan sellest loogikast aru, mis ta. Nagu ma saan mõttest aru vaata, Ja miks? Miks see nagu nii on? Aga nagu ütled, ütleme niimoodi, et siis mina olen see nagu mu naine. Vaata, mina guugeldan asju Läbi neti punkt, E, E. Ja nii on
Õpetaja: ta Enam seda ei tee. Muidugi.
Õpetaja: Okei, Ee, kuidas Ja teeme pausi? Liis tuli ka. Jah, printslast.
Õpetaja: Kas ma rekordin ja räägin? Kõik rekordida? Ei ole vaja, aga rääkida on ikka vaja, sest Rain on, ee, on kaugelt,
Õpetaja: et nagu Selles mõttes, et räägi siis. Või noh, oled lihtsalt siin. Sa oled niikuinii siin ju?
Õpetaja: Okei, ühesõnaga. Ee, jõudsime siis sinnamaale, et et miks Siis tuleb täpselt. Ee, et me nüüd saime aru, et süsteem on selline, et vastavalt rajale. Ee, tuleb niiöelda sellest ülejäänud osa sellest,
Õpetaja: aga Siis on küsimus, et. Ee, et, ee, kuidas ja miks
Õpetaja: nüüd? Esiteks on Niukene tava ja konventsioon, et meil on see nüüd see, mis Te kõik näete siin source ja kaustad ja failid. Kui te teete uue projekti Ee käsu realt, et te uus projekt panete teile mingi nime, onju? Siis niuksed, failid. On teil vaikimisi Kohe seal projektis olemas.
Õpetaja: Õpetused selle kohta olemas. Kui jõuame sinnamaani, kus te hakkate projekte tegema, Siis saate vaadata, kuidas selle asja loomine käib.
Õpetaja: Midagi keerulist pole. Ee, siis meil on eraldi kataloog. Vaadetele Siia käivad siis ainult sellised voekomponendid. Need on ka voekomponendid. Nagu selles mõttes, et need on. Näete, punkt. Voe on nii.
Õpetaja: Need on vaekomponendid. Aga nendel on siis niimoodi, et Nad on mõeldud siis olema vaatekomponendid.
Õpetaja: Mis tähendab seda, et need on siis vastavalt Urlile, et sellised komponendid
Õpetaja: niukses kohas ja siis, ee, siin on siis selline? Niiöelda fail faili nime konventsioon, et siis vaatenimi Mingisugune vaade. Vaata, et see View on selles faili osa ee nimest,
Õpetaja: eks See ei ole nagu tehniline, kui sa ei pane. Vaata. Oi, see ei tööta. On ju, et sa võid mida iganes kirjutada siia, aga Et siis kõik ee vaated, et oleks neid lihtne eristada teistest komponentidest, siis nendel on veel eraldi Ee Sufix Ee view. Suure tähega on Arusaadav,
Õpetaja: kõik vaatekomponendid, Kui me keskendume sellele sellele.
Õpetaja: Siin on küsimus, et siin on tõesti fail. Siin on template. Siin on see script Jälle Ka ma selle prügikasti niikuinii. Aga ma korra tõstan endale alla, et oleks visuaalselt parem vaadata. Keskendume jälle ainult selle template ile. Siin on Üks konteiner bla blabla. See on,
Õpetaja: on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, Siin on üks header. This is an about page this is an about page.
Õpetaja: Siin on üks ee fosfor Mastan. Kasutasin Oso Maicons või mis iganes. Nüüd ma võtsin selleks selleks teekursuseks. Võtsin ühe teise deegi, kus saab võtta Ikoone. Näete seda ikooni?
Õpetaja: See on lihtsalt mingi suvaline ikoon. See on lihtsalt, et nagu tal on kõik vajalik mant olemas, et kui vaadata, Jälle seda. Ee, siis siin on olemas fosfor Icons,
Õpetaja: et me saame igasuguseid erinevaid ikoone, et see osa siin selle ma sain internetist all In good time. Kui meil läheb ikoone vaja. Noh, mida iganes, mis iganes, Ikoone tahate. Ee, seal on, Mina ei tea kõige suurem valiku üldse, Nii et ee, sobib see kõige lihtsamini. Nii see selleks,
Õpetaja: et, ee, põhimõtteliselt me näeme, et see lihtsalt, ee, visuaalselt peegeldab seda Html I on nii?
Õpetaja: No on on ju fosfor Ikoon, detective. Noh, detective, siin on I Guess
Õpetaja: Midagi taolist oleks võinud vaadata, kas mingi Batman Või midagi taolist on oleks lähedal. Nii, aga nüüd on küsimused. Oot, oot, aga kuidas siis? Kuidas ta nüüd siis teab? Vaata, et siin On Küll olemas vastavalt ruudile. Aa, nii öelda Sina niiöelda siis mingi komponent joonistada selle? Ta joonistab ka kenasti, et Aga kuidas see siis setup on, et või Kuidas ma. Siis saan nagu seda asja defineerida?
Õpetaja: No kui te vaatate neid kauste, kas siin võiks midagi silma jääda Üks kaustadest
Õpetaja: ruuter. Sellepärast neid asju kutsutakse. Erinevalt ruut.
Õpetaja: Sama. No voest kutsutakse seda ruudiks.
Õpetaja: Teekond.
Õpetaja: Vaht on rada nagu selles mõttes, aga same Same põhimõtteliselt heal lapsel. Mitu nime?
Õpetaja: Ee, kui me teeme Ruuteri lahti, siis siin on indeks ja avascript i fail
Õpetaja: ee. Kui me tuleme Siia siis. Ee. Mina teeks niimoodi, et ma hästi natukene lühendaks. Ee, seda asja.
Õpetaja: Ee, paremaks või isegi Jah, käib. Ta on üks näide, on siin. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: vaata, kui seda Homeview D. Vaata, lihtsam,
Õpetaja: kui kui meie oleme lihtsalt rajal kaldkriips.
Õpetaja: No Brauser sööb selle kaldkriipsu ära, aga Tegelikult on. See on home vaade, onju?
Õpetaja: Siin on ära defineeritud Ee, sellel paremal kujul see, see. Näide. Mulle ei meeldi. Aa, siin on Niimoodi, et meil on Niukene asi, nagu
Õpetaja: siin on mõned voe Mingid sätted pole seda vaja teada. Aga Mida on vaja teada, on, on Roots.
Õpetaja: Mis sellel Rootsil Praegult, Kui ma tõmban kogu asja kokku. Mis siin, mis siin paistab? Mis need kandilised sulud on? Väike küsimus, lähme korra sinna generali alla. Kõik, kes vaatasid need Ee. Jason videod Ära Pange oma silmad alla, Siis kõik vaatasid ära. Eile andsin ülesandet. Vaadake,
Õpetaja: Lõpuni ei jõudnud aga aktsiat vaatama. Keegi vist üldse ei vaadanud.
Õpetaja: Jah, ee, vaadake. Ee. Harraid ei hakka seletama. Ee, siin on siis harraid. Selles mõttes on siin meil kaks. Ee, klotsi.
Õpetaja: Kaks objekti on Home ja About. Vaatame seda Home I Lihtsalt See on lihtsam. Vaadata. Siin Defineeritakse ära rada.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et kui näiteks
Õpetaja: keegi läheks rajale. Aa, no proovime.
Õpetaja: Kui ma lähen korra About I, et mul oleks Nagu näha.
Õpetaja: Ja ma nüüd tulen. Aa, siis laetakse koduvaade saate mõttest ära. See siin on definitsioon.
Õpetaja: Ee, Ruudil on nimi.
Õpetaja: Siin on süntaks Lihtsalt nagu vaate. Ee, räägin nimest kohe. Ta lihtsalt on nimi Roots. Ruudi nimi, et edaspidi saab nimeliselt ka selle asja poole pöörduda. Kogu Selle ruudi poole saab selle nime abil ka pöörduda. Aga mis on nüüd see kõige tähtsam osa on komponent.
Õpetaja: Tema ütleb. Et hei, kui Sina lähed rajale. Aa, siis palun. Lae komponent Home You
Õpetaja: Nüüd See Homeyou on siin niimoodi valge. Ee, siit kui ülevalt vaadata, siis me Näeme, et meil on öeldud, et mida Home You täpsemalt siis ikkagi tähendab?
Õpetaja: Ta tähendab seda, et ee soojus kataloogist üks samm ülesse, mis
Õpetaja: See võiks hädivaks panna seda põhimõtteliselt.
Õpetaja: Täpselt parem Aa, siin Voes töötab asjad niimoodi. Kui sa paned mistahes hetkes kuskil rajal ätt,
Õpetaja: siis see on fikseeritud Source kataloogiga. Palju palju mugavam. Mäletate, enne kui me tegime niiöelda seal publiku? Me mängisime selle päris indeks. Atml iga vanamoodi oli Veitsa raske aru saada, et mida ta mõtleb. Nagu, kus. Kus me oleme Praegult Nagu kui me hakkame mingi paati defineerima. Kuskil on ankur,
Õpetaja: Kas See on kogu projekt või mis iganes No siin on lihtne. Ätt on alati selles Voes source.
Õpetaja: See on kokku lepitud nagu su Poe on niukse disainiga nagu disainitud niuksed. Kataloogid on olemas.
Õpetaja: Käib ikka vä ja käib Jah, vist Ise kaitsen,
Õpetaja: aga alati küsi üle Igal juhul parem on karta, kui kahetseda.
Õpetaja: Nii Ee, sa näete. Siin on põhimõtteliselt defineeritud. Kui ma vajutan praegu klikki siia peale Views, ma Satun Views ka osta. Kui ma klikin siia homeview peale, siis ma satun siia kausta või siia. Faili Peal on nii siin üleval on ära defineeritud. Kui seda ei ole,
Õpetaja: siis tema ei tea, mis asi see voe on? Vaata, Sest et see on nimi. Vaata, nagu see on Komponendi nimi. Niimoodi ta teab. Ehk siis iga ruut koosneb kolmest osast
Õpetaja: rada, mis komponent laadida. Ja kuidas me saame lihtsalt viidata sellele definitsioonile? Minule nüüd meeldib jälle. Ma ütlen, minule meeldib, ee, seda süntaksit natukene muuta, et mulle meeldib, et iga ruudi juurde selle ruudi nimele me Paneme juurde Sufixi ruut.
Õpetaja: Sest edaspidi, kui me kuskil koodis veame, et palun mine sellele ruudile. Mulle ei meeldi näha seda, et mine home, Vaid Mulle meeldib home ruut
Õpetaja: hiljem kasutades, kui ma viitan sellele. Mulle meeldib niimoodi, et on palju nagu see täpsem, nagu väljendab paremini, kuidagi Nagu ma ei oska öelda, et ta nagu tegemist on Ruudi ruudi nimega. Sellepärast komponentidel on ka nimed.
Õpetaja: Komponentidel on ka nimed ja nii Edasi, Ee, siis mulle meeldib, et siin jätkame Kaine nagu sama malli, et Lihtsalt, onju.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuigi ei hakka konteksti lugeda, et seal, kui sa seda kasutad, Sa saad sellest aru, aga Still recardesse mulle meeldib. Ma saan üle projekti otsida ja kukkuda täpselt siia,
Õpetaja: kui ma kuskil Seda näen. Ma saan siia kukkuda ja vastupidi ka.
Õpetaja: Kui sa paned lihtsalt Homes I, siis ma ei tea, mis kohad me kõik üles Leiame võibolla Home Root. Kuskil on kasutatud You find Id.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, kas see mõte on selge? Vaata, et kuidas nüüd need kaks asja kokku mängivad.
Õpetaja: See ruut ütleb meile, et navigatsiooni vaade on Ja nüüd vastavalt. See nüüd on siis see sinine. Kast
Õpetaja: mäletate? Toon korra veel Selle, kus meil, Ee, need pildid olid.
Õpetaja: Selle Pildi võtaks ette indeks Atml koos navigatsiooni menüüga. No see on tegelikult. Vahepeal on see hapefoefail ka veel,
Õpetaja: siis tuleb vastavalt ruudile.
Õpetaja: Locations vaade.
Õpetaja: On see arusaadav?
Õpetaja: Siin Ruuter indeksis. Ma hakkan siin. On. Vaata Ruuteri indeksis. Siin on see, Kus me hakkame. Edaspidi me viitame sellele sellele failile niimoodi. Ruuteri indeksis, on see koht, kus me saame defineerida. Ära
Õpetaja: rajad urlid, mis on meie rakenduses vaatad Sest meil on ainult üks fail. Vaata, me peame ütlema, et nagu. Näita seda või näita toda.
Õpetaja: On siin kohal kellelgi Mõni küsimus.
Õpetaja: No väga hea.
Õpetaja: Okei, super, Super Pupper.
Õpetaja: Kui me vaatame näiteks seda vaatamise koht,
Õpetaja: siis see on see punane klatš.
Õpetaja: Et kui Korra vaatame näiteks, et mis on home vaates.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma rii muutsin selle kogemata siin selleks ajaks ära, onju? Ma Taastan selle nii nagu oli.
Õpetaja: Ahah, niimoodi oli see. Läheb lihtsalt kodu.
Õpetaja: Home home. Et Kus kohas see siis kõik on? Et ma ju. Ma ju lähen vaatan Nagu, et, ee. Lähme vaatan Home Yout
Õpetaja: ei näe siin mingi ridade viisi. Nagu mingit staffi.
Õpetaja: See nüüd on siis see värk, et me Kutsume välja mingit ee alamkomponenti.
Õpetaja: Näete, siin on kaust komponents.
Õpetaja: Hello, World. Mis kurat? Hello, World. Kustutame ära.
Õpetaja: Jälle Kogu aeg kustutame ära.
Õpetaja: The Welcome.
Õpetaja: See on see osa sellest pildimaterjalist.
Õpetaja: See location stavel sisu.
Õpetaja: Vaade ei näita mulle Ee metsad ja maad, aga sisu siis tulebki ka veel, Ega kõik ei ole selles Ühes? See on see sama asi. Me tahame, et seda, et meil oleks erinevad. Ee, niiöelda erinevad ee Osad Niiöelda eraldi failid Esiteks taaskasutatavus.
Õpetaja: Teiseks koodi loetavus
Õpetaja: Kui kogu lehekülg läheb Kui kogu Html läheb juba mingi ee nelisada rida, siis see Ei ole nagu väga mõnus vaadata. Peale
Õpetaja: see nelisada rida võib potentsiaalselt olla isegi võibolla sada rida, Võibolla isegi viiskümmend rida, võibolla veel vähem
Õpetaja: Ja sa saad selle üldpildi kätte. Ja kui sind huvitab mingi spetsiifiline osa sellest lehest, siis sa lähed või vaatad.
Õpetaja: No tee oma voed Tuul selle lahti. Kohe näed ära. Nagu mis? Millest? Nagu sõltub. No vaatame ka ära,
Õpetaja: kui ma teen lahti inspekt, tulen Vaatamise koht, mul on Ta siin olemas.
Õpetaja: Teen inspekti lahti. Ka see tuleb settingutest panna. Eraldi vist kuskilt. Ee, targiks,
Õpetaja: Kes soovib pärast panna. Kuskil on need Settingud. Ma ei viitsi otsida neid, Aga siin on Niuke asi, nagu
Õpetaja: mulle ei meeldi. Nii väikene. Kuidas ta paneks nagu responsideks?
Õpetaja: Kuule, mis ta nii väikselt näitab Zoom level.
Õpetaja: Noh, niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, vaadake, kui ma tulen. Vaata, et see on kogu app Vaade
Õpetaja: homeview, on sellest osa Okei, praegult on natukene halb näha. Võibolla niimoodi ei aita mitte kauba näha näha. Vaata, et. Noh, siin ei ole nagu, nii et te Saate aru et need on erinevad osad? Need on tükkides kokku pandud,
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: Kui me hakkame vaatama sõltuvus suhteid vaata siis põhimõtteliselt see Routerview. Ma mõt Okei äpp. Vaade on lingid.
Õpetaja: Lingid on navigatsioon. Siis Tuleb vastavalt ruudile asjad.
Õpetaja: See ruudi järgi tuleb. Homeview on Child on Welcome
Õpetaja: ja Welcomil on nüüd Welcome. Aita meid. Üks, kaks, kolm, neli, viis korda või? Failide mõttes on meil siis siin üks,
Õpetaja: kaks, kolm, Neli faili.
Õpetaja: Nelja faili peale on tegelikult see asi ära tehtud.
Õpetaja: Ja üks osa on nagu korduvalt. Nagu. Vaata,
Õpetaja: kui ma lähen korra About Ile
Õpetaja: siis Meil on ainult About View ja ainukene laps. Komponent, mida me kasutame, on see fosfori niiöelda Ikoon, Detective,
Õpetaja: aga seda kas te Näete, kuidas siit näeb selle Aa, päris suhte ära nagu. Vaata, et kes. Nagu. Kellega on, nagu kes kelle laps on
Õpetaja: ja siin ma juba räägingi, et see on tegelikult see. Flow on niimoodi ülevalt alla alati.
Õpetaja: Nii, No okei. Me saame selle asjaga siin
Õpetaja: Ee, tutvuda küll. Ja küll, eriti kui me hakkame nüüd siin kohe kohe enda asju tegema.
Õpetaja: Okei, nii ee, super kuper.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui me. No lähme vaatamegi, Vaata, noh, et kuidas? Kus siin see home siis nii resetti peaks? Ka Umbes Nii et kui me vaatame seda home I, et vaata, Kus Siis ei ole seda Aga siin on. Näete suure tähega. Vaata, see on. See Ei, ole.
Õpetaja: See ei ole Html I komponent.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, Jälgige siin. Ma panen kõik kaustad siit kinni.
Õpetaja: Kõiki The Welcome. Peale Kuhu me Satume? Components I alla The Welcome.
Õpetaja: Nii, Nii, ja siis on. Siin me. Me ei lähe sellesse sügavusse niikuinii praegult, Nii
Õpetaja: et see nagu on. Lihtsalt kontseptsiooniliselt.
Õpetaja: Kas seda kihilisust ja seda dünaamilisust, kas on Vaja veel mingisuguseid selgitusi. Ma ei küsi, et et nagu. Mis selgitusi ma küsin, mul on üks pildimaterjal ka, aga ma pigem ei kulutaks aega. Saate juba sellest aru, et see dünaamilisus tuleb niimoodi
Õpetaja: niimoodi klotside kaupa järjest sügavamale. Siis Kui sellest kontseptsioonist üldpildis saate, aru, siis Mul ei ole vaja seda teha.
Õpetaja: Praktika käigus tulevad need päris teadmised. Niikuinii ei kuluta rohkem aega, on ju nii? Siis järgmine asi, mis me tahame, teha, on see, et siis hakkame mõtlema, kuidas tarkvaraarenduses tegelikult tööd tehakse.
Õpetaja: Ee on kaks lähenemist
Õpetaja: on kaks lähenemist on niuksed ee süsteemid. Keegi on kuulnud, nagu oled kuulnud, aga keegi teine.
Õpetaja: Aga sisu tuleb toyotal.
Õpetaja: Ee, Toyota töötas välja. Kui ma ei eksi, ma ise Töötasin kunagi Manufacturing Ee seal. Manufacturing is. Seal oli ka veidi oli. Vaata,
Õpetaja: ee. Ma tahan ehitada autot, mida mul on vaja auto ehitamiseks Komponente juppe on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, Kas mina neid juppe ise toodan? Noh, mõned toodan, aga valdavalt ei tooda. Kuidas on valdavalt? Kust tulevad Jupid
Õpetaja: tehasest. No kes need tehased on,
Õpetaja: Norma? Jah, on küll. Ee, Tornija Keegi teeb ega ise ei väga vähe ettevõtteid on, kes teevad Vertical Integration It See on see, et põhimõtteliselt kõik etapid on nagu enda halduses, nagu et ise toodad Ise teed väga vähe tänapäeval kindlasti odavamad sisse
Õpetaja: arendajaid. Samamoodi India mehed teevad siin ee, vihuvad tööd. Nii et silmad funnis.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd võibolla hakkab kvaliteeti ka tegema, aga mingi jaksavad endale lubada. Ma ei tea, võibolla ei jaksagi.
Õpetaja: Ee, Kuidas nad kamba peale vast saadavad? Jah,
Õpetaja: pead ühe töö ära ja siis saad kuu aega Jälle ka, Cloud iga kasutada. Ja,
Õpetaja: ee. Okei, Ee, Toyota Siis põhimõtteliselt ee. Leiutas välja niukse süsteemi, et nagu, kuidas, nagu, ee, siis Nagu garanteerida, et sul on nagu piisavalt palju juppe õigel ajal. Aga väga palju inventaare pole, sest inventaari annavad raha, sa võid seda raha kinni. Sa ei saa investeerida. Sa saad midagi teenida, Mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Ee, Keegi ei taha inventari hoida. Mitte keegi kunagi ei taha inventari hoida, Ma olen töötanud Eurospace. Selles ma tean. Mitte keegi ei taha inventari hoida rohkem, kui vaja.
Õpetaja: Tuleb leida. Niukene Tuleb leida Niuke Ohviline tasakaal, et sul on. Sul ei juhtu kunagi seda, et jupid saavad otsa. Vaata aga sa ei taht neid juppe ka liiga Aa, nagu liiga palju nendel A.
Õpetaja: Ee. Ja siis on nagu. Ma nüüd joonistan. Kahjuks rain seda sealt kodust. Ei, näe, vaata, aga ma lihtsalt tõesti tahaks lihtsamalt teha paberi peal.
Õpetaja: Kujutage ette, et meil on Toyota tehas Ma panen siia Toyota teie mida iganes,
Õpetaja: ee, ja siis nendel on Niukene Klass, kus nad tahavad võtta juppe.
Õpetaja: Võtame välja. Mingi töö. Messi
Õpetaja: on õnnelik, et tahame midagi võtta sealt välja ja tema saab selle peale midagi teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, süsteem oli siis välja vaadata, et, ee, et siin, on tegelikult aa pandud nagu tornija. Tegelikult toodab. Mis on, Patch?
Õpetaja: Mingi pulk. Vaata, kui sina tellid mul pointe, siis mina müün need sulle saja kaupa. Mitte niimoodi. Et sa aitad enne sada kolm, vaid noh, Tellin sada või kakssada. Ise tead, mis sa teed. Vaata aga sellepärast, et tootja tahab ka nagu normaalselt asju teha. Vaata, nagu toota mingis kindla süsteemi järgi.
Õpetaja: Ja siis see, ee, süsteem on hästi lihtne. Näiteks, et ee, siia maksimum mahub sisse mis me soovime, et oleks maksimum on enamvähem Niukene, Ütleme mingi
Õpetaja: viiskümmend.
Õpetaja: Miinimum on näiteks meie jaoks kümme vaata. Et, kui, on juba kümme kümme komponenti siis sellega need, enam, väga pikalt ei pane, aga. Noh, siin on midagi veel.
Õpetaja: Mõte on nagu see. Vaata, et, ee iga kord, kui see näiteks ee, langeb siia mingi kümne peale siis, automaatselt niiöelda läheb mingi järgmine juntsu või kes. Iganes see võib isegi selles samas tehases väga olla see. Ei pruugi olla, et on kuskil mingi suurem kast kellelgi teisel tarnijal, onju, et põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: kuskil mujal, kus on neil nagu põhimõtteliselt rada,
Õpetaja: et kui See tase langeb. Kümneni. Minnakse, siia ja võetakse ütleme. Siis Näiteks nelikümmend juurde see. Liigub siia kasti nüüd. Siin. Ei ole enam sada siin. On nüüd kuuskümmend.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see vend ka. Siin on ka mingi ee. Mingi säte, et oota alati alla. Kahekümne, siis me nagu tellime nagu juurde.
Õpetaja: See on kanvan Tõstad. Tõstad ühest kastist põhimõtteliselt teise ja manageerid oma seda tööd. Sellist mõttes niimoodi, et ega autodega on ka, vaata, Et nagu sa isegi auto ostad niimoodi, et ainult tellimuse peale teed.
Õpetaja: Kui Kübeautot on tellitud siis, sa tead palju, sul on vaja vaata. Millal sul. Noh, see on umbes nagu kuidagi, nagu niimoodi. Aga see põhiline asi on see, et see need kastid ja see süsteem iseennast Nagu manageerib tellimused ka enda nägu,
Õpetaja: mida mul on vaja. Millal ei ole mõtet siia panna? Tuhat seda asja ei mahugi. Vaata,
Õpetaja: sest et See kriitiline piir kus meie nagu jaoks on? Nagu on vaja juurde, on nagu. Kus on Nagu mingi väike puhver. Siis ta kutsub puhvreiks. On kümme kümnega me sul. Valvime näiteks noh mingi. Ma, Ei, tea paar päeva, või mis iganes, oleneb see tarneahela. Nagu oleks, nagu ideaalne Vaata, põhimõtteliselt tahab. Otsa Siis oleks ideaalne, et võtab uue väga vähe.
Õpetaja: See on, ee. Nüüd, Kui me räägime nüüd projekti haldusest, siis Chiras on kaks lähenemist. Põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: üks on Can Pan
Õpetaja: on Lihtsalt board ja niukseid. Numbreid ei ole seal. Vaata, et Oi, taskid hakkavad otsa saama
Õpetaja: Kunagi otsa Pigem on niimoodi Vaata, et on üks suur backloge kast
Õpetaja: siin suur sada ja ütleme niimoodi, et see nädal me võtame nagu Bordile ja plaanile, et võtame siit mingi. Noh, Kümme Taaski, sina. Teed mida iganes
Õpetaja: kui, vaja nagu. Keegi Teeb oma töö Ära vaata. Nagu Põhimõtteliselt, nagu need plaanid on täidetud, siis võetakse sealt Back logist järgmine ja, noh, töö ei saa küll kunagi otsa rajada. Nagu taastuda ei saa.
Õpetaja: Teine lahendus on sprindid. No Kes eelkursust tegid? Vaata seal olid sõnad. Sprint. Sprint. Sprint oli nii?
Õpetaja: Ee, Okei
Õpetaja: Vaatame korra. Sprinters Tuleme Canbani juurde. Tagasi. Sellepärast, et see meie projekt on Canbanis tehtud. Kui ma praegu korra lähen ja otsin ülesse
Õpetaja: Chira Alt Ee projekti nime Ka Aa, car Portal. Näiteks
Õpetaja: Nii, tänu selle car portali lahti.
Õpetaja: Back logi Backlog vaatesse.
Õpetaja: Ma korra. Panen natukene Väiksemaks. On planeeritud kaheksa sprindi jaoks. Nüüd see päriselus ei tööta niimoodi. Vaata, et meil on kaheksa Sprinti ja kõik Projekt on läbi. Ja tsau, baka sprint. On Sprint on lihtsalt siis mingi ajaühik. Kas ta on üks nädal või kaks nädalat?
Õpetaja: Aa, enamus ettevõtted optimeerivad kuskil seal vahel kuni neli nädalat, Võibolla Agiilse arenduse printsiipide järgi, nagu kuu aja jooksul ikka releasid. Tavaliselt see tähendab reliisi ka. Kui tihti nagu, Aa teed nagu mingid muudatusi süsteemi paned, aga ei pruugi olla. Kui sul on hea süsteem, teed töö ära, vajutad nupu, läheb serverisse,
Õpetaja: Saab nii ka olla, aga vähemalt töid Planeeritakse siis mingi intervalli kaupa, et see kunagi ei muutu. See võib nagu pika aja peale muutuda nagu, niimoodi, et okei, et siiamaani töötasime oma töid ja asju planeerisime. Mõtlesime kahe nädala kaupa, et noh läheme nädala peale. Niimoodi võib olla, aga see ei ole niimoodi, et teeme See nädal üks.
Õpetaja: See on järgmine päev, kaks. Vaata, see on ka üks. Sama rütm on lihtsalt arendustsükkel. Näeb
Õpetaja: selles siis, kui mõelda nagu Ee, scrammi peale, mis on nagu metodoloogia Kuidas, nagu
Õpetaja: arendustööd juhtida. Aga muid projekte saab selle sama süsteemi all. Mingid kindlad on miitingud kindla Struktuur on ju siis tavaliselt kuidagi. Need planeeritakse nagu selle ajavahemiku peale. Too siis näitad ka Eesti energias oli see kaks nädalat Ee, Lhv S oli üks nädal.
Õpetaja: Aa, et nagu seal, nagu erinevad. Kuidas Kuidas see meeskond valib? Ma ütlen traditsiooniliselt. Ta kipub ka ainult olema üks Või teine Aga Kujutage, et siin võib ka olla mingeid projekte ja asju. Vaata, kus. Võibolla kuu ajaline. Ee, sprint on ka nagu mõistlik Vaata, et et see on nagu kokkulepe lennuvärk.
Õpetaja: Ja kuidas see nagu on, on see, et tegelikult siin on mingi kolm itemit, mul praegu On ju mingi reserved? Reserv ja mingi ülesanne, siis. Ee, päriselus on. Siin on siis. Aa, siin on palju Taaske
Õpetaja: mingid pugid, Asjad, mis Nagu Võibolla on kriitilised mingid pärisarendused. Mida iganes, Back log.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui ma töötasin selle ettevõttes minuga, oli lihtsalt see, et kõik tellimused, nagu, Mis on nagu eilse kuupäevaga. Põhimõtteliselt onju et noh, peaks nagu ammu ära tooma, et
Õpetaja: sellele keskenduma ja siis oli tuleviku va tuleviku asjad, Aga arenduses on siis mõeldud, et kõik taaskid, mille seast Põhimõtteliselt siis nagu need, kes siis nagu planeerivad nagu meeskonnas, Ma mõtlen, struktuur võib olla väga erinev. Kas selleks on mingi eraldi töötaja? Tiim ise valib või mis iganes vahet pole, keegi ikka prioritiseerib asju.
Õpetaja: Ja kui täna Näiteks oleks print kaheksa. Vaata ja nüüd me tahame siin süsteem. Noh, natuke planeeritakse ette vähemalt mingi nädal või midagi, nii
Õpetaja: et tahaks nagu Nädal järgmise nädala Sprindi asju nagu teha, Siis mis me teeme, on see, et vajutame, et Hei, Sprint. Uus print. Automaatselt läheb sprint üheksa
Õpetaja: Nii Ja siis hakkab sealt Backlog ist. Räägin dropiga. Lihtsalt vaat võtame, Teeme seda, teeme toda. Valid nagu töid. See on siis kõige tavapärasem Niiöelda tööviis
Õpetaja: see nüüd erineb.
Õpetaja: On nagu niimoodi. Lihtsalt nagu võtad Bordile järjest. Vaata, et me. Me ei pea nagu mingit niukest arvestust, et see nädal. Ja see võib töötada ka niimoodi, et me. Me ei planeerigi isegi nädala võttes. Me Lihtsalt kogu aeg topime lihtsalt kasti juurde, Kui on vaja, nagu,
Õpetaja: et ei ole nagu niukest süsteemi, ei ole mingi, et ei, siis see tähendab ka seda, et ei ole ka Mingisugust niukest arutlust. Võibolla, et. Aa, mis me see nädal teeme? Või Mida iganes arendajad ise võivad võtta sealt backlog ist. See Backlog on Igal juhul tavaliselt ka enam vähem. Mingi prioritiseeritud järjekorras.
Õpetaja: Seda on arvestatud, et inimesed saaksid lihtsalt tasku võtta, on ju? Aga Noh, mis on Ikka tähtsam on üleval. Ja mis on nagu vähem tähtis on all, on ju?
Õpetaja: Vahel? Nagu näed, Kuidas on. Ee. Need numbrid. Tiketinumbrid tulevad Automaatselt
Õpetaja: nelikümmend viis oleks põhimõtteliselt. Järgmine on ju? Kui teed uue tiketi, siis ta on nii edasi Järgmine number edasi. Vahel sa nagu näed Mingisugust asja, mis on. Arvake ära, kuidas
Õpetaja: väike number. Jah, madal number niimoodi on? Mäletad, ma rääkisin seda haruvärki. Vaata, et ärge jätke harudega on hügieen.
Õpetaja: Kui sa oled mingi asja ära Merchinud Masterisse vaata, siis kustuta see haru sealt pilvest ära. Siis ta jääb teistele nagu vedelema, On ju kuidas? Sealt samamoodi nagu lõpuks. Keegi kirjutab nagu kuskile. Ee, avalikku kanalisse. Vaata, Oi, siin on mingi kuradi Task Whatever the Hell.
Õpetaja: Kas See, taaskond veel endiselt vaata. Noh, et näeb, et on Closed.
Õpetaja: Sa näed väikseid numbreid. Noh, enamus on mingi üheksasada juba millegagi vaatad seal mingi seitsesada. Vaata taaski number. No haru. Vähemalt Lhv S oli see tava ja Eesti energias ka minu meelest, et taaski number on Osa haru number. Sellest haru nimest
Õpetaja: tausta oligi lihtsalt Lhv. S. Oligi nii lihtne. Lihtsalt see taaski number on harunumber,
Õpetaja: mis? Kõik asjad olid Connected niimoodi Igal pool lingitud ja väga mugav oli.
Õpetaja: Aa, Ja siis noh, siis oligi vahel see, et ee. Vahel võis kaaskist endast Näed ka ära vähemalt selle, et kui ta on lahti. Aga see võib ikka küsimus olla, et kas taaske nuustatud kinni panna, et kas arendus on ära tehtud
Õpetaja: või investe keedetud, kui oli mingi taas. Noh, viisakas oli ka, kui sul oli mingi blokker et sa ootad mingi välise partneri taga või? Või mingi teise süsteemi taga. Mida iganes sa saad taas ka alati panna oma kommentaari ka. Noh, et
Õpetaja: seisab, seisab lihtsalt sellepärast, et ee, mingisuguse asja järgi ootame, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, Kas te saate enamvähem aru, mis nende kahe süsteemi vahe on?
Õpetaja: See on lähenemine, kui Te, teete ise, hakkate projekti tegema. Kui tahate teha näiteks mingit projekti. Aa, New Project. Ta küsib kohe. Vaata, et kas sa tahad Nagu või tahad. Nagu sprintida ka. Vaata, sest nad on erinevad.
Õpetaja: Mõistlik. Teha sprintidega sest, Et meil oligi kindel aeg kindlad. Nädalad oli nagu mõistlik Mõelda et, kuidas me nagu, Näeme et, õpilased teevad õpilased Teevad online seda kahe nädala kaupa vaata. Onju, meil? Oli oma struktuur ja Süsteem. Mismoodi? Mis moodi meil oli? Seal need workshop, Id. Ja kõik muud asjad.
Õpetaja: Selle Springiga ei teki Jälle see, et ee, ma saan aru, et meil on veel. Tekib lõpuks seal mingisugune, mis? Meil on mingi kolm nädalat seda aega teha.
Õpetaja: Kuus sprinti, näiteks. Aga kuidas ma Tean, et need printide osakaalud on selles mõttes võrdsed, et mul ei ole Lõpuks niimoodi. Ei teagi. Siin vastus on juba. Ma ütlen, et Ära ei teagi, et sa võid planeerida. Vaata, teeme selle sprindiga nagu need asjad ära vaata, onju? Ja järgmine sprint Teeme mingeid muid asju,
Õpetaja: Aga kui sa tegelikult. Noh, päris tööd võtavad kauem aega, siis ongi lihtsalt see. Et noh,
Õpetaja: ei juhtunud. Noh, me planeerisime, See on meie Eesmärkplaan. Vaata, on ju, Aga see on väga tavapärane asi. Vaata, et see kandub järgmisse sprinti edasi. Vaata, on going. No see noh, selles mõttes, siis ongi see. Vaata, kui järgmine sprint oli ka juba planeeritud taaskirja, siis võibolla sealt peab midagi vähemaks võtma
Õpetaja: Noh, siis ongi küsimus, Kui see kandub nagu uute nädala edasi, vaata, et kas ta nagu äkki lõpeb ära esmaspäeval või teisipäeval on, ju,
Õpetaja: et siis on nagu lootust, et. Noh, see ülejärgmine plaan ka. Äkki veel kuidagi läheb, läbi onju? Või siis on nagu, niimoodi. Et. Okei, Noh, ilmselt, sellega läheb kauem vaatad, siis me võtame midagi ära. Sest arendaja tavaliselt ise niikuinii ei pea nagu midagi mõtlema. Vaid pigem on mingid planeerijad, kes nagu, Noh, mõtlevad seda, et mismoodi Järjekorras,
Õpetaja: et ee, teie koolitöödes. Ee, ma ei. Te võite teha, kui tahate, aga ma pakun, et ärge pange, kui Te, tahate dokumentatsiooni ja kõike, mida iganes teha, vaata oma plaane ja mõtlete mingisuguseid Taaske asju välja.
Õpetaja: Tehke need lihtsalt repose Md failidena, Ma näitan mingi hetk siis oma projekti. Miks sellepärast lihtne on? Hoida seda informatsiooni seal. Kui te hakkate pärast midagi seal niiöelda aega progema, Vaata, Siis see info on kõik seal, mitte siin.
Õpetaja: Ee, et niukse väikse projekti puhul nagu on nagu overkill.
Õpetaja: Ee, mi mis, ta minul on hea, lihtsalt. Noh, ta on hästi visuaalne. Ee, ta on päris tööriist. Loomulikult. Eesmärk on ka see, et te nagu õpiksite, nagu seda Päris asja. Mida te tööl kokku puutute. Mingisuguseid teistsuguseid lahendusi on ka see atlasjani litsents maksab per nägu. Vaata, on ju
Õpetaja: ee. Mingisugused väiksemad Ettevõtted võivad kasutada mingisugust tasuta alternatiive või soodsamaid alternatiive. Aga ma võin öelda, nagu enamus nagu maailm on nagu peal,
Õpetaja: nagu
Õpetaja: töötab Siin on Need teised asjad ka. Ja Ja muud integratsioonid on ju? Mille jaoks on see? Noh, Austraalia ettevõte Ee, kindlasti nad on nagu turuliider Ee For sure.
Õpetaja: Nii, aga lähme sellest ära. Vaata, Lähen tagasi, siis jagan panni.
Õpetaja: Me oleme Frontend I. Nüüd Kahjuks need taaskid, mis? Mida me Näeme ja kasutame. Te lihtsalt näete. Ma võin teha Pdf kop isid, kuigi isegi kas need on vaja või mitte, eks? Selgub, onju. Need on nagu minu isikliku Ee, selle. Need on minu isikliku konto all. Mitte nagu Bcs i omal. Ma ei saa kuidagi mugavalt neid ära Tõsta
Õpetaja: ee, mille ma tõstaks.
Õpetaja: Ja. Aga seal pole eriti vahet. Mina jagasin asjad. Esiteks, epikuteks on kuulnud keegi niukest asjaarendust nagu epikud
Õpetaja: Epic, on Siis suurema mahulisem. Näed, margariita on suurema mahulised nagu plaanid, et see on nagu mingi suur pealkiri, nagu No ma toon näiteks näite, eks? Et, ee, et ee. Meil on internetipank. Ja me tahaksime näiteks panna sinna, et mingi pensionifondi. Mingisugused
Õpetaja: tegevused. Ee, saad vaadata, kuidas sul See kasvab seal. Saad seal mingid toimingud ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Kui me nagu võtame nagu ettevõttena nagu plaani paika, et kui me me tahame Nagu niukest asja süsteemi juurde panna. Siis see ei ole enam väike Taas
Õpetaja: see on nagu. See on terve suur mingi uus,
Õpetaja: siis on Niimoodi, et et me planeerime oma töid nagu selles sektoris. Ja me. Tahame ka võibolla tunde. Vaid tundide logimine käib läbi Gira enamus ettevõtted ikkagi soovivad ja nõuavad, et te logite tunde. Kuidas see käib?
Õpetaja: Ee, mina olen saanud endale Feb. Aa, viie taskiks. Aa, mis ma pean tegema. Nüüd, kui ma seda arendust niiöelda teen, siis ee.
Õpetaja: Enamus kohad tavaliselt teevad, niimoodi. Et ka need nädala lõpuks peavad olema sul tunnid logitud. Mõni ütleb, et iga päev pead logima kindlalt. Mõnel on nagu, et kuu lõpuks olgu olla Aa, kuu lõikest, nad vaatavad asju.
Õpetaja: See on see, et sa saad sinna sse minna. Noh, siin õppeprojektis ei saa. Siin õppeprojektis. Me nagu vaatame, Me ei klõbista, ma nagu näitan ära, Kuidas see käib ja nii edasi. Aga teil ei ole igal ühel personaal. Teil ei ole niikuinii ligipääsu Sellele tšiirale ei peagi olema. Ka see ei ole tähtis, aga põhimõtteliselt. Ja siis ettevõttes logitakse tunde.
Õpetaja: Ee, eriti seda, Kui tegemist on rätsepa ettevõttega, miks siis miks just On vaja tunde loogida.
Õpetaja: Jah, sellepärast, et väga vähe ettevõtted teevad sellist arendust oma klientidele, kus nad lepivad tükihinna kokku. See, on, ee, seda saab teha ettevõte, kellel on väga suur kogemus mingis rätsepala ettevõttel, kellel on väga suur kogemus Mingisuguse tüüpprojekti tegemisel
Õpetaja: Näiteks online kasiino on ettevõtted, Kes on spetsialiseerunud nende keskkondade niiöelda loomisele ja tegemisele. Vaata, nemad võibolla võivad kokku leppida, et me teeme. Lepime kokku, mida te saate, vaata Ja tükki Hind on selline,
Õpetaja: Sest et see on hästi riskantne.
Õpetaja: Miks see skoop hakkab paisuma?
Õpetaja: Forschade,
Õpetaja: See on niimoodi, et kui inimene tuleb, ja ütleb. Aa, lepime kokku. Tee mulle niukene. Asi on ju. Ja siis see peaks olema nagu detailideni lihvitud. Sellisel juhul see aspekt tegelikult, Kui me tükihinnaga hakkaks kauplema, Sest varem või hiljem tuleb klient nagunii tegelikult ütleb. Vaata, ja. Ja. Aga tead, tegelikult seda ma mõtlesin natuke teistmoodi,
Õpetaja: kui ma tegelikult ise kirjeldasin ja soovisin.
Õpetaja: Ja siin ma ikkagi tegelikult tahaks natukene mingisugust, asja, mida ma kohe ei mõelnud. Meil on See tüki hing kokku lepitud. Mis me nüüd hakkame siis tegema? Jah, see on nii väike asi. See on nii. Väike asi, Vaata, et, Noh, tehke ära. Vaata lihtsalt nagu põhimõtteliselt hinna sees. Ja ja teeme. Siis tuleb järgmine väike asi ja nii edasi onju tüki hinnaga eriti Keegi ei taha.
Õpetaja: Ikka on niimoodi, et palun väga, mitu soovite? Ahah, väga hea. Mitu arendajat te soovite?
Õpetaja: Aa, ma pean ütlema ja pead Ütlema. Ja noh aa. No, mis te arvate nagu. Noh, me arvame, et neli. Ee, Millised Aa, kas seeniorid? Juuniorid.
Õpetaja: Mis see tähendab siin on meil, saate aru? Meil on ettevõttes erinevad. Vaata, seenior teeb siin mingit keerulisemaid ja põnevaid asju Vaata Oskab elada. Juunior, nagu teeb lihtsamat onju? Seenioritunni hind on nüüd teile. Selline
Õpetaja: Juunior on selline. Vaata, et, noh, kuidas, ta Noh, seal on kindlasti mingi, mis optimaalne tundub või Mis Iganes onju ettevõte peab ise lõpuks taustal teha. Mida iganes, et nad tegelikult pillivad neid seeniorite eest. Nad tegelt taustal teevad tööd, võibolla Ka juuniorid mängisid väikseid asju, Aga
Õpetaja: vahet pole. Aga mis on tähtis, on see. Vaata, et me tunni eest maksab ettevõte,
Õpetaja: aga siis on ju seda vaja. Nagu niimoodi need ettevõtted nagu väga ei tahaks mängida pooli Vaata, kui ütelda, et lähme. Lihtsalt ütleme iga nädal sulle lihtsalt Nagu suvaliselt, Nagu mingid tunnid. Vaata,
Õpetaja: et nad tahavad. Nad tahaksid detaili taha. Vaata, et meie esitame plaani see asi ära teha ja siis on hakata vaja vaatama seda, et kaua mingisugukseks asjaks nagu aega kulub. Nüüd. Tellija võib olla ka piisavalt tark. Tegemist on ka liit ettevõttega, Nad teevad ise ka Võibolla arendusi, aga nad kõike ei jaksa teha. Vaata, nad tellivad midagi sisse,
Õpetaja: et sealt hakkab vaikselt nagu välja kooruma, Kui mingi asjaga nagu läheb liiga kaua siis saab nagu arutada seda asja, et. Noh, tegelikult see keerukus, kus on. Võibolla ongi kõige keeruline. Võibolla midagi ongi keerulist ka. Vaata, et, noh, tuleb mingid ootamatud. Asjad Aga päeva lõpuks on ikkagi nagu maksad nagu by the Hour
Õpetaja: et Rätsepa puhul on see põhimõtteliselt sisse kirjutatud. Kui te lähete niisugustesse kohta, te peate oma tunde logima
Õpetaja: nüüd oma toode pangad mis iganes telekomid Aa, mis arendused? Mis? Igatahes, ettevõte, kes ise omi asju seal arendab, onju? No ja nemad samamoodi kasutavad tööde manageerimiseks midagi taolist, on ju? Ega neil neid ju huvitab? Kaua aega läheb.
Õpetaja: Noh, isegi kui nad. Isegi kui nad tegelikult ütlevad. Jah, me tahame ka enda nagu mõttes Lihtsalt näha, kui palju ühel või teisel projektil aega läheb, siis võibolla see, et sa pead tund aega iga nädal logima taaskide kaupa. Vaata, See võib tavaliselt nõuavad mingi kas viieteist minuti või poole tunni täpsust, nagu
Õpetaja: et sa. Noh, kui sa teed nagu mingi viis minutit tööd, Siis sa ei pane. Sa teed seitse minutit tööd. Sa ei seda nagu ei pane nagu kirja
Õpetaja: sa ümmardad. Jah, noh, mina ei tea, No enamus asjad lõpus kipuvad niikuinii minema. Niimoodi. Vaata, kas tekib mingi. Eks? Ikka tunde või Tegin terve päeva. Vaata või terve nädala.
Õpetaja: Vahet pole, onju? Aga päevalõikes pead neid ikka. Noh, kuidagi tunnid Ütleme mingi täpsuse. Nad annavad ette. Vaata, millega sa pead ütlema. Vaata, et pä Päriselus Niikuinii opereerid, nagu sul on mingi mitu taaski. Vaata
Õpetaja: kahe peale. Paned enamvähem kokku. Vaata, et ma mine. Kaheksa tundi peab päevast ära süstama. Seal ongi natukene. See pitsa värk ka. Vaata, on ju. Et. Ohohoo, Rain. Vaata, sul on siin juba mingi miljon tundi nagu selle Taskiga Oled nagu,
Õpetaja: tead, mingisuguste Asjade Standardid on ka ette nähtud.
Õpetaja: See asi. Oleme selleks ajaks valmis või?
Õpetaja: Ee, näiteks, ee, no, deadline vä. No see siin ei saa vastata üheselt. See on.
Õpetaja: Sul on oma toode kui kriitiline see meil on. Kas see on nagu mingi aspirational Deadline. On meil mingi deadline, millest ei saa üle minna. Kas meil on rätsepas? Ja mingid ütleb, et polgu olla valmis? Selleks ajaks ma Ostan. No kõik sõltub. Vaata, see deadline I kohta. Projekt, kus sa töötad.
Õpetaja: Niukest asja ei ole, aga on ikkagi nagu selles mõttes, ma arvan. Mingid üldised ootused küll, et ee, et juuniori kohta saadakse aru, et ta läheb kaua aega, sest ta peab vales hakkama õppima ja Vaatama projektiga käima Vaata Onju,
Õpetaja: et. Et ei ole nagu seda. Vaata, et seenior teab, et ta teeks seal põhimõtteliselt viie minutiga ära vaata Ja nüüd on nagu, et. No meie juunior peaks selle nagu tegema tunni või kahega ära, et,
Õpetaja: et, ee, juuniorite puhul ikka arvestatakse, et nagu, Nagu, noh, et läheb kaua lähebki aina. Vaata. Aga see ka näitab. Võibolla seda, et kas see inimene nagu sobib meie meeskonda või mitte. Vaata, et
Õpetaja: alguses on kindlasti väga suur. Nagu selles mõttes, et ee, ootused on alati hästi madalad, nagu, nagu selles osas, et ee, Ta, Noh, pigem mina olen nagu näinud seda mindset I, et juuniorit ikkagi alguses oleks niuksed armulised nagu,
Õpetaja: et ee, ei olda nagu pahased Seeniorile, Kellele maksad niimoodi, et ee, ettevõte. Ma mõtlen niimoodi, et ninast verd lendab. Vaata, on ju loomulikult seal on mingid ootused, et ta Ei istu mingisuguse väikse asjaga kuradi taga mingi nädal. Aega. Vaata, onju? See palk makstakse, on niivõrd suur onju.
Õpetaja: Aa, mis on siis nagu See hea tava. Kas sa nagu müüd kliendile mingi iks koguse tunde, et ta teab palju või siis.
Õpetaja: Ja ei, selles mõttes et, noh, Ma. Ma ei ole osalenud kunagi selles protsessis, Aga eks see on ikkagi selles mõttes nagu läbirääkimised. Nagu iga teine Onju, et kui keegi Tuleb sulle ee. Nagu, Noh, sul tööd nagu niiöelda ostma. Vaata, onju et. Kuule, et tehke mulle niukene infosüsteem, vaata, et siis ikka nagu Arutatakse, et. Noh, mis nad arvavad? Vaata,
Õpetaja: et kaua läheb. Ja ja mis saab tehtud ja niukest nagu arutlusi saab pidada seal niiöelda selle Projekti alguses üldises mahus, kui ka jooksvalt. Vaata onju, et. Noh, kui tihatuuri kaupa näiteks ehitatakse juurde, tehakse nagu inkrimmentaalselt Igast asju, onju, et, Noh, ka. Meil selle järgmise asjaga läheb? Mis me arvame? Vaata, onju.
Õpetaja: Ja. Ja kui ei lähe niimoodi, siis tavaliselt, eks ikka viisakalt minnakse Nagu tagasi ja öeldakse, vaata. Et. Noh, et, ee.
Õpetaja: Teate, et me ei sõltumata Vaata, point on see et kes nagu maksab, vaata, onju, Ega ega selles mõttes, et ka arendusettevõtted kindlasti võtavad üsna palju tunde enda kanda. Vaata, noh, oma töötajale. Nad peavad niikuinii maksma, Võibolla neil Isegi mingisugust arendajat, kes nagu teevad oü kaudu. Vaata, et, noh, maksma peavad igame, aga nad söövad selle nagu enda kasumimarginaalist ära, vaata. Et Kui kui vot siin on küsimus, et kas tahab nagu meie pärast kauem aega või
Õpetaja: on see mingi tehniline asi või üldse kellestki teisest sõltume. Vaata, et mingi keerukus on tekkinud, on ju? Või? On nagu midagi. Keerukus on tekkinud nagu ettenägematust asjadest et mida me realistlikult ei saanud nagu ette näha, et on väga keeruline, Aga nüüd on osutunud keeruliseks. Siis ikkagi. Klient Tavaliselt maksab selle kinni. Võibolla on ka mingi Kahasse variante, et see on.
Õpetaja: Kas ma mõtlen, kui klient tuleb rahulikult, hakkabki talle tõestama, näidates, kui mitte, et kuna need on tehtud, et Mis on tehtud,
Õpetaja: kui kui see selleni läheb. Aga ma arvan, et need nii detaili ei minda kunagi. Vaata, et ega siin on alati see. Vaata, et koostööpartnerid üritavad hoida nagu ilusaid suhteid. Vaata sellepärast, et mõlemad mõlemad pooled on päeva lõppkokkuvõttes tegelikult aa huvitatud sellest samast missioonist
Õpetaja: Ee, saada võimalikult kvaliteetne asi Ee, võimalikult kiirelt ja. Ja võimalikult, ee, soodsalt. Okei, Ai, kes nagu arendusettevõttel, võib olla seal natukene motivatsiooni, et Sa viimane osa ei ole nagu see tema motivatsioon Kõige rohkem. Vaata, et see tuleks võimalikult odav by the way Siin On see kolmnurk ka
Õpetaja: siin on. Ma ei mäleta kuidas seda nimetatakse. Inglise keeles kuskil teie ülesse. Meil on kvaliteet Qualit.
Õpetaja: Siis Meil on ee, raha ehk Kulu on ju?
Õpetaja: Meil On kiirus.
Õpetaja: Kõike kolme ei ole võimalik saada. Alati on ainult võimalik kaks saada.
Õpetaja: No mõtleme selle natukene, kui sa Tahad saada. Midagi kiiresti
Õpetaja: Nüüd Järgmine valik on see, et sa. Sa saad selle kiiresti.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on see Vaata, et ee, siis kui Te tahate seda kiiresti saada? Ma võin kakskümmend kuradi arendajat peale. Palun väga
Õpetaja: maksa.
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd ütlen, et ei, ei, raha meil ei ole, Aga tehke see asi kiirelt.
Õpetaja: No me teeme siis selle väikse meeskonnaga selle kiirelt valmis.
Õpetaja: Aga siis on nagu seda, nagu kvaliteetist on natukene Halb, kui te mõtlete, et. Okei,
Õpetaja: mina tahan maksta või ütleme niimoodi, et ma tahan kvaliteeti
Õpetaja: ja mul on, ee, palju raha,
Õpetaja: Okei, siis sa seda. Jah, Okei, see siis, kui sa kõigest oled nõud maksma nagu noh põhiline argument on ikkagi, seda, et et kui sa tahad mingist asjast nagu alla anda. Vaata siis siis see kuskil maksab kätte. Nagu midagi lonkab,
Õpetaja: et kui sa. Oota, ma tahtsin öelda seda. Vaata, Kui sa tahad mingit kvaliteetset asja saada. Vaata, on ju Ja, noh, sul ei ole raha, Vaata, on ju? Ee, et palju maksta on Ju sa tahad kvaliteeti? Tehke hästi ja ma vaatan seda varianti. Kui sa tahad, et me tahame, et tehke, palun, Hea asi meile,
Õpetaja: aga Meie raha on selles mõttes nagu piiratud. Et meil ei ole nagu väga palju raha. Vaata, siis on see, et vaata kiirus. Kannatan
Õpetaja: no Me maksad siin mingi odavalt ja mingi paar venda, nagu teevad, onju? Aga nad teevad ja teevad ja teevad ja saate sellest mõttes aru sa kuskilt internetist Tegelt ka selle asja ülesse.
Õpetaja: Ee, see sama asi nagu et siin on see kaheksa. Kas sellel
Õpetaja: aja mõõtmine, et sa Panedki projekti jooksma sest. Noh, näiteks kui sul on. Ma ei tea, ma ei saa üleüldse vastata. Vaata, minul ei ole kuskile pandud, aga Loomulikult tehnilisi lahendusi. Kuidas kontrollida, et kaua sa töötad ja nii edasi ei jää? Kasvõi ise mingid, kui sul, on kümme projekti
Õpetaja: on, niimoodi et sa lähed sisse. Seal on see.
Õpetaja: Ei pea.
Õpetaja: Ma ei, ma ei tea, ma. Ma arenduses seda kunagi pole kasutanud. Ärge unustage, üks Sama Tiket on analüütikul testijal arendajal Deployment vennal. Nagu Ee, mina Nii kaua kui olen töötanud, siis selles mõttes on, on see,
Õpetaja: et sa Ise nagu paned. Vaata, et. Et see, et ma teen.
Õpetaja: Jah, me võime seda vaadata vahetunnil. Vaata, et kuidas teil on ja võibolla on Ajad muutunud ka?
Õpetaja: Jah, ja on igasuguseid erinevaid lahendusi ka, Nagu, mis on sul arvutis ja nii edasi Vaata, botomline on kõige tähtsam, et Lihtsalt seda teada, et. Noh, siiralt kasutatakse selle jaoks.
Õpetaja: Okei, aga läheme nüüd edasi Ee,
Õpetaja: meil on siin. Meil on Epicust Tahtsin rääkida. Epic on siis niiöelda katus taask
Õpetaja: mille alla tulevad niiöelda väiksed taaskid.
Õpetaja: Ja ütleme, niimoodi et päeva lõpuks ongi see, ka, et, noh, Lhv S Oli samamoodi, et võtsime ette mingisuguse kindla uue asja. Vaata, mida me tahtsime välja arendada. Siis ma tegin niimoodi, et kõik taaskid läksid konkreetselt selle epiku alla. Ja siis nendel suurtel ülemustel oli siis tegelikult ülevaade, et nagu palju tunde on nagu läinud
Õpetaja: siiamaani või või siis projekti lõpus. Vaata. Ja nemad loomulikult. Ee, rehkendaksid selle loomulikult oma peas rahaks.
Õpetaja: Ee, võttes siis aluseks nagu mingi keskmise arendaja ee, tunnihinda ja võibolla Isegi mitte niiöelda nii niivõrd nagu oma tegelt seal oligi. Umbes niimoodi, et nad võtsid näiteks mingi viiskümmend eurot tund, või mida iganes nad
Õpetaja: Kui Nad tulid kunagi ütlema, et Kas see projekt läks nagu hästi halvasti? Sest nad ei öelnud kunagi nagu tunde otsased, vaid Nad ütlesid, et see on juba sada Tuhat maksma läinud. Vaata, nad rääkisid alati niimoodi,
Õpetaja: et nad ikkagi panevad tunnid nagu
Õpetaja: ee niiöelda siis ee, rahalistesse numbritesse, nagu kõik siin maamunal.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, ja siis kuidas nad said ülevaadet? Noh, siiralt lähed, vaatad, et palju selle epiku alla on nagu läinud nagu tunde. Sellepärast, et see süsteem võtab automaatselt kokku. On ju, et sa saad. Noh, raporti mõttes sa saad siin igasugust ee raportit, mis tahad.
Õpetaja: Kuidagi määratakse nagu ette ära ka. Näiteks see, kes koostab kogu selle kava. Vaata, ma võin jälle nagu enda omast kogemusest rääkida Kahe koha peal. Ei,
Õpetaja: nagu ei määra. Nagu meil kuskil ei määratud ette. Kui kaua sa seda pead? Tegema Ee, on on niukene asi Nagu vaata või või? Kuule, ma ei tule meelde, kuidas seda pokkerit kutsutegi. Aa, on ka niimoodi. Vaata, et on koosolek, kus arutatakse seda, Mis me planeerime? Ja inimesed panevad seal niukseid kaarte. Need on kaardid. Ee, mis on see? Üks, kolm, seitse, Mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuidas
Õpetaja: Jah, Kuldlõige. Aa, need numbrid. Need on niuksed, kaardid ja raskusastmed. Vaata, et põhimõtteliselt arutatakse mingisugust taaskoosolekul ja igaüks peab panema nagu numbri, Vaata mis? Sa nagu, mis see raskustase on? Vaata või mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Ee, et kui raske see on, on ju siis niimoodi. Kõik Paned oma kaardid nähtavale. Vaata, kui kaardi on välja valjunud, siis vaadatakse kahte äärmust,
Õpetaja: kes pani kümme tundi kümme või. Üks vaata on Ju, nagu raskusaste
Õpetaja: ja Siis nagu mõlemad pooled peavad ka enda. Nagu põhjendama. Vaata, et miks nemad arvavad, et see on väga kerge Teine pool peab nagu põhjendama. Miks sa arvad, see on nagu tohutult raske, onju? Ja siis ilmselt leitakse kuskilt see kuld niikuinii, et kuidagi hinnatakse raskusastet ja selle järgi Võib ka siis tegelikult nagu põhimõtteliselt, nagu planeerida mingit aega, et mis me nagu mõtleme. Aga Gen, vaata, küsimused on hästi. Individuaalsed.
Õpetaja: Kultuur on Erinev lähenemine on erinev. Ettevõtete suurus on erinev. Mis seal üldse pannakse? Nagu mingisuguseid planeerimise. Nagu mingi. Palju Sind hakkab minema. Aega ja nii. Edasi. Lihtsalt. Mehed istuvad arvuti taha ja kütavad lihtsalt. Vaata et, ruttu midagi valmis saada on. Ju
Õpetaja: et, see kõik on hästi sõltuv et, Nendes nendele küsimustele. Tegelikult ei ole ka kunagi võimalik käest vastata.
Õpetaja: Ainult kogemusest. Saan rääkida mida? Tean
Õpetaja: Ee, et, ee, ja ma ütlen ka, Et, ee, Noh, üldjoontes kusjuures igal pool ei mõõdeta ka aega. Nagu. Ei tehtagi ajalogimist
Õpetaja: et on ka ettevõte, kes ei tegele sellega nagu,
Õpetaja: Ee, nagu ma ütlesingi. Vaata, väiksemad ettevõtted. Ee, nende jaoks. Seal on lihtsalt see, et Job seal jälgitakse seda, et tööd liiguvad ja töö saab valmis
Õpetaja: Sest et
Õpetaja: neil ei ole nagu neil on mingi palgatöötajaid. Ja neil ei ole nagu mingi oma projekt või toode, vaata et Neil Ei ole nagu seal. Seda ee mõõtmist neil üldse vajagi. Ja et mul on nagu olnud kaaskolleege, kes on suundunud teistesse ettevõtetesse, ma Kuidagi on ikka alati jutustaks tulnud. Vaata, kas te logite aega või mitte. Mitmed on öelnud, et te ei logi. Vaata, selles ettevõttes ei Logita aega,
Õpetaja: aga ärme nüüd sellele kinni ei jää. Ee, lähme nüüd edasi, palun.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui me võtame nüüd taskid lahti, siin nad on niimoodi epikute all. Niiöelda teemade kaupa.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see järjekord ei pruugi olla Aga Noh, mina olen muidugi need taskid teinud. Nad on suht järjekorras Isegi nende numbritega. Meil hakkavad minema väiksest suuremaks numbriks. Vaata aga, vahepeal nagu hüpleb ka. Ärge üldse nendele numbritele mõelge, sest päris elus on juba mingi sada. Seitsekümmend neli ja
Õpetaja: kakssada. See on lihtsalt. See on lihtsalt tiketi number nagu mitte midagi Ei, ole,
Õpetaja: aga kuidas me kasutame, on see. Vaata, et on Board
Õpetaja: ja Bordil on siis nad niimoodi ikkagi pandud Selles mõttes järjekorda, et kuidas me sooviksime teha seda arendust, Siin on sõltuvus ju teineteisest.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd päris taskis. Kui ma teen ühe taski lahti. Ta teeb niukse Preview vaatega ma alati klikin siia lingi, peale, et läks nagu täisvaatesse üle ekraani.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis hakkab see pihta pealkirjaga. Siis tuleb Description
Õpetaja: bla, bla, Bla Paremal pool on staatused. Aa, need staatused saab ise timmida nii palju, kui tahad.
Õpetaja: To analyse in development review.
Õpetaja: Ee, kodruud. Meil näiteks elav ees ei olnud etapina oli, aga mitte Chiras. Aa, siis on mida iganes need on lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Me peame lõpuks jõudma lõpustaatustega. Aa, et siin on ainult see, mis Tuleb vaikimisi kaasa. To do in progress Done. Noh, enam nagu lihtsamalt, nagu ei saa, vaata, on ju
Õpetaja: aga päris arenduses on neid samme Natukene rohkem, Ma ütlen ka Isegi tasuta versioonis Saate oma projekti nii nagu tahate. Mis on, mis? On need sammud ja need samad samad Astmed on siin. Ee, ujumisradadega on nagu ujumisrajad.
Õpetaja: Selle mõte on see, et see asi peab hakkama siit rändama nagu põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: Noh, keegi, nagu, Ee, sa saad jällegi nagu mitut asja saad. Erinevat pidi teha, et saad siit tõsta. Vaata, näiteks in progress või saad teistmoodi et sa, Lähed taski sisse, kus on tavaliselt ikkagi liigub, et ütled in Progress saate mõttes aru.
Õpetaja: Päeva lõpuks on lihtsalt staatused ja visuaalne representatsioonid ja Siin on siis nagu boardistiilis. Vaata, lihtsalt võta järgmine kes iganes ja küta
Õpetaja: selliseid boorde katsume. Isegi tegelikult sprintida sest, lihtsalt ülevaade et, neid See sellist poodi saab ka tegelikult sprintsüsteemis. Lihtsalt vaadata, kuidas me nagu praegu mõtleme. Vaata ja see on nagu jälgimiseks, see on rohkem nagu nende teema vaata. Ja nad tahavad, kuidas
Õpetaja: webline võib nii öelda. Jah, ja ja ülevaade. Põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: nüüd meie esimene taask on siin. Ee, error Vaade. Hästi, lihtsalt alustame.
Õpetaja: Ma teen selle lahti. On tema nimi. Front and Bank
Õpetaja: Ee. Error. Lehekülg. Midagi läks valesti Description ütleb loo error Lehekülje, vaade, kaldkriips. Error Pilt on ka
Õpetaja: midagi taolist. See on väike komponendi nimi Noh, Ee Niuksed asjad tavaliselt taskis ei ole, aga aga Ka võibolla mingi faili nimi või asi nagu arenda enda välja mõelda. Ee, aga siin on loomulikult detailsemad. Uus vaatekomponent Error voe aadressil kaldkriips, Error Lisa juurde. Heeder tekst. Midagi. Läks valesti Lisa juurde. Mingi Gif
Õpetaja: Aa testi. Error vaadet minnes vastavale error aadressile. Noh, umbes niimoodi ongi Päriselus ka. Nüüd kvaliteet tekst. Vaata, sõltub Aa suuresti selle taskirjutajast. Ee,
Õpetaja: on ettevõtted. Kus on analüütikud, kes neid kirjutavad, on ettevõtted. Kus Arendajad Ise kirjutavad neid, taske ise, analüüsivad ja teevad Jällegi, Ee, see ettevõtte suurus. Ja mitte ainult suurus ka lihtsalt tegelikult kultuur ja struktuur. Noh, Ma mõtleks praegu kohe mingi
Õpetaja: proekspert. Ma tean, neil on niuksed meeskonnad, kes ise nagu majandavad. Ja Ee, on täiesti Flat.
Õpetaja: Pole mingit asju, Noh, seal midagi on, Nagu, võibolla. Nagu, et kaine. Keegi, kes nagu jälgib et kuidagi tiimis siin. Asjad liiguvad edasi ja nii edasi. Aga et Kuidas, nagu kes kirjutab taaski. Kas arendaja või analüütik sõltub. No eesti energias. Lhv S on selleks analüütik
Õpetaja: Ee, näiteks
Õpetaja: nii vahet pole. Aa, nüüd taaski. Kvaliteet jälle sõltub. Vaata, mõni kirjutab Jumala ilusti asjad lahti. Võtab pilveste eks? Teine paneb mingi. Noh Aa, mina minu kogemus, Lhv St. Ma lasen teile Arvata. Mis te arvate? Aa, kes kirjutas paremat taaski? Kas Aa vana kogenud olija
Õpetaja: või uus ee meeskonnaliiton analüütik, Miks uus püüdlik
Õpetaja: tahavad iseenda jaoks peavad võibolla seda asja seal lahti kirjutama, et kuidas see töötab?
Õpetaja: Ja siis, need kes need vanad analüütikud Olid Siis nagu niimoodi. Et nemad on harjunud, et nad töötavad seal mingisuguste arendajatega, kellel on viimased viis kümme aastat koos töötanud
Õpetaja: noh. Neile, Sa võidki öelda, et tee niisugune asi
Õpetaja: ja las siis see arendaja ise nagu analüüsib. Aga noh, eks nad kuidagi need lakoonilised nagu Description Id tulevad päeva lõpuks. Ega keegi, kui seda analüüsi kirjutab tingimata. Ta ei tea isegi, kelle lauale see maandud.
Õpetaja: Ta kirjutab sealt See on Nii palju asju, mida vaja kõik ära teha ja lahti analüüsida. Kes sellega hakkab tegelema? Selles faasis pole üldse mõeldudki. Isegi kui on mõeldud Mingi väike tiim Asju tehakse tiimides nagu. Vaata isegi projektide vaatest, et mõtleme, et mingi kaks arendajat. Ja mida iganes, onju, kes nad hakkavad olema. Jumal teab
Õpetaja: siis, kui see aeg saabub, kätte vaadatakse et. Noh, võibolla üks nagu vanem oli võibolla mingi noorem ja mida iganes kand on niimoodi. No kuidas iganes. Jällegi Kultuur. Aa, süsteemid, asjad. Igas
Õpetaja: ettevõttes oma staaf.
Õpetaja: Nii et, ee, Jah, Tavaliselt minule tundus küll, et iga Kord, Kui oli see vana olija kirjutas Ma teadsin, et sealt mingi kaks rida näeb sealt Descriptionist
Õpetaja: Kui oli üks uutest või uuem uutest, Siis sa teadsid, et seal on natukene rohkem. Ega see eksammustas neid ennist ennast ka. Vaata, et noh, kui sul on väga kui ma Näengi seal analüüsi on kirjutatud. Mul on nagu. Noh, kui on Niukene kultuur, vaata, et analüütik kirjutab ja analüütik vastutab, kui sul on mingeid küsimusi. Kelle poole sa pöördud?
Õpetaja: Analüütiku poole? Noh, kas me hakkame pingpongi Mängima? Ja igapäev suhtlema? Või kirjutad mulle lahti selle Up to you, On ju,
Õpetaja: ee, et see ka kõik sõltub Mingid pildid, asjad. Jah, Frontend is Täitsa vabad võivad olla isegi olemas. Ja nii edasi,
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Mida meie hakkame tegema? Siis Me hakkame mängima päris elu, Et, ee. See on nüüd meie taas.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mida me kõigepealt peame tegema? Ma Kõigepealt kommitin kõik muud asjad praegult ära.
Õpetaja: Aa, võibolla ennem kui ma. Aa,
Õpetaja: ee, et te peaks. Äkki te tulete ühe korra veel, Mulle Lihtsalt järgi sobib.
Õpetaja: Ma teen nagu aja kokkuvõtmiseks. Ma Kustutan seda, ära mida pole vaja.
Õpetaja: Ee, komponentide alt. Ma kustutan. Mis asi Icon Community Documentation.
Õpetaja: See on kõik mingi, kes on mingi valmistab It poolt alati peale. Ee,
Õpetaja: nagu uue projektiga. Ja nüüd põhimõtteliselt ja siis kõik need Ma kustutangi. Jah, aga ma mõtlen, ärge praegu jälgige. Tulge lihtsalt järgi. Vaata, et siis kõik hakkavad siin mingeid kursarid mingeid asju taga, ajama Ja nii edasi. Ma teen selle asja nagu suht nagu niukseks.
Õpetaja: Selle kustutame ka ära.
Õpetaja: Refactor Anyway Home View võib jääda. Ee, sellisel kujul Selle tõstan alla
Õpetaja: ja siis hakkame niimoodi vaikselt. Ee, minema.
Õpetaja: Setup I. Võtame ära. Typescript. I, me ei tee.
Õpetaja: Oota korra, Poe ka veel Ära indeksis. Üks ruut sobib.
Õpetaja: Midagi vist puudub olema. Korra lihtsalt vaatan, Kui ma käivitun uuesti. Kas mul midagi automaatselt ette viskab?
Õpetaja: Ei tohiks, Võibolla Jäi midagi kuskile. Tundub, et ei jäänud
Õpetaja: võibolla tegelikult terminalis korra käivitada. Ka. Mis asi see oli? Npm Brun lint, vä.
Õpetaja: Midagi siit ei tulnud. Ee vast. Võiks jääda meil niukseks normaalseks Asjaks. Ma korra vaatame. Mis siin komitee all. Toimub.
Õpetaja: Mm, panen start lihtsalt selleks. Ee,
Õpetaja: No kui midagi jäi, siis näete siin praegu.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta ei läinud kohe esimese käsu peale.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, tulge nüüd. Kõik vär järgi. Aga Tehke niimoodi praegult. Tehke niimoodi. Minge korra. Lihtsalt masteri peale. Kõigepealt.
Õpetaja: Aa, kui teil midagi on seal minge korra. Tehke checkout. Aa, Masteri peal, Kustutage nüüd oma vana enda. Päris nimeline. See, mis ei ole mingi V, üks ega V. Kaks Me tahame, et teil kõigil tekib sellest Õpetajast
Õpetaja: tekib ee, enda nimeline haru, sest see hakkab olema Teie Master Haru.
Õpetaja: Aa, me tahame kõik olla sellel puhtal seisul see tähendab seda, et kustutage enda nimeline Haru lokali alt. Ära Kustutage enda nimeline haru sealt. Aa, kõiki nende inimeste haru. Mis Iganes V ühed kahed, kustutage kõik need ära Sealt, Aa, lokali ja Remote i alt ära.
Õpetaja: Ja peale seda Fetchi Fetchi.
Õpetaja: Aga unustage ära, et kui mitte, ainult vaadake, et teil midagi kaasa ei lohiseks
Õpetaja: All Back. Iga kõik, mis on
Õpetaja: ja lõppmissioon, on see, et te võtate õpetajast ühe uue haru ja Panete suurte tähtedega lihtsalt oma eesnime kõik.
Õpetaja: Ja see siis on nüüd mängult teie Masteraru,
Õpetaja: et oleks. Kujutage ette, et te olete üksikarendaja,
Õpetaja: kui Te olete tiimiarendaja. Ja siis see teie nimeline Haru ongi. Mastarharu ja mina mängin täpselt samamoodi,
Õpetaja: et päris mastanaru vastu me kõik ei saa mängida. Kahjuks me teeme kõik seda sama Staffli kogu aeg.
Õpetaja: Mingi merge konflikt Aa merge konflikti otsas
Õpetaja: ja lõpptulemus siis hakkab teil, olema, et Te olete täpselt sellel samal joonel nagu mina.
Õpetaja: Võta sellest õpetajast. Võta oma uue aru.
Õpetaja: Ma veel ühe pu ühe. Push I teen, aga Ma minu meelest juba tegin. Niikuinii
Õpetaja: Siin ei ole mul midagi pushida, Nii et kõik, mis on pilves, on Up to date anyway, aga Tehke ennem.
Õpetaja: On kriitik kriitiline ja parem teha uuesti. Lihtsalt ja
Õpetaja: kustuta kohe ära. See mina jälle. Ma ütlen, et seda oksa ei saa saagida, mille peal istud. Mine kuhugi mujale. Kustuta oma vananimeline asi. Ära veendu, et see on kus, et et kui ma praegu teen, nagu siia. Aa, nüüd. Haru majanduse peal. Teen
Õpetaja: siis. Vaatame, mis seis mul Siin on. Ma just Remodi all mõtlen. Vaata ma peaksin hakkama kõiki Nagu teid nägema. Varsti nad ei ole välja push inud.
Õpetaja: Te võite selle asja ka ära teha. Siis te näete kohe, kas Bush õnnestub või mitte, te ei ole ühtegi kommitti teinud, Aga te tegite just uue haru. Ju, on ju nii?
Õpetaja: Tehke see push ära. Noh, mina olen juba teinud. Ma ei saa seda rohkem teha.
Õpetaja: Idee järgi peaks meil tulema siis sinna kõigile remoodi all. Me peaksime nägema kaheksateist üheksateist, nime. Üks on õpetaja,
Õpetaja: et kõik teie harud ilmuvad sinna alla, Et kui ma nüüd praegu
Õpetaja: ma praegu vaatan seda arvu, siis ma ei saa samas puhul pilti,
Õpetaja: mis samasugust pilti sul vaja on.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan kontrollida ära Sealt koodi ei vaatagi, see on kõik. Kestan ee
Õpetaja: ja Nüüd lihtsalt lähed ülevalt. Aa, Võtad, siit. Ei, no seal ka Vaata, See kehtib selle aru kohta, mille peal oled. Vaata,
Õpetaja: Riho haru, ja Kui see nüüd õnnestub. See tähendab, et sul seal ees pilves midagi. Pole. Seda selle nimelist haru.
Õpetaja: Noh, logimeja kütab tundub. Et, sa pead veel kitarr sisse logima. Pane Auto rais.
Õpetaja: Sa pead. Siis sa pead logima,
Õpetaja: palun.
Õpetaja: Sa võid selle bussiga pärast ka tegeleda, vaata Peaasi, et Sa saad all alla Said. Tõmmata ju. Vaata,
Õpetaja: Ee, väga kaua. Ei tahaks siin ka peatada. Käsi püsti. Kes veel midagi teeb, et ma Tean, kas ma. Mida ma. Kaua ma pean ootama. Ma jälgin siis, et kõik käed lähevad alla.
Õpetaja: Ma rain Rain kodus teeb midagi Seal Ma Ei tea, mina ei tea. See on. Praegu võin öelda, et mina ei tea, mis toimub
Õpetaja: ja kui Fets teha, siis nagu suures pildis, nagu peaks tulema. Näete siin juba
Õpetaja: nii?
Õpetaja: Kas kõik said enda nimelise haru ette? Vaata, see pilve Push Im ei ole isegi praegu Primaarne tegelikult. See on ülisavi.
Õpetaja: No peaasi, et tal peaasi, et tal endal ei olnud oma nimelist Remote I juba ees. Vaata siis ta Ei saa, Push Ida, vaata enam.
Õpetaja: Nii, Kas võin edasi minna
Õpetaja: nüüd? Järgmine samm, mis te teete, on see, et nüüd te olete oma Haru peal.
Õpetaja: Ee, tulete. Ütlete New Branch ja ja siia te panete sidekriipsu ja suurte tähtedega feeb
Õpetaja: viis ja siis vajutate create.
Õpetaja: See nüüd on arenduse haru.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd see nagu kõrvaline haru, kus te saate toimetada möllata Ee, teha rahulikult, asjad valmis ja lõpuks läheb see Siis Sinna viimistletud produktina läheb Masterisse tagasi.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis teie enda nimelisseharusse onju? Kui te näete oma nime, siis mõelge Master, Ee, ja kui Te näete seda arenduse haru. Siis ärge mõelge seda, et see päriselus oleks ka. Näiteks Artur Feb. Viis onju vaid päriselus oleks See lihtsalt Feb viis Lihtsalt baskinumber
Õpetaja: Nii mina teen Create ka ära.
Õpetaja: Okidoki. Ee, nüüd pange kõik tabid kinni. Teeme nagu hästi lihtsa vaate ja võtke lahti. See failistruktuur. Tehke korra klõps.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Meil on öeldud, et loo uus vaatekom. Komponent. Error View aadressil. Kaldkriips error.
Õpetaja: Sellest seda ruutingut me ei saa ennem teha, kui meil see komponent ise on olemas. Et siin on nagu järjekord. On nagu sissekirjutatud.
Õpetaja: Me peame kõigepealt tegema ühe uue vaate Ja see vaade on põhimõtteliselt see, et mis see Error View saab olema, on niimoodi. Meil on mingisugused vead, mis meil Back End Is on ära programmeeritud ja defineeritud, et niuksed nigu võib tulla.
Õpetaja: Need on vead, mida me teame.
Õpetaja: See vaade nüüd on selle jaoks, Kui on mingisugune veaolukord. Aga ei ole ükski nendest veaolukordadest, millest keda me oleme osanud ette ära näha ja ette programmeerida, No ta on Lihtlabase näitaja. Kui ikka taustal andmebaas kukub maha. Noh, Back end kuskil vea saab,
Õpetaja: et. Noh, seda me ei programmeeri. Nagu, et, Oi, andme Paalt kukkus maha. Meil ei ole vaja kliendile öelda. Vaata, et andmekaaslikus maha. Või mingi pilveteenus. Näiteks mis on kriitiline meil seal kuidagi mingi Asi,
Õpetaja: mis kukub maha. Vaata, me ei pea iga asja kohta ütlema. Nagu inimesele. Vaata, et midagi läheks valesti. Me ei pea kogu aeg ütlema, et see läheks valesti. Too oleks valesti. Me peame ainult neid asju ütlema. Aa, mille üle tema tegelikult on? Kontroll
Õpetaja: Neid asju peame ütlema, et läks valesti. Ja Mõned asjad ei ei tulevad lihtsalt Alerdina või mida iganes, onju? Ma toon näite. Näiteks Aa, uue kasutaja registreerimine
Õpetaja: No frontend Ei tea igal juhul seda, et ee, mis email on juba süsteemis.
Õpetaja: Aga kui mina tahan regada nagu sama nimega emaili ka Aadressil Uut kontot on ju. Ee, sõnum läheb teele. Palun Registreeri ära nagu. Uus Konto On ju ja siis Tagasi Selles mõttes tuleb ee sõnum Niiöelda Back end ilt vea teatlejana. Vaata, et kahjuks.
Õpetaja: Sorry, Ee, selline kasutajanimi on juba olemas. Nagu et ei ei, saa. Vaata, on Ju
Õpetaja: seda me tahame ära programmeerida, et ee kasutaja. Siis nagu saab mingit tagasisidet seal vormil. Selle kasutaja nimi on Ju olemas, aga kui Midagi läheb. Ee, lihtsalt nii katki. Vaata, et server lihtsalt ütleb, et toimus mingi sisemine viga. Vaata, meil ei ole mitte midagi näidata, kui me seda ära ei programmeeri, siis ta näeb mingit koledust.
Õpetaja: Aga kui me paneme vähemalt. Kas te olete näinud seda? Ups, midagi läks valesti. Noh, see ongi Ups. Midagi ei läks valesti.
Õpetaja: Nii seda me praegu teeme.
Õpetaja: Me teeme sellist aa niiöelda vaadet, mis hakkab elama rajal Error.
Õpetaja: No proovime selle jaoks. Me võtame siis Source i alt lahti. Views, Kataloogi
Õpetaja: Tuleme, teeme parema klõpsu selle kataloogi peal New
Õpetaja: ja pakkuge mis Ma siit valin.
Õpetaja: Kuule, jah, Kas kõigil on see poekomponent nähtaval?
Õpetaja: Okei, pomm.
Õpetaja: Mis ta praegu siin alla küsib?
Õpetaja: Okei, faili nime me peame, kirjutama kohe. Me võime selle isegi ära kirjutada. See on Error View.
Õpetaja: Aga mida ta siin all pakub, on see, et vaata, et mis stiilis. Me tahame siis teha, kas Ee või Composition api, sest et seal see kirjaviis ja lähenemine on erinev. Loomulikult,
Õpetaja: nüüd vanasti oli templeid Üleval pool. Siis kustutasin midagi ära.
Õpetaja: Jah punase joone alla tegema ja läheb. Ikka Kõik läheb, Kitty.
Õpetaja: Teil on ka punane joon vä?
Õpetaja: Ei, Aa, okei, No üks. Tiiv sisse. Vaata ja unustab ära.
Õpetaja: Nii, aga mina tahaks nüüd seda järjekorda korda teha. Võtke see Scripti osa, edaspidi Me. Meil saab olema, asi, mis meid aitab. Control. X. Võtke ära. Kui see Scripti osa,
Õpetaja: Tõmmake see. Style Block siniseks ja pange sealt Control V.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi, et templeid ta oleks üleval mälet. Me juba seda arutasime. Mäletate, on ju?
Õpetaja: Me juba leppisime kokku, et me teeme niimoodi, et template on üleval.
Õpetaja: Nii üks stiiv on sees. Ee, üks keyboard Shortcut. Mida ma soovin teile õpetada, on Control alt. L.
Õpetaja: Ma korra Teen paigast ära. Mida teeb Control Control Idel Line Formating.
Õpetaja: Ta järjestab asjad niimoodi. Nagu tema aru, saab, et standardina klassikaliselt peab olema siin Just mõeldakse seda külgvahe paiknevust. Vaata, kui ma panen näiteks mingi niukse jama. Vaadake mingi no niukest koodi. Mina ei tahaks lugeda. Ei taha Ükski teine arendaja lugeda niimoodi standardina. See kood ei ole.
Õpetaja: Control on line formating.
Õpetaja: Kuna meil jaavas hakkab tulema ja ka siin tegelikult paar asja veel. Mida iga kord jälgida,
Õpetaja: Siis tegelikult on kokku kolm niukest asja, mida koodi korrastamiseks tahaks. Vajutada. Control l
Õpetaja: line formating Ee, veelgi Täpsemalt nagu see ärakaotamine. Te ei pea aru saama, mida see tähendab. Viimane asi on optimeeri Import Id,
Õpetaja: et kas on mingit importi, mis, Ee, on nagu kuskil importsektsioonis. Öeldakse, et palun impordi see fail siia sisse, et ma saaksin seda kasutada. Tegelikult keegi ei kasuta.
Õpetaja: Optimise. Imports Saadab selle pensionile, kustutab ise ära. Nüüd palju lihtsam on kõike kolme käsku korraga niiöelda. Ee, siis vajutada, et teha omal see koodifail ilusaks Ta ei tee vigu kord ega midagi.
Õpetaja: Ja kõige. Parem on kuidagi endale meelde jätta, et. Ee, noh, mida? Ma vajutan Control alt pead niikuinii peale hoidma. Ja nüüd üks haaval. Toksite siis teise sõrmega. Niimoodi hoiate kontrolli all, Siis võtate te isegi Appi
Õpetaja: Ilo Ja siis kuidas me seda mäletame. Hakkame edasi seda mäletama. On I Love optimizing.
Õpetaja: Noh, kuidagi niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Controlelt
Õpetaja: I l o midagi praegult ei juhtunud. Sellepärast kõik Oligi ideaalselt korras. Aga nüüd teie. See on nüüd. Ma panen käe südamele. Palun pidevalt. Klõpsige seda,
Õpetaja: Sest et kui keegi teine vaatab teie Koodi. Ja kui seal on justkui üks tühik. Rohkem kuskil kohas, kus mitte kunagi. Aa, tühikut ei ole Või veel vastupidi, tühik on puudu, Siis kui keegi arendaja vaatab sellele otsa, saate aru? Tal hakkab
Õpetaja: pisarate asemel verd voolama. Lihtsalt tunned, kuidas midagi kriidid Silmas
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, kui sa Iga Jumala päevaselt töötad koodiga ja sa oled aastate viisi harjunud nägema, et seal on see tühik. Ja kui seal, ei ole seda tühikut, Siis see ajab närvi
Õpetaja: Ja Pealegi,
Õpetaja: kui te tahate saavutada seda hetke, kus Code Reviews pannakse pöialt ilma ühegi tagasiside kommentaarita, siis praegult on See võimalus, kuidas ta lased sellel esimesel korral omal võimalusel mööda minna?
Õpetaja: Vanasti, kui Chat Chip It asja ei olnud
Õpetaja: ja kellegagi konsulteerida, tegidki oma parima koodi mida sa oskasid. Ja siis sa andsid. Ja nüüd mõlemal poolel on oma missioon. Arendajale on kirjutatud perfektne, ideaalne kood, kus Ei ole võimalik, mitte kui midagi öelda.
Õpetaja: See on missioon. Vähemalt minul on see missioon. Ja nüüd Review Tajal on oma missioon. Ma pean kaskui ühe asja leidma.
Õpetaja: Aga üks asi alguses peab olema. Mis saab improvida nüüd, kui teie
Õpetaja: tegelikult tegitegi ideaalse koodi, aga noh,
Õpetaja: siis te Saate selle review. Teate, kui lihtne on temal seda üles leida.
Õpetaja: Tema on lihtsalt nagu vaatab Changes I seal ühtegi Changes It ei ole,
Õpetaja: vaatab kõik failid, mis te olete teinud. Otsib faili Boost kasvõi lihtsalt ülesse. Näiteks siit samast. Need samad
Õpetaja: tuleb samamoodi. Paneb Intelligence näiteks I Love Optimising.
Õpetaja: See formateerib selle. Ära Teil leiab selle ühe tühiku ülesse.
Õpetaja: Siis ta tuleb. Vaatab nagu loll.
Õpetaja: Sul on siin üks tühik puudu, sõber, näiteks.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ta ütleb teile. Vaata, noh, oligi. Te olite nii lähedal nagu sellele päevale,
Õpetaja: kus ei ole midagi öelda, sest on siin ükskõik mis puudu,
Õpetaja: et ärge andke neid lihtsaid asju. Aga tegelikult asi oli isegi nendes lihtsates asjades. Kood peaks olema kogu aeg ilus ja puhas. See on lihtsalt basic hügieen.
Õpetaja: Kui te enamvähem olete Mingis failis isegi töö käigus. Ma ei, ma ei viitsi vahel isegi nagu, Ee, nagu mind ei huvita. Eriti nagu need paiknevad asjad, et korraks läheb paigast ära. Midagi, ma ütlen. See taanded asjad kogu aeg korda.
Õpetaja: Mind ka häirib, kui ma tulen kellegi arvuti taha Ja ma näen nagu eriti jaavas. Nagu tõsiselt nagu ajab närvi. Nagu Vaata, kuidas ma Kirjutan kõik kokku. Lihtsalt nagu miks, nagu, miks, miks. Ja siis nagu räägid, et palun vajutage seda nuppu, sest niikuinii pead mina, ma, nagu Alati ma näen kõik ära.
Õpetaja: Kus harjutus ma olen töötanud, kui ma. Ma ise ei mäleta,
Õpetaja: Ma käin kõik need failid läbi ja klõbistan Seda Mida iganes ma ei taha jätta, mitte midagi niukest nagu. Ja, noh, see on Basic endal. Siis ise ka leiad ülesse, vaatad Aa, Okei, kurat, siin. Nagu mingi ee, jäi, et hoidke oma kood struktuuri mõttes nagu ilusti korras.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd kus mul see vaade on, justkui olemas. Aa, mis see sisu siin pidi olema? Midagi läks valesti.
Õpetaja: Nüüd võtame selle harjumuse ära, et me alati mõtleme struktuurile, isegi kui täna Tundub, et nagu piisaks siin H. Üks taaskõmab niikuinii rohkemat pealkiri, Ja mingi asi bla blabla. Aga Jätame endale alati võimaluse, et me saame Kontrollida layout. I.
Õpetaja: Mis mu mõte siin võiks? Olla
Õpetaja: Noh, ragista kausi, et kogu aeg struktuuri hoida, mis? Kuidas,
Õpetaja: pole see? No võibolla lähemal Olen Mingit tiiba. On vaja teha küll, aga kuidas ma kontrollin seda layout i edaspidi, et nagu kõik oleksid täpselt nii, nagu mina tahan
Õpetaja: Kellegil turgatab mingi mõte. Rääkisime tänasel päeval sellest nii hea
Õpetaja: ja alla cool ülalt alla. Tahaks asju hoida Küll jah.
Õpetaja: Ahah, mis? Ma tahan Sealt vahet pole, me panime endale shortcut. No lähme siis sinna, kuhu me satume.
Õpetaja: Kui te panite selle shortcut i või favourite Seal nii, Nagu ma õpetasin, siis me oleme.
Õpetaja: No nii, või nii. Isegi me varem või hiljem peame sellele mõtlema. Siis iga kord, kui te teete Uue vaate? Mäleta? Nõue on siin sees, et siin peab olema üks child element. Vähemalt peab olema tegelt. Peab Täpselt üks Child element olema.
Õpetaja: Ee, see asi tegelikult Ei, armasta. Mitu last on praegult siin?
Õpetaja: Noh, ma panen ta nüüd visuaalseks. Mitu last on Template Il üks laps.
Õpetaja: Mitu last on? Ee, sellel template. Il
Õpetaja: ei ole ikka üks laps. Noh, ei, usu. Tõmbame siis kokku. Noh, üks laps on tal
Õpetaja: nii Mitu Noh, teeme selle viimase variandi ka ära? No see on nagu nii obvious. Juba
Õpetaja: kaks, on ju? Aa, tegelikult vanasti oli see täiesti Nõue Nüüd ta on natuke rohkem Flexible Iks läinud. Aa, vähemalt selle peamise templeti osas. Aga tegelikult peaks olema ainult üks. Tähendab, ainult üks Laps peaks olema. Kui me võtame, võtame siit praegult selle konteineri.
Õpetaja: Kui meeldiv ongi see, et kogu leht on selle konteineri sees, mis võimaldab meil oma layout i defineerida. Ärge siin selekteerige midagi. Tulge, Copy To Clipboard,
Õpetaja: Tule, Te panete selle lihtsalt siia template vahele. Niimoodi
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: No, meil siin taaskis öeldakse, et ee, on heeder. Ja siis mingi kihv.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis me praegult. Meil on lihtsalt vaja veergude mõttes mitut Veergu meil on vaja. Kui vaadata lihtsalt siia peale
Õpetaja: ühte veergu on ju?
Õpetaja: Siis on, niimoodi et me nüüd ülejäänud kaks kustutame ära
Õpetaja: ja Hetkel võib lihtsalt ee öelda. Ma panen lihtsalt praegult selle.
Õpetaja: Ma lihtsalt peab See See sisu läheb niikuinii muutuma. Ma panen lihtsalt praegu. Tead, midagi oleks näha, siis panen siia terror Vihu siia selle nime. Ahah, ma korra tahaks rääkida, Eksport Ja Fold ist. Ka
Õpetaja: See on voe komponent.
Õpetaja: See asi siin defineerib ära. Kuidas on selle komponendi nimi?
Õpetaja: Selle kogu selle faili nimi? Nagu ta saaks See faili nimi on olemas, Aga tema faili nimes on see punkt. Voe ka veel, onju? Ee, Sel selle komponendi nimi on Error View
Õpetaja: Export Default name osa on See, et mis? Kuidas me seda kutsume? Ma panin praatse komponendi nime. Põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: nii. Nüüd, kus mul see vaade on olemas, ee selle sisulise poole peale, et kuidas ta välja näeb? Kohe läheme ka, Aga saaks ennem sellega hakkama. Vaata, et see peab olema seotud rajaga
Õpetaja: error.
Õpetaja: Küsisin Mina teilt. Et Mis me nüüd? Siis? Kuhu me läheme? Mida me teeme, Ruuter Ruuteri indeksisse läheme.
Õpetaja: Teete selle klõps lahti?
Õpetaja: Peaks olema, et Hetkel siin. Selles massiivis on ainult üks element.
Õpetaja: See Siin see objekt.
Õpetaja: Kui me tahame teist samasugust juurde teha, paneme koma
Õpetaja: ja kui mõnusalt Nüüd Ärge nüüd seda. Ee, tublit, Copy Based või Dublitseerimine? Dublitseerimine. Miks ma praegu niimoodi tahaks seda dublitseerida?
Õpetaja: Kui ma teen nii, siis midagi On nagu tukses.
Õpetaja: Pole reavahetust.
Õpetaja: Kui te tahate Dublitseerida tulge niimoodi ülesse, et reavahetus on ka teeme Dublicate
Õpetaja: ja meil on see põhimõtteliselt ees. Nüüd, onju. Nüüd on ainult täidalüngad.
Õpetaja: Ee, see ei ole. Jason. Seda asja kutsutakse. Ee Trailing komma lohisev koma.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan, kas see eestlint Hakkab vinguma, sest et selle kohta tõesti on. Tavaliselt saab ka säte olla. Ee Ranlint.
Õpetaja: Mitte ühtegi Warning ut ee. Ühesõnaga. Treiling Komando lubab siin. Selle Script I osas kasutada.
Õpetaja: Ee, Jason ei luba treeningu omad see tekstifail mis on mõeldud andmete vedamiseks. Treilingu oma teeb automaatselt Ee Jason I katki.
Õpetaja: Siin võib
Õpetaja: nii. No meie jätame selle ülesse poole ja hakkame siis sellega toimetama. No mis see rada peab? Olema
Õpetaja: Error On ju nüüd name Võiks olla?
Õpetaja: Jah, ei ole Error View Sest et see on teekond,
Õpetaja: kui ma kunagi tahan programmiliselt öelda, et mine Palun vaade Lükka error ruudile, Siis ma kasutan seda nime.
Õpetaja: Ta ei ole View. Noh, võiks panna, Aga ärge unustage ära. Vaata, mis ma Just ütlesin, vaata. Komponendil on nimi. Mis on komponendi nimi?
Õpetaja: See Komponent, Mis me lõime? Tema nimi on Error View.
Õpetaja: Kui ma paneks siia ka juba programmiliselt hakkaks sellele viitama. Niimoodi. Siis See on nagu see läheb sassi. Vaata, nagu,
Õpetaja: noh, mulle ei meeldinud ka see, sellepärast see Lihtsalt sa see näitega oleks lihtsalt error. Mulle see ei meeldiks mul. Mulle meeldib see explicity siin praegu, et ta nagu täpselt ütleb. Ära
Õpetaja: Nüüd tema Copy Based Ina. Niiöelda avab. Aa, selle me kustutame. Ära. Nüüd on tähtis asi. Iga kord, kui te siin hakkate seda komponenti kirjutama.
Õpetaja: Ee, vaadake seda selle faili nime.
Õpetaja: Kas ta hakkab suure või väikse alguse tähega
Õpetaja: suurega? Siis nii peab kirjutama, aga me ei viitsi seda asja siin pikalt välja kirjutada. Mis võiks olla need kaks suurt tähte, mida me kirjutame?
Õpetaja: E ja V ja ta juba peaks pakkuma meile asju ja meid huvitab just see siin.
Õpetaja: Kas te näete seda noolekest, mis seal, on juures ka?
Õpetaja: Ta näitab seda, et see on Mingi väline komponent.
Õpetaja: Me soovime seda kasutada. Ja kui niipea kui ma vajutan siia, tab I, Noh, te võite juba vajutada, aga minu vaates Vaadake lisaks sellele, et siia Reale viisteist tuleb, siis see. Vabandust, Error View. Siis vaadake praegu minu ekraanil rea. Rida kolme
Õpetaja: vaid. Ta on Üks, Kaks, kolm.
Õpetaja: Mis ta veel tegi.
Õpetaja: Mhmh. Nüüd, kuidas tulevad vead?
Õpetaja: Kui sul on mingi lihtne komponent, siis mõni teeb seda asja
Õpetaja: kõik Kui sa Tabiga ei vali seda valikut, mida sa mõtled, siis importi ülesse ei tule.
Õpetaja: Ta küll ütleb siin punase joonega, et Kuule, Hello Ja kui punane pirn, mis seal tekib? Kui tuled siia, Homerdad peale,
Õpetaja: taas tuleb alt Enter. Ee pakub, et ee, lahendust Kui ainult üks Lahendus on, siis ta teeb automaatselt ära. Nüüd tuli Punane pirn ka. Ma nüüd nägin,
Õpetaja: et sa seda saab tagantjärgi ka teha, aga parem Saame lihtsalt harjumuseks, et Ev tuled. Otsid mingi asja üle, valid selle saad impordi peale kauba.
Õpetaja: Kui tellid nüüd kohe uue elektrikli,
Õpetaja: siis sa Saad selle importida Hiinast.
Õpetaja: Näiteks
Õpetaja: kui me nüüd läheme. Ee, ja vaatame seda. Ee, kui me läheme ka nüüd oma lehele kodulehele,
Õpetaja: Noh, kui Teil oli siin ee, link olemas. Saate minna või on tab lahti? Kuidas me saame seda Kontrollida? No, taaskis öeldi ka kaldkriips. Error
Õpetaja: näitab seda sisu, siis me teame, et see töötab.
Õpetaja: See on seotud sellega
Õpetaja: Krooni suu. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: ma arvan, et see, võib olla see kindlalt ei tea. Ahhaa, väga hea, väga hea, väga hea point. Mis sa praegu välja tõid? Ee, kui me kirjutame koodi
Õpetaja: Kui me kirjutame koodi. Ee, Te teete järgi, mina teen ees. Teie teete järgi. Tekib varem või hiljem selline situatsioon, et teil on mingisugune asi. Ee, visuaalselt teistmoodi,
Õpetaja: siis Ta ütleb, ma ütlen, no jah, et sul on midagi teistmoodi. Ja siis ta hakkas ütlema, et. Aga mul on täpselt sama kood, nagu Minul
Õpetaja: äpi peavad samamoodi nagu minul. Aga midagi On teil siis visuaalselt või käitumisest teistmoodi
Õpetaja: Ee, minu Minule meeldib. Kui tuleb see see lause tuleb ära. Siis ma ütlen, et vau.
Õpetaja: Kas lõpuks on siis saabunud see päev, kuidas ühte samasugust koodi Brauser tõlgendab kuidagi erinevalt, sest et on lihtsalt, kurat masin.
Õpetaja: Ta lihtsalt teeb seda, mida kood ütleb. Ja kui meil on täpselt mõlemal sama kood, kõik on identselt sama,
Õpetaja: siis, Ee, minul on raske uskuda. Vaata, et arvuti oskab seal mingit oma loomingut teha
Õpetaja: ja. Ja ma ootan seda, päeva, mis, nagu, näitaks tõesti, Et vaata, et ongi sama kood
Õpetaja: ja Näitab erinevalt või käitub erinevalt iga kord, kui see pakkumine on tulnud, sest et ma ise ütlen ka, et et nagu ma ootan. Ee, teilt seda. Ee, hetke. Ee, mõni inimene ongi julmalt veendunud, et on. No on sama. Kõik on sama
Õpetaja: Siis siiamaani. Iga kord on midagi olnud. Ikkagi natukene erinev. Pole veel saabunud seda päeva.
Õpetaja: Siin on mingi kandiline sulg, mis mul jääb silma. Ja kogu see asi peaks olema nende kandidaatide.
Õpetaja: Sa tegid valesti ja sa ei oleks pidanud veel kopiga tegema.
Õpetaja: Näed ta siia samamoodi I love optimising. Näed, see on see komponent, mida sa soovid.
Õpetaja: Aa, okei, Ta On sul mälus? Vaata, me ei hakka tubliike tegema, Kurat,
Õpetaja: Kaks maha, üks alles
Õpetaja: ja. Ja see on see.
Õpetaja: Need on kolm sõna. Nii,
Õpetaja: lähme edasi, Palun Kohe Lähme pausile ka, et kui keegi Ma ütlen, nagu. Lihtsalt ütlen. Kui keegi praegu kuidagi jääb maha, siis kas. Vaadake, Vaata, onju? Aga kas me võime edasi minna?
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd Kus meil on? Ee, nüüd, kus meil on see olemas.
Õpetaja: Keegi võiks praegu küsida, Miks on see. See siin on valge, aga. Vabandust, Valge, Aga see on lilla. Teil on ka niimoodi või? Huvitav, ma ei tea. Miks. Vaata, Ei, huvita. Ka. Ee, lähme edasi,
Õpetaja: ruttu ennem kui. Aa, nüüd meil on taaskis öeldud, et, ee, peaks tulema mingisugune tekst. Midagi läks valesti.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui me nüüd tuleme siia Colli sisse,
Õpetaja: me Võiksime panna seda vabalt siia, aga mul on plaanis see pilt ka panna. Vaata, minu mõte on pigem see, et siia kooli sisse tuleb. Mitu asja
Õpetaja: võib tulla? Võib ka eraldi roo peale minna. Mis on see element? Me ei hakka teksti lihtsalt kirjutama nagu põhimõtteliselt, et ta Ei ole nagu mingi tekstielemendi sees, mis tekstielementi võiks kasutada siin
Õpetaja: selleks pealkirjas?
Õpetaja: Aa, üks päis ju? Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Aa, üks tab. Ja, Noh, Võib isegi oma loomingut võite ka teha. Siin. Ups, midagi läks valesti.
Õpetaja: Kui mulle tulete järgi. Siis niikuinii on kõik nii nagu minul on, Midagi läks valesti.
Õpetaja: Noh, mingi Smile ka siia. Võibolla.
Õpetaja: Ja kohe saab vaadata ka.
Õpetaja: Noh, see on. Mu taiba Tuli teile kaasa ette. Sinna
Õpetaja: Küll tuleb nüüd. Ee, Järgmine asi, mis ee. Oli siin öeldud, et mingi
Õpetaja: ee. Teeme selle ka.
Õpetaja: Esiteks, mis asi, mis see element on? Ee, pilt.
Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: Kui Me tahame pilt. Jaa, Gif on ka pilt. Jah, on ju
Õpetaja: Tegelt on küll Ee, siis tasuks lahti, teha, et saaks mingi võibolla skaleeruva pildi või mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Kui teete lahti ja otsite image
Õpetaja: responsi images image. Siin on igast variante,
Õpetaja: siis me näeme. Vaata, et see tavaline imidž. Vaata, aga näete seda
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt me võiksime võtta siis. Ee, selle siit.
Õpetaja: Me peame ära defineerima, Source i
Õpetaja: Ee Lepime kokku, et alt ei hakka täitma. Vaata, see oli see. Kui pilt ei suuda laadida, siis Ta näitab mingit katkist ikooni ja mingit Teksti ei viitsi. Aa, ei taha, et võtame selle asja siit. Ma tegelt ma ainult tahtsin seda peast. Mina niukest asja ei tea,
Õpetaja: et Tuleme siia alla ja paneme niimoodi plärati maha.
Õpetaja: Ja selle alt osa. Nüüd vaadake, kus te kustutate nagu need jutumärgid ja kõik asjad see osa. Kustutage ära.
Õpetaja: Nii nüüd on meil vaja mingeid pilti.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd Google koht.
Õpetaja: Ma võin ta kui ta soovite. Ma võin ka teha aegajalt sellist trikki, et ma lükkan. Ma. Nagu toimetan niimoodi,
Õpetaja: et te saate kooli ka vaadata.
Õpetaja: Ee, alati me seda ei saa teha, Kui läheb nagu kood väga suureks. Aga te võite mulle kogu aeg meelde tuletada, et pane Rain, Pane splitti. Teeme Niimoodi on ju
Õpetaja: Ee, Searchist Ma otsin, aga siit. Ma tahan Googlest otsida. Päriselt Googlest.
Õpetaja: Ee, mina tean, Noh, siin Te võite ise mõelda, mis te tahate, Mina Panen Explosion. Panen pildid.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma panen siia sõna Gif ka juurde.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Mul on vaja. Päris. Ütlesid. Siin on lihtsalt preview. Noh, võibolla See Ei, töötaks mulle.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan korra, kas ma siit saan panna kopi? Image adress. Seda pakub on ja mina alati valideerin selliseid linke Nagu eraldi Tavis,
Õpetaja: et kui ma näen nagu seda eraldi lehena, ju siis ta töötaks igal pool. Saate mõttes aru,
Õpetaja: et kas panen pilti, Sest Vahel on niimoodi, et sa kopid mingi lingi ja mõtled, et see on pildilink. Aga Tegelikult, see on mingi veebilehe link, et sealt Läheb veel edasi.
Õpetaja: Okei, nüüd on mul see kenasti olemas.
Õpetaja: Ee, otsi lihtsalt mingit Ghi või mingit pilti. See ei pea olema ka
Õpetaja: kihvt tingimata. Ta lihtsalt toetab kihvti ka.
Õpetaja: Ja mis me sellega teeme ja jutumärkide vahele sorsi. Alla.
Õpetaja: Vaata niimoodi põmaki
Õpetaja: ja siis loomulikult tulete vaatate, Mul Ei ole nii palju. Tab E, lahti. Vaata, mis see on.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Closed apps to the right.
Õpetaja: Jah, on midagi niukest.
Õpetaja: Kuidas Error tegelikult siin käib.
Õpetaja: Läksin lihtsalt kaldkriipsu ära.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: no, midagi taolist. Ee, saab teha. Võite panna omi mingeid asju, mis teile meeldib. Ee, ma Ütlen ka, et ma vanasti panin midagi pildi või lihtsalt tekste. Aga vaata, see on täpselt niuke koht, kus saab võibolla oma oma päris Süsteemis saab võibolla kuidagi pehmendada seda olukorda.
Õpetaja: Mingi midagi. Armsad Mingid kassid või olenevalt temaatikast, mis Teil on? On ju mingisugune niukene Võimalus on alati
Õpetaja: nii edasi Kartul tule järgi. Kas sa saad järgi tulla? Kontroll K.
Õpetaja: Et kui sulle midagi katki ei tööta, siis me järgi ei saa oodata. Ma teen komite poissi.
Õpetaja: Lihtsam, Keegi, kes tahab, võib praegu ka järgi tulla. Kasutage võimalust
Õpetaja: ja ma ütlen, et selle jaoks, mis Te peate jälle tegema. Aa, feci fetch I
Õpetaja: uus haru. Aga nüüd siis nagu V. Kaks sest, ee, sest et, ee, aeg ei soovi.
Õpetaja: Aa, kes, ee, esmaspäevast on? Cloud I omanikud. Siis pakume Skill I. Mis teeb selle tee eest ära,
Õpetaja: Siis saab puhtalt, et ei tule Mingit V kahte ega midagi. Siis on nagu. Noh, see käib nii kiirelt.
Õpetaja: No õpetaja
Õpetaja: viie võtke. Pange see enda nimi. Feb, viis ja V, Kaks, Vaata, Sealt ei ole mingi See haru juba. See nimi on juba reserveeritud. Ees Vaata, onju
Õpetaja: käsi püsti. Kes üldse on järgi tulemas, siis ma tean, kuidas keda oodata. Okei,
Õpetaja: korrastamist siis Ta paneb need source ja klassi ikkagi nagu ühte jätasse.
Õpetaja: Aga korra vaatama teeme Sellise eest kaks nädalas oli.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: siin on nagu see konksu, et ta teeb, keda peab tegema. Vaata, aa, sellepärast. Vaata, ma räägin kohe Siit joonest ka. Vaata, on ju. Ee, Sa näeb, et vaata üle. Joon, et tehniliselt võttes. Vaata, See pool. Mahub ilusti siia, niiöelda sellesse Tavapärasse vahesse ära. Nagu soovitud tulemus. Ma ise ei pannud isegi tähelepanu. Jaa,
Õpetaja: miks te ei lase mul välja minna? Ma üritaksin, ma üritasin, Ise olin siin alguses.
Õpetaja: Vaata, sa ei pea isegi kuskilt Ära minema. Vaata. Ee, teeme niimoodi. Ikka Vaata, sa tuled lihtsalt siia. Ee, New Branch, paned siia asemele oma nime.
Õpetaja: Panen siia lihtsalt V, kaks, mis iganes.
Õpetaja: No create ja thats it done Aa, näed?
Õpetaja: Noh, praegu saab Nagu edasi minna. Käsi püsti. Kas ma nüüd või? Kes veel midagi teeb? Kas ma tohin edasi minna?
Õpetaja: Lähme edasi, tahaks. Minna edasi. Ee, Siin oli küsimus ka, et kui teha seda I love optimising Ut, siis see läheb kõik ühele reale kokku. Ma vaatan, kas mul läheb ka ei taha minna, aga ma korra räägiks sellest joonest Siin, mis siin on?
Õpetaja: Minul on lausa kaks Joont. Näitab mingil põhjusel. Ee,
Õpetaja: kas Te olete ikka kaks Ei olnud
Õpetaja: Sellest Oleneb muidugi, kui lähedal oled. Võibolla kui väga kaugele Scrollida, siis tuleb välja. Ee, see mõte on. See Siin on enamvähem soovituslik joon. Aga mul on niuke tunne, et on kaks, et on mõeldud juba seda, et ee, ekraanid on laiemaks läinud.
Õpetaja: See on nagu. Umbes nagu, et see ei ole selline rusikareegel. Joon, millest ei tohi üle minna, aga umbes niimoodi, et koodi ei tohi liiga kaugele horisontaalselt minna, sest et muidu inimesed peavad su koodi lugemiseks hakkama nagu mingi scroll Ima nagu siit teisele poole.
Õpetaja: Ee, et See sellest sellesse suhtutakse Relaxilt.
Õpetaja: Aa, päris koodibaasis. Nagu et kui sul sa ikka eelistaksid toiduasja ühel real, et oleks üherealine, sest et ongi Üherealine kood Aa, Sa ei taha seda splittima hakata. Vaata, siis kui ta veits läheb üle, on keegi Views tagasi ei tule
Õpetaja: aga need Automaatt tööriistad vahel nagu ise hakkavad Push ima asju et mõte on see, et tegelikult see kõik saab olla ühel real siin kenasti
Õpetaja: niimoodi
Õpetaja: I love optimizing. Aga Näe, minul ta. Näed? Ta võtab minu intelligenci settingud, et minul lükkab ta ikka kahele reale, aga kellelgi teisel mitte, onju? Mõtle, kas see imelik joon on siin?
Õpetaja: Mul ei. Mulle tegelikult meeldiks, et ta ei läheks niimoodi, aga ma ei saa ka midagi teha praegu, sellest, et. Ee, ma pean ise uurima, kas kas teil on ka nii väikene? Mahub ju ära. Ja mis probleem
Õpetaja: nagu see Pisike kriips või?
Õpetaja: Vahet pole. Aa, ärme selle üle praegult keskendu. Lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: On kuidas? On ee? Nii, kui ma lähen nüüd edasi, siis Ee, vaatame taaski.
Õpetaja: Kas on kõik asjad tehtud? Mis Description is on nõutud?
Õpetaja: Okei, no kui. Kuidas muidu te saite vaadata? Siin on käsitsi testimine.
Õpetaja: Aga selle kihvi suurusel. Minul on nagu üle terve lehe slaid ja praegu on okei Savi piksleid taga ja,
Õpetaja: noh, kas sul on Kõik need asjad siin. Ka. Muidugi, kui suureks sul on tehtud?
Õpetaja: Sai võibolla ka Mängib rolli. Ma ei tea,
Õpetaja: ma korra tulen. Vaatan siis, Mismoodi sul on lihtsalt huvi päevas?
Õpetaja: Jah, see see praegult Ee, rikkus sul sinna asju. Võibolla
Õpetaja: ei, aga sa nüüd kustutasid ühe tädi ära Lihtsalt lõppu tagasi.
Õpetaja: Teine korra koodi. Oota, võtame kontrol
Õpetaja: siin. Ma nagu räägiks ühest asjast. Vaata ka,
Õpetaja: aga sul ei ole päris sama ju. Vaata, näed, Vaatame hakkame vaatama. See on nagu see peamine tiim Onju selleks helendama.
Õpetaja: Lõpebki siin. Ära. Vaata, on ju Aga sa kustutasid sel, Sa kustutasid selle ära. Vaata, aga tal ei ole enam paarilist. Siis on. Põhimõtteliselt on tupikateid ja nüüd sul kohe ka enam ei mahu, Ära usu mind,
Õpetaja: kui ma nüüd kustutan selle ära vaata.
Õpetaja: No vaatame. Tegelikult Siis ei ole nii kaugel. Vaata
Õpetaja: Nii, et siin selgus ka, et kõigil käitub samamoodi. Koht on päris sama.
Õpetaja: No, siin oli see klassikaline asi. Vaata, et et tema ekraanil oli midagi teistpidi. Vaata, et Nagu Ei saa olla nagu sama kood, et midagi oli erinevust. Mingi ühe Tv i teema oli seal.
Õpetaja: Nii Kuulge, paneme edasi veel. Ee, Oota, millal me pausi teeme või? Kas me kannatame kolmteist viieteistkümneni ära?
Õpetaja: Kannatame, onju?
Õpetaja: Davai, siis me jõuame rohkem veits teha.
Õpetaja: Siis tuleb see Pikk paus niikuinii. Aa, kui kõigile sobib, siis lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Nii, aa, mis me siis tahtsime? Järgmiseks, Ee, see on taaskond tehtud.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mis Tegevus järgneb. Ee, sellele,
Õpetaja: kui taaskond tehtud. No mis te arvate, mis me teeme? Teeme kõigepealt. See on hea mõte.
Õpetaja: Ee, ütleme. Paneme siis Feb.
Õpetaja: Meil oli nõutud, et komites on, ee, taaski nimi, aga algab. Febla blabla komplit,
Õpetaja: et Committee võib teha, kui ta mingeid Warning Uid teeb? Ma ei tea, ülikama.
Õpetaja: Buss, puss, buss.
Õpetaja: No, kui kellegil mingi error tuleb, siis võib olla see, et te tulite järgi, näiteks mulle Pilves juba on? Vaata, näiteks mingi. Ütleme siis.
Õpetaja: Ee. Tegite mingi uue haru? Panite vee kahe lokaalselt. Muutsite, ära, et on ilma veekaheta uuesti et Siin on see, et. Vaata, sa ei saa kunagi Push Ida. Näiteks niukest haru, mis on juba olemas. Aga sa pole täpselt see Sama haru nagu
Õpetaja: et sa füüsiliselt. Sa oled vahepeal teinud mingi uue haru ja lihtsalt nimetanud samamoodi nagu ennem,
Õpetaja: siis on küsimus, mis edasi Ja
Õpetaja: Aa, ei, Kit Oot. Kui kellegil kit username, küsib, kas ta küsib. Mingi Global ütleb ka. Vaata.
Õpetaja: Ja. Ja ja Tegora Screenshare, ma Võtan enda Screenshare I ära.
Õpetaja: Kas kellegil veel tuli? Nüüd Push ides Kui esimest korda Push Ib midagi ette, siis ee, Okei, lihtlabaselt, pange Lihtsalt sinna oma eesnimi ja pange oma emaili aadress. Seda kuskile ei näe niikuinii.
Õpetaja: Aga ma näitan ära. See on nüüd see, nimi,
Õpetaja: mis On Teil kommitee juures, näiteks. Mul on tüür Lihtsalt jäänud, Saate aru, See on see nimi.
Õpetaja: Aa, Kitil on nagu globaalne setting niiöelda et Hei, kes sa oled? Nagu iga kord, kui ma teen, kes sa oled?
Õpetaja: Ee, ja kui panna emaili aadress. No ma paneks selle ema sama Emaili aadressi, mis? Mis on ta ühel või teisel viisil kasutatud Kitarap is. Ta ei pea kattuma, aga siis ta näitab mingisugust mingit
Õpetaja: asju aitab veits. Õigemini mul lihtsalt ükskord juhtus niimoodi. Vaata, et üks inimene, kuidas see töötab. See on nagu nii veider, Keegi pani nagu põhimõtteliselt välja mõeldud Aa nime enda nimest
Õpetaja: ja pani nagu selleks, et et kui ma teen siis ole hea. Vaata, Niuke nimi on Niuke email, siis ma küsis, kas pean päris panema. Ma ütlesin, et ei pea ja ta pani variatsiooni enda nimest ja siis tuli välja niimoodi, et kellelgi ongi juba rega regatud. Kithub is selle emailiga konto.
Õpetaja: Ja kui tema oma kit hub ist nagu nägi nagu enda komite asju, Ma räägin Brauserist, Siis ta räägin mingi teise venna nägu seal Vaata siis ta küsis.
Õpetaja: Kuule, kuidas see tuleb? Siis Mul alguses oli ka Häming. Ma ei tea, kuidas Private Repost mingi vend saab mingi pilt olla. Ta lihtsalt Comiti taustal võtab ka selle emaili aadressi ja lihtsalt Kitsab, Siis kuvab mingeid lõustakesi. Vaata ja ta võtab selle emaili pealt
Õpetaja: Täitsa huvitav asi, nagu mul on. Nüüd üks küsimus veel. Võtsin sinu selle Alla Panin oma oma selle Riho kataloogi sinna. Aga ta ei lase mul Push ida, sest mul ei ole midagi
Õpetaja: Aa, no vaatame. No proovi.
Õpetaja: Mul on mingi jama.
Õpetaja: No ta teeb seda. Vaata, siin on olemas. Aa, ehk, et nüüd see fail, mis mul on, seal See on nüüd sama kaugel, nagu mul on olnud. Ja. Aga mitte fail, vaid haru. Tähendab, haru. Jah, kõik, mis sul on. Vaata, mis Tahes muudatused, kaasa arvatud see.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kas ma hakkan aega kulutama, et Pull Request läbi mängida või mitte. Tegelikult Te peaksite ikkagi selle protsessi ühe korra läbi tegema ja oma projektides. Te võite kasutada, aga ei pea. Point on see. Vaata, et ta peab nüüd Masterisse kuidagi jõudma.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma pro teil päriselt projektist luban? Ma luban. Otse Masterisse. Merch, Ida.
Õpetaja: See tähendab, et siin arvutis te saate öelda et Tehtud töö siin arvutis. Ee Veb, viis, merg inse.
Õpetaja: Ja siis sa saad ja push ida. Aga päriselus see ei õnnestu sellepärast, et ee, Master Our on Protected, et sinna ei saa tulla otse komite. Vaata, nagu arvutist. Vaata põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: vaid kõik käib läbi Aa Pull Requesti Sellepärast, Et Siis saab sinna protsessi peale panna, et ükski Bulrequest ei lähe läbi kui enam vähemalt üks arendaja on pannud oma
Õpetaja: sinna, vaata onju Tavaliselt need on Protector Id, Seega mängime siis ühe korra seda läbi.
Õpetaja: Ühe ainsa korra. Aga edaspidi me mörtsime otse Master I, sest et Meil lihtsalt on niimoodi kiirem.
Õpetaja: Me Võime pärast teha ka siis mingi skill i selle jaoks, mis teeb ka need sammud kõik korraga ära, et kaine, siis nagu visuaalselt jääb kõik korrektne. Aga lõpptulemus on niikuinii Täpselt üks ja sama töö peab jõudma Masterisse Vanad haarud, kustutame ära,
Õpetaja: On see arusaadav?
Õpetaja: Kui te panite tähele siis, kui push isite, siis võibolla kõrval isegi pakkus. Vaata ka sellist varianti, et vaata onju, aga Ma ei taha seda siit teha. See on, ee. On olemas. Integratsioon Saab siit tööriistast ka väga edukalt teha ja võibolla ma päris elus isegi teeks. Neid. Vaata nii. Aga, Mul on pigem tähtsam see, et. Ee, et minna.
Õpetaja: Nii, minge teiega kütte abi tulete Glash Money Peale
Õpetaja: Nii kui mina tulen praegu siia Masteri alla. Siis Siin on juba
Õpetaja: vale projekt. Glash Money peale. Ma olen, ee, vale kontoga sõbrad.
Õpetaja: Nii Ma olen vale kontoga. Ee, teil peaks olema Niukene asi nagu Car Portal. Ei, car portal.
Õpetaja: Vali T. Nelikümmend front. Mis iganes see, on, Vot see,
Õpetaja: ma annan teile lingi. Lihtsalt, Ee, chat I. Kui te soovite, palun,
Õpetaja: Sest et kui te olete abi sisse logitud, siis sellele repole. Te saate ligi. Te näete kõik seda sama vaatepilti nagu mina,
Õpetaja: mis Ta näitab praegu. Kakskümmend kaheksa. No see klapib Meil on ju enda enda nimeline arv. Ja siis enda nimel on ju? Ja mida meie tahame teha, on see on.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et me paneme Serveris püsti palve.
Õpetaja: Võtabull Request ja siit. Ee. Teie juba vajutage. Ja siis saate näha, mis seal ees on.
Õpetaja: Me tahame nüüd panna niimoodi püsti pilves, et mina soovin panna See tiimiliikmed peavad ju nägema seda tööd. Keegi päriselus, et mina soovin, et minu töö läheks sinna Masterisse Ja Siis keegi teine saab seda niimoodi sealt kohe ka näha.
Õpetaja: Nüüd siin näete seda noolekest.
Õpetaja: Siin ta nüüd Ütleb. Vaata, et kust, kuhu, Nagu tahad tööd sisse nagu tõmmata. Kuidas me siin nüüd siis peame toimetama? Mis siiapoole jääb,
Õpetaja: ei, jää. Master jääb teie, Master,
Õpetaja: sest me ei saa kõik Masterisse Merchida. Ee, ehk siis mina tulen siit. Find I alt. Ma panen õpetaja.
Õpetaja: No teie võite otsida sealt oma nime onju?
Õpetaja: Ja Mis siiapoole tuleb. Siia tuleb arendusehaaru.
Õpetaja: Minu puhul on see ikka Obt ajaga. Siis Feb viis Nüüd päriselus. Kujutage ette, et siin Paremal pool on lihtsalt Feb. Viis ja vasakul. Pool on master. Kas see kontseptsioon on teil selge? Vaata, noh, me ei saa lihtsalt kõik Nagu Masterisse panna. Vaata, on ju, et. Noh, me ei saa tööd. Me ei saa kõik sama tööd teha kogu aeg ja Masterisse panna konfliktis. Elad
Õpetaja: nii nüüd. Esimene asi, mis ta üldse ütleb Meile on Able to Merch. Mida see tähendab,
Õpetaja: et saab, ikka, et konflikti pole Kui päriselus sa ei pruugi nüüd niimoodi minna on. Vaata, tegite kaua tööd. Master on liikunud rämedalt edasi. Keegi on teinud täpselt samas failis muudatuse nagu sina. Meie analoogia võib olla see, et meil oli uus fail, tuli onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, Error View. Kui keegi teeb täpselt samasuguse ee Faili nagu Error View. Sest et kuidas see nagu programm vaatab, Kit vaatab, mis oli see eelnev seis nagu
Õpetaja: ennem ei olnud niukest faili.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd mina selle selle arendusega see tekkis.
Õpetaja: Aga kui seal on juba ees see fail Master ees, siis ta ei saa nagu mõelda, et ma panen mingi oma mingi staffi sinna nagu üle, lihtsalt. Ja pigem üldse. Master on ju king. Vaata, see on ju testitud, see on vaadatud. See on Code Review.
Õpetaja: Me. Me ei saa, vaata, aga siin loomulikult ei ole mingit konflikte. No meil väga ei saagi konflikte tulla,
Õpetaja: siis sa pead seda Push ima. Aa, siis mine. Kui sa oled selle haru peal veel endiselt, siis tule siit. Vajuta, Push,
Õpetaja: See on suure tähe tundmed Ka
Õpetaja: Bussi jaoks ei ole midagi vaja. Aa otsimise mõttes. Aa,
Õpetaja: ahah, Vot. Kas sa otsisid väga väikse tähega?
Õpetaja: Aa, Okei, see teeb buss. Vaata, bussiga on ka kohe näha. Vaata, et kui sa tuled, nüüd oled sa seal oma arendusharu peal.
Õpetaja: Ei, no Ma mõtlen konkreetselt seda
Õpetaja: see see kehtib. Vaata sellele harule. Vaata. No mõlemad saad. Push, ida. Push, Ida. Saad kogu aeg harusid. Vaata, kas Ta on juba või ei ole? Vaata, kui sa vajutad selle peale, siis minul sinu. Võibolla näitab siin mingi New Vaata, et uus haru läheb ülesse. No siis ongi see,
Õpetaja: Kui sa teed selle push I ära. Ja Browserist teed. Refresh, oota. Sa võtab aega ka. Muidugi, onju Lähed sinna alla? On alati väike. Joonekene
Õpetaja: on ju, et kaua tal võtab see aega Niipea kui see on Done,
Õpetaja: siis juba Refresh iga Nüüd peaks leidma selle
Õpetaja: samal ajal, enne kui me seda ülesse paneme. Ta juba näitab ühtteist. Ta näitab ka mitte. Ta näitab, mitu faili on Change I nüüd. Aa, kes on?
Õpetaja: Kui siit alt vaatate, siis ta isegi näitab Preview, D mis ta näitab, näiteks ta näitab, et Ruuteri indeksis tuli juurde. Niukene import vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Okei, aa sinist osa. Ta lihtsalt peidab sind teatud arv ridasi. Nüüd Ta näitab, et ta kustutas ära selle viimase ruuting objekti. Aa, lõpetava selle kooloni
Õpetaja: ja tekitas uue rea. Kus on see sama kool on nagu Coman juures,
Õpetaja: Ülejäänud Osa on põhimõtteliselt nagu siis, see. Sellist asja on algajal raske lugeda. Vaata, sa pead nagu mõttes nagu panema kokku, seda, et mis kustutas ära. Ja mis tuleb, on ju aga lihtsam lahendus on see, kui sa teed kellegile, on see, et sa vaatad siit neid nagu muudatusi, et mis ta nagu tegi. Aga tegelikult sa lähed nüüd lahti. Lähed teed checkout I Vaata sellele arenduse Harule,
Õpetaja: Tõmbad nüüd arvutisse, onju? Ja Siis juba vaatad. Vaata neid koodiridu, mida tema muutis,
Õpetaja: Et, Noh, selle saad ju nii kiirelt kätte. Vaata, on ju, Kui mul on see Arenduseharu olemas. Ma võtan selle sama ruuteri indeksi. Lähed sinna
Õpetaja: teed? Ee, noh, sa tead neid faile juba kuhu vaadata, ja siin oleks praegult ju kellegi teise nimi. Vaataja kuupäev.
Õpetaja: Aa, okei. Ja siis. Sa juba vaatad lihtsalt seda koodi nagu terviklikuna, nagu, et, Aa, okei, see tundub Okei, et kogenud Ee, tüübid vaatavad põhimõtteliselt.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt vaatavad sealt samast. Ära vaata enam vähem,
Õpetaja: aga lihtsam on. No, siin on ka see võimalus, Kui ma midagi ei leidnud, siis ma võtan. Igal juhul ma tulen igal pool seda I love optimising ut siin toksima ja vaatama, kas Ma leian äkki mingisuguse asja või midagi muud ei leidnud.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, siis. Kui vajutad, siis ta alles tekib. Sinna süsteemi Näed. Pull Request I tal ühtegi Request I pole.
Õpetaja: Noh, mul on märgitud siin Base õpetaja, et kas see siis on?
Õpetaja: No see representeerib nagu Cloud või
Õpetaja: Ei, see. See representeerib, et kuhu see töö sisse läheb? Siin on see suund. Hästi tähtis. Vaata, kas mina tahan Masteri asju tõmmata enda arenduse alusse
Õpetaja: või? Mina tahan oma arendusasja Masterisse vaadata. Märku selles osas, et et sinna hakkab uus info minema.
Õpetaja: Okei, sul on ka noori
Õpetaja: Noor mängib siin rolli. Vaata, ta lisaks noorele annab veel informatsiooni, et siia põhimõtteliselt taxabase siia lisandub midagi. See On põhi, millele tuleb midagi juurde. Et see kõik toimub Cloud Is Ja me lihtsalt nõrsimegi.
Õpetaja: Ja täpselt me me üldsime arenduse haru põhialuse.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis, see, mis läheb kliendile tehtud töö. Ja. Noh, kui me selle oleme ära teinud. Aa, ma ei tea, kas ma nüüd jõudsin vajutada nuppu või mitte, vist, Mitte ee. Ma saan siia mingit Description It juurde. Panna mingeid notes E, asju Mida iganes, Bla blabla
Õpetaja: alles siis. Aa, ma saan panna Aa, juurde ka. Ma vajutan selle nupu ära. Vaata, olemas seal nüüd. Ta on Cloud Is olemas. Näete, Pulbrequest on juba kolm. Kolm Pulbrequesti on süsteemis olemas.
Õpetaja: Aa, siis päriselus. On see umbes, niimoodi et teed klõpsu sellest lindist. Aa, no tähendab, päriselus on, see et sa paned Näiteks,
Õpetaja: ma panen iseenda. Vaata siia praegult. Ee, näed. Kõik kes on meil selles projektis osalemas? Kurat, uued läbi. Lahti Mine tagasi, Ee, et Kõik, kes on Reviewers olemas. Ma näen kõiki Siit ma saaks otsida oma töökaaslast. Noh, näiteks Artur Saate aru,
Õpetaja: ma saan aru, Sina oled Reviewer. See on Reviewer. Aga see, et. Kas see see tegelikult temale, on see järgijõudnud Ma Võin Review te paika panna, aga veel, Notification It ei lähe.
Õpetaja: Ja siis on see, et kes, kes nagu vastutab praegult selle pulbriku eesti ees Nagu, et kes midagi peab tegema. Ma saan panna. Vaata, et ee, hetkel tegelen sellega veel. Mina
Õpetaja: ja ühel hetkel, kui ma tunnen. Vaata, et okei, sa siia saab ka mitu panna. Ma vajutan kogu aeg valet nuppu. Ma pean siia vajutama peale.
Õpetaja: Ma saan otsida selle iseenda ja sealt maha võtta, Kui see Pcs on?
Õpetaja: Ei saagi. Saan panna. Näiteks Artur, siia. Ma ei tea, kui ma panen. Artur,
Õpetaja: vaatame, kas. Aa, kui ma selle vajutan, siis minu meelest ma midagi saveida ei saa. Vaata, kas sulle tuli mingi notification või mitte. Ma Ei, tea, kuidas see süsteem töötab.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: ei ole Midagi, ma. Ah, võibolla ma. Ei. Ma ei tea, ma ei oska öelda. Ma. Ei, ma ei ole väga palju. Aa, päris ee, kasutanud. Me katsume peamiselt Bucket It seal natuke teistmoodi.
Õpetaja: See ei olegi tähtis. Põhiline on see, et jah siin saab ära ka määrata, vaata, kes tegeleb ja mingid pöidlad. Ja ma ütlen, mul ei ole mitte mingit konfi. Siin taga tuli nüüd me A. Meil tuli, onju päriselus Tavaliselt oli lihtsalt niimoodi, et andsid selle pullediku Eesti lingi ja kirjutasid Kuule, et ma panin sulle
Õpetaja: Sa nagu teadlik. Vaata, et keegi ei jaksa meile vaadata. Eriti automatiseeritud meilid.
Õpetaja: Ühesõnaga tuli lõpuks sulle siia, ka, onju? Nii, Mida nüüd näiteks Ee, Artur. Näiteks saaks teha, on see, et Tema nüüd tuleb täpselt siia vaatesse. Nüüd näeb seda.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuidas tema nüüd toimetab? Kas ta vaatab ka mitte asju? Taas vaadatakse lihtsalt seda File Change või vaadatakse Conversation. Sellepärast siin on niiöelda omavaheline suhtlus ka kirjas.
Õpetaja: Ma nüüd natukene mängin, Nagu, et ma oleks nagu Artur.
Õpetaja: Noh, Kui ma tuleks nüüd näiteks siia, siis ma näen kõik failid.
Õpetaja: Vaata, see annab juba ette. Vaata, et mis failid hakkavad muutuma,
Õpetaja: juhul kui See Pull Request peaks minema Masterisse nagu läbi.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd see koht. Kuidas Ma saaksin mängida ka kokku. Vaata, et ma saaks rahulikult siin vaadata ja seal vaadata. Ja, noh, siin. Natukene vähemalt ja poolt Juba integreeritud ka. Aga ma ütlen, et kõik ettevõtjad ei kasuta tingimata Neid platvorme on bränd ja teenusepakkuja. Kit on tehnoloogia.
Õpetaja: Neid on palju. Ma ei tea igasuguseid on Veel
Õpetaja: suuremaid ja väiksemaid. No on kindlasti Üks suuremaid ee nendest pakkujatest.
Õpetaja: Ee, et nüüd ma saan tulla siia. Ja mis on nüüd teeb Sellele mugavaks, on see, et kui mulle Midagi ei meeldi siin.
Õpetaja: Mina kui Reviewtja. Näiteks võtan vastu midagi.
Õpetaja: Noh, ee, mis mul võiks mitte meeldida. Kõik on perfektselt tehtud, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, No võibolla võiks. Võib olla. No ma teen näiteks siin. Saab Niimoodi plussiga valida. Kas ühe rea
Õpetaja: ja kirjutada kommentaari või sa saad tegelikult Isegi Drag Ida. Niimoodi et näed see sektsioon,
Õpetaja: et vaata point, on see, mida ta lahendab, on see, et me ei hakka omavahel Slack Is Kirjutama kirjeldama. Vaata see fail. Rida see ja too või see meetod on ju vaid. Mul on siin võimalik nagu otse adresseerida, nagu, Mille kohta see kommentaar käib?
Õpetaja: Noh, võibolla kirjutab viisakalt niimoodi. Ee, niimoodi ilusti. No kuule, kuule, kuule, nii need asjad ei käi,
Õpetaja: okei nii Ja siis ta ütleb. Vaata, et ee, vale blokkide järjekord Nii
Õpetaja: siis ta ütleb kõigepealt kas ta viitsib üldse kirjutada? Noh, ma ütlen, et Siin on ka erinevad. Mõned lihtsalt viitavad vigadele. Mõned viitavad vigadele. Kui nad saavad aru, et sa oled Newbie, et saad midagi loogi, mingi Stiiliasjad ja värgid. Vaata, on natuke erinevad, on ju? Aga kui mingisugune loogiline asi on midagi valesti, siis tihtipeale aidatakse Review sse ka see Põhjendus. Vaata, et
Õpetaja: et kui sa oled mingi. Vaata, tee parem niimoodi. Sellepärast, et Või ära tee niimoodi, sellepärast, et,
Õpetaja: ee, sest see mõte On ju tegelikult seeniori roll. On ka ju mentordamine ja õpetamine ja välja treenimine,
Õpetaja: et nagu, ei ole lihtsalt nagu tee korda. Vaid nagu, et tee korda. Loomulikult ära. Edaspidi tee seda sellepärast, et
Õpetaja: miks põhjendus? Vaata, miks teistpidi on kuidagi parem. Näiteks kõigepealt tuleb Script Mm, Ok,
Õpetaja: Ja Siis template. No näiteks, äkki talle ei meeldi see.
Õpetaja: Ja siis tema paneb Ee, kommen. Ma ei. Tea. Mida see start Review täpselt Tähendab, nagu start Compleet, mis? Kas tal võtab nagu aega? Ja ma pean enda jaoks nagu kuidagi markeerima. No võibolla lihtsalt start, Review ja Kommentaar läheb sellega koos.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd kujutame ette. Ee, see oli seenior.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma olen ka siin projektis ju tegelikult, eksole, on ju Nii
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen siia, näete, kuidas ma hakkan Urli urli. Ma ei lähe kuhugi klikkima.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma olen juba tark. Ma tean, mida rajad tähendavad. Mul on siia rain tuur, sest mul on ka ligipääs sellele projektile.
Õpetaja: Ei, niimoodi ei saa. Aa, siis ma vahetan rolli.
Õpetaja: Teeme niimoodi, et ma jätan rolli. Ma lähen.
Õpetaja: Ee, Pull Request.
Õpetaja: Nojah,
Õpetaja: aga kas ma tegin ju pulbreid? Kui hästi, Miks ma ei näe midagi praegult?
Õpetaja: Kus on harud? Harudes on ka üks bränz. Mis ma valesti teen?
Õpetaja: Teate, see on ikkagi valesti. Aa, see mul ondel ka Repos bank. Nelikümmend front. Ma korra valesse kohta, Push. Isin. Esialgu, ma pean ikkagi olema repo mõttes. Kenasti, nagu ma. Olen
Õpetaja: ee. Kus oli Pcs? See On ju Repo?
Õpetaja: Nii, ma pean lihtsalt nüüd olema logitud sisse kui Rain Ja ma ju nüüd olen seda vist
Õpetaja: ma vaatan, kui ma Hakkan kommentaari jätma.
Õpetaja: Kus Ma näen Request. Aga see ongi see sama
Õpetaja: Ee, pool request. Noh, kurat, mina tagasi.
Õpetaja: Nii Conversation.
Õpetaja: Huvitav,
Õpetaja: kas ma Vahetasin intr ka.
Õpetaja: Mm, ma nagu oleks kujutanud ette, et ma nagu näen seda.
Õpetaja: Ee conversation Id
Õpetaja: pending.
Õpetaja: See ongi see, et ma startisin. Vaata, kui. Vaata mis variante veel on.
Õpetaja: Ee, no okei, Ma panen siis. Ee, Submitreview. Äkki see ongi. See on draft. Vaata
Õpetaja: praegu, et Sa saad toimetada. Nii, nüüd ma lähen ära. Vaata, nüüd on oota. Nüüd. Conversation I all on igal juhul see üks siin olemas. Vaata, et ma leian ülesse, et näed siin Error Views. Nende ridade kohta on Bts i poolt,
Õpetaja: et. No Kuule, need asjad ei käi nii Vale blokkide järjekord. Kõigepealt tuleb Scripti blokk ja siis tuleb templeid Nüüd ma korra vahetan rolli.
Õpetaja: Ee, Tulen siia, kuna ma olen iseennast ka Luba enda isiklikku seda kontot lubanud ka projekti. Kui mina Tuleksin nüüd siia vaatesse, siis ma näen ka seda vaadet ja nüüd ma saaks nagu selles mõttes vastata. Reply
Õpetaja: ei teeni
Õpetaja: ikooni. Emotikoni ei saagi panna Või ma
Õpetaja: tuleb selle asemel Ei taha mingit. Läheb lihtsalt niimoodi. Läksin ju panen kommentaar.
Õpetaja: Aga Päriselus, mis ma oleks kirjutanud, on see, et ma oleks selle korda teinud
Õpetaja: selle asja endale ja siis ma või Kui ma kavatsen seda korda, et. Okei, teen ära või tehtud.
Õpetaja: Ma. Mina. Tavaliselt kirjutasin tehtud alla ka, aga siin tegelikult on ka olemas Niuke asi nagu
Õpetaja: see tähendab seda, et vaata see konkreetne vestlus. See sellepärast, et ta kogu aeg on siin selles Conversation I all senikaua Kuni ma lähen korra tagasi. Noh, siis nagu teisesse vaatesse. Mis asja see visuaalselt näeb? Täpselt sama välja. Aga Bc saab nüüd. Tema ju Näeb nüüd niimoodi nagu. Vaata,
Õpetaja: ee, kirjutasin. Ee, Kujutage ette, et mina olen vanem arendaja. No kuule, nii. Kuule. Nende asjad ei käi vale Blokkide järjekord. Kõigepealt tuleb skripblokk ja siis template. Ma vaatan, Rain vastas. Tee ei tee nii ja näitab keelt ka, onju
Õpetaja: Ee, siis päriselus Oleks Siin näha, et see on.
Õpetaja: Peab olema tehtud. Aga see põhiline asi on, see, et et enam ei ole, saab vajutada niukest nuppu Nagu resolve Conversation
Õpetaja: et seda on vaadatud juba nagu
Õpetaja: Ta on tegelikult siin olemas. Aga teda visuaalselt kohe enam ei kuvata, et ei ole Nagu avatud.
Õpetaja: Aga põhiline asi on ikkagi. Loomulikult siis need failid ja Change Id.
Õpetaja: No siin on ka kirjas. Vaata, näed, siin on mingi kommentaar mingi teatud ridade kohta. Aga see on markeeritud Resorv See on nagu tööriist, mis aitab nagu mõlemat poolt.
Õpetaja: See aitab eelkõige tegelikult Code Review I, et tal on lihtne jätta tagasisidet mis talle ei meeldi.
Õpetaja: Ja seda on seal lihtne Selles mõttes siis ka ee koodi omanikul, Nagu vaadata nagu neid kohti, mis nagu ei meeldi. Ja Conversation on kõik nagu ajaloos olemas.
Õpetaja: Aa, nagu selles mõttes, et kõik on nagu, näha, mis me üksteisele kirjutame. Ja me ei pea hakkama nagu kuskil. Aa, Slack is või kuskil nagu selles mõttes suhtlema. Kuule, see projekt, See klass, See meetod. See rida nagu. Kuule, please. Mul ei ole aega, et saate aru, mis asja see nagu aitab, onju?
Õpetaja: No lõpuks, Kui kõik on korras, on ju siis päriselus Saab kenasti panna oma mingi pöidla kuskile.
Õpetaja: Ee, mina ei tea, kust Jumala kohast seda teha saab
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt siin. Ei näe ju mitte midagi. Ju? Siin on kõigil sama.
Õpetaja: Nii et, ee, kuskil saab tegelikult markeerida ka ära et see, on nagu tehtav, aga mind isegi ei huvita, mis mind huvitab. On see osa siin
Õpetaja: Merch Pull Request See nüüd on, see, et Masteriga ei ole mingit probleeme. Noh, siin on muidugi õpetaja,
Õpetaja: et seda ära niiöelda. Aa, niiöelda sinna, et ta saab seda teha.
Õpetaja: Aa siin on Kaks varianti. Tegelikult veel. Aa, seda viimast ma ei puudutaks Merch Commit. On see niimoodi, et kõik Commit Id, mis selle arenduse sees niiöelda tehti.
Õpetaja: Need saavad olema ka nüüd seal Masteris. Kui eraldi komitid Mina tegin kakskümmend komitti, et jõuda oma lõpptulemuseni. Kui me Merchime tehtud töö Masterisse, Siis seal on ka kakskümmend komiiti. Kain olemas. Saate mõttest aru
Õpetaja: on niimoodi, see, et nad sinna. Ütleb. Kaks komite on tehtud, Aa, on see, et ta põhimõtteliselt ta lükkab kõik commitid. Aa, üheks komeit Iks ja Merch Ib selle töö ära.
Õpetaja: Ee, vanasti me kasutame kasutada Merchi. Aga on tiimid, kes kasutavad squash and Merch ja mulle isiklikult meeldib. Ee, see squash and merch rohkem. No ei ole vaja näha seal kõiki neid taustal, ühel või teisel viisil. Kuidagi on kajaloost nagu jälgitavad ja tagasi minna. Aga ma mõtlen lihtsalt, kui keegi vaatab seda Kiki, joont sealt sellest tööriistast, mis näitab või mitte,
Õpetaja: siis seal on vahe. Kuidas sa seda näitad?
Õpetaja: No võibolla teemegi niimoodi, et teie tehke Näiteks, ee, Squash and Merch. Ja mina tean selle tavalise. Ja vaatame, kuidas me asju erinevalt näeme.
Õpetaja: Tee, Pange squashion Merch.
Õpetaja: Sest Mul on Kindlalt kaks kommitti. Ee, mul on midagi. Peaks siis saama nagu näidata.
Õpetaja: Jaa, otsige enda see ülesse. Vaata
Õpetaja: või kõrge.
Õpetaja: Tehke ära.
Õpetaja: Ja mina Panen tavaline Merch Poor Request. Aa, niipea kui te nupu vajutate, siis pange tähele. Mis siin paremal pool Te võite minu ekraanilt vaadata. Mis siia tekib.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, ma aitan. Merch Bull Request Confirm Merge
Õpetaja: Merch and closed.
Õpetaja: Ee, Minul Tavaliselt on tulnud nagu deliit nupp ka juurde. Kus see on.
Õpetaja: Ma pean vajutama, onju?
Õpetaja: Ja ma tahtsin seda ka ise näidata. Nagu. Kas ma mingi vale asja peal, vä?
Õpetaja: Kuidas, ee, mis Tab i peal. Sa oled, kus sa Näed? Seda
Õpetaja: seal algus on. Kuulge, Merch. Selle sama realiga.
Õpetaja: Siin on teil Eliit, onju Minul Mingil Põhjusel pole ma korda Refresh. Ja äkki tuleb
Õpetaja: onju see lillas. Mul on open.
Õpetaja: Ahaa, ma vot. Võibolla ma ei tea, Vaata, kui te Näete sealt eliitnupu? Siis vajutage seda. Protsessi on sisse kirjutatud.
Õpetaja: Kui sul oli mingi tehtud töö. Asjad on nagu põhimõtteliselt üle vaadanud, et on ära vaadanud. Keegi on tammsappi pannud,
Õpetaja: kui sa murtsid selle haru ära vaata niiöelda, sest et sa see haru iseenesest ei kao sealt süsteemist Kuhugi See, et ta kuskil joonisel näitab, et ta sõidab jälle tagasi Masterisse, ei tähenda, et see haru on surnud, ütles, sa saad sinna Muusiku mitte lisada ja nii edasi Pole mingit probleemi.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga nüüd ongi see, et lihtsalt Basic hügieen on see, et kui see töö on juba ära mörsitud, Siis mis meil seda arendusharu on? On ju samas? Ei, ole see ära automatiseeritud. Vaata, äkki on mingi põhjus, siis On see võimalus, aga, Noh, ütleme. Lhv S oli ikka kokkulepe, kes ära mörtsib, siis kohe deliliatib sealt selle ära, et ei ununeks,
Õpetaja: mis sa oma arvutis teed? See on läbu maa. Tahad hoida seda haru endale alles? No hoia, siis. Ma ei tea, Tead, mis tahad. Sellega, Aga vähemalt teised kõik, kes ülejäänud tiim, nagu näevad, ei taha näha enam seda haru,
Õpetaja: sest selleks enam ei ole vajadust ja kui tekib Mingi vajadus, et. Oi, keegi ununes midagi. Ununes või midagi taolist. Noh, eks siis. See inimene läheb, võtab masteris lihtsalt uue, haaru nimetab seda samapidi ja teeb teeb mingi väikse Fixi ära. Ja, noh, kuidagi tuleb välja, et ununes midagi. Järsku kuidagi kuskilt keegi avastab,
Õpetaja: mul näitab erinevaid, Mul on nüüd see. Mul on mingid erinevad nuppevahetused. Jään vastu võluga. Vahet pole, ära stressa
Õpetaja: ja ta teeb ikka ainult ühe kommiti, vaata Aga nüüd ma nagu näitangi seda vahet. Vaata teil nüüd kõigil. Nüüd on nagu see asi. Vaata, ka nüüd on üks asi. Vaata, mis on? Vaja, Ei tohi ära unustada.
Õpetaja: Kus kohas toimus? Praegult. Kus see töö läks? Praegult meil Masterisse pilves,
Õpetaja: kus ta, kus ei ole seda veel juhtunud.
Õpetaja: Me ei ole ka, aga fetšimine mõjutab ainult meie arvutit. Peegeldus onju. T on niikuinii vaja. Teha No teeme siit tulebki see asi välja. Vaadake, mis nüüd Ee, omanimelise Masteriga toimub.
Õpetaja: Oi põmm. Mis see on?
Õpetaja: Üksteist asja on. Mastersitud pilves.
Õpetaja: Lähme vaatame.
Õpetaja: Mis toimub.
Õpetaja: Vot See on see, kui ei ole Protection It ei ole peal.
Õpetaja: Ee, vaatame pilve.
Õpetaja: Nii, Nii, mis sind aimab?
Õpetaja: Remington Rmt, Remington, Remington Steel, Sealt võtsid vä? Aa, väga hea. Oled seda sarja näinud ka?
Õpetaja: Ee, ja ma tean, et revolverid, arvutusmasinad ja. Ja ee, rems, siis otsustas, et tema tegi oma vastu.
Õpetaja: Aga väga hea, las olla. Las olla siis nii. Nii, on.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan korra. Nüüd vaatame nüüd korra, nagu Kuidas näeb välja minu kommit?
Õpetaja: Ee, minu master näeb välja selline,
Õpetaja: et ee, stardist võeti üks uus haru.
Õpetaja: Ma ei saa kunagi aru. Vaata, Siin näidatakse seda, mis mina tegin. Ee, enda arvutis.
Õpetaja: Worki. Need kaks komit te näete,
Õpetaja: on ju? Ja siis on merge,
Õpetaja: aga kui me Vaatame kedagi teist, keda ma võiks. Vaadata.
Õpetaja: Vaat, ma ei saa masturit. Sorry, ma tahan vaadata. Näiteks näete seda Joont?
Õpetaja: Üks kommit on lihtsalt juurde. Tulnud Oota korra, Artur.
Õpetaja: Sai õige Origin. Arthur
Õpetaja: ongi. Nagu Vaata Arturi Joon on niimoodi. Et Temal. Oli see ee, õpetaja Haru ja Siis tuli juurde. Lihtsalt üks kommit.
Õpetaja: Ma ei viitsi vaadata. Päris ka. Ee, see ei ole vahet. Vaata, ma lihtsalt tahan öelda, et see Squash. Päeva lõpuks teeb vähem. Kui mitte Master jääb. See joon jääb ilusam alati
Õpetaja: seal. Ei tule neid, Ta ei näita neid harusid asju, Mitte midagi, vaid lihtsalt tuleb juurde Üks kommit,
Õpetaja: et tegelikult. See on väga fine.
Õpetaja: Et mina ei näe ühtegi põhjust. Mina projektis enam ei tee. Ee, seda, Merch. I Vaid teen. Squashion Merch.
Õpetaja: See asi on tiimis. Kindlasti kokku lepitud. Kuhu iganes te lähete, nii põrutame edasi. Meil On veel. Ee, meil enam Ei ole. Midagi väga jäänud aega. Ee, Teeme lihtsalt siis hügieeni ära.
Õpetaja: Teeme selle ära nagu et. Ee,
Õpetaja: minu Lõpetaja kolm komitti. Aga Ongi vist. Vaata, ma igaks juhuks vaatan üle.
Õpetaja: Ee, õpetaja Feb.
Õpetaja: Näed, minul tulebki põhimõtteliselt. Nüüd. Ee, Feb,
Õpetaja: Vaadake Minul, Minul minul on kaks Comiti. Täpselt nii nagu on. Vaadake, ee, siin on niimoodi, et on see start,
Õpetaja: kus ma võtsin? Näete seda, Tag I siin. See siin näitab, et praegu minu see ee, lokaalne haru on siin,
Õpetaja: aga on siin veel mingi Work in progress tulnud,
Õpetaja: kus on ka Artur Kuidagi mingi valemis. Ta võttis vist mingi haru. Vaata, ta vahepeal. Aa, sa tulid ju järgi mulle. Vaata onju, Midagi ta Näitab, Aga päeva lõpuks Mul on siin tegelikult kaks kommitti.
Õpetaja: Aga squash iga oleks olnud ainult
Õpetaja: üks Comiit Ja kujuta ette kui te teete Viisteist Comiti nädala jooksul. Noh, ei ole mõtet risustada minu meelest, et ma nagu enam nagu tagasi nagu teed ei läheks, et, ee, mina teeks, Saates seda. Me lõpetati ka seal kursusel vanema arendajaks.
Õpetaja: No siis on viimane asi. On vaja see, et meil on vaja siis oma Niiöelda, Master. Päris master on vaja viia. Ee, siis niiöelda
Õpetaja: ee, vastavusse, et. Noh, kui ma point, on see, et kui ma võtan New Branch Praegult siit. Sellest hetkest praegult võtan. Uus Branch hakkab mingi veb, viite tegema, Veb neljadega, mida iganes,
Õpetaja: aga seal ei ole, ju seda Tehtud tööd, mis me just tegime,
Õpetaja: Õpe. Vaata, kui ma tulen siia, vaatan, mis õpetaja see on, Kui ma teen lihtsalt checkout I lihtsalt Õpetaja peale.
Õpetaja: Kui ma lähen vaatan faile, siis mul on see seis, mis oli stardis
Õpetaja: Views all on mul ainult home View Ruuterite all On mul ainult home ruut, aga tegelikult.
Õpetaja: Okei, See on õpetaja, on ju? Mul on need olemas, et see on arendus. Ma tegin, et Me tegime pilves Selle tööde ühendamise master on maha jäänud nüüd pilvest,
Õpetaja: Mis me teeme siin apteedi või? Master Id ongi kõik
Õpetaja: Te peate natuke kujutama. Lihtsalt päris elu. Vaata, et teil on Master arendusharu. Masteri arendusharu sinna. Masterisse tuleb iga päev. Kui te teete fetsi, tuleb mingeid muudatusi, sest kõik arendavad sinna samma kohta.
Õpetaja: Iga uus töö mis läheb nii öelda kliendile. Põhimõtteliselt on Masteris ehk siis nagu, ee, iga iga pä Iga kord, kui te hakkate Masterist uut haru võtma,
Õpetaja: siis te peate alati tegema Fetch, update ja alles siis võtate uue haru,
Õpetaja: sest et pole mõtet endale mürge konflikti juba potentsiaalselt tekkida, et vahepeal on mingi kakskümmend kakskümmend juurde tulnud. Pastor on kõvasti edasi liikunud. Sina võtad oma haru mingist jumala hapust seisust. Ma mõtlen, kus on nii palju aega möödas tagasi, on ju? Ja kui sa lõpus isegi arendused ära kiirelt ära. Tahad Tagasi Merchides? Sa vaatad, et. Aga sa. Sa puudutasid mingit faili. Vaata, mis on ühest nendest kommit idest
Õpetaja: niiöelda juba tehtud, Vaata, mingi mingi muudatus on,
Õpetaja: et alati kõige värskemast seisus peate võtma nii värske kui võimalik. See annab teile võimaluse, et nõrge konflikti tõenäosus on väiksem.
Õpetaja: No, see oleks ebaloogiline. Nüüd, enne kui me pausile läheme, ma näitan ühe asja ära. Siis, Ee, Mida Riho küsis? Et Aga Oletame, et Riho näiteks vaatab kodus videot.
Õpetaja: Oi, aga ma nüüd praegu sain. Aru, Vaata, et võibolla squash ei ole õppimise juures kõige parem
Õpetaja: Ee, mõte on see. Vaata, oletame, et ma teen mingisuguse. Ja see on ka sisukam Commit, kus Ei, ole lihtsalt working progress, üks või Kaks, kuigi ka seda tegelikult. Ee, videos siis näeks. Ja kui sa tahad, näed videos mingit hetke. Vaata, et oleme selles kohas nagu näiteks Ee, siin.
Õpetaja: Ja ma tahaks nüüd täpselt sellest kohast, kus Rain tegi komitee järgnevaid asju proovida ja teha kaasa,
Õpetaja: et me saame teha, vastab tõele. Me saame teha Harusi nendest harudest, mis on siin enda lokali. Vabandust, lokalis olemas ja originis.
Õpetaja: Te saate ka täiesti uue haru teha, Lihtsalt mingi suvalise komiti pealt.
Õpetaja: Näiteks see koht siin.
Õpetaja: Parem klõps.
Õpetaja: Checkout ei taha. Checkout i New branch.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd täpselt sellest seisust. No ma võin panna, mis iganes ta nimeks
Õpetaja: see nüüd on. See nüüd on checkout. Sellest kohast
Õpetaja: Näete, see mummu läheb seisab siin, saate aru mõttest.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma teen vahele lihtsalt seda ise. Tegelikult. Aa, siis. Aa. Kui. Aa. Ma otsin seda kohta, kuhu ma tahan tegelikult tagasi minna.
Õpetaja: Ma võtan nagu, et ma olen. Aa, ma näen, et see tee ei vii nagu päris sinna kohta, kuhu ma tahan. Aa, mul On plaan
Õpetaja: või teha rebase. Või Võta lihtsalt uue haru. Vana, kust? Võtan ära? Veel Lihtsam on, ju, et ma leian ülesse selle koha, Aga et ma saaks aru, kas see on õige koht? Siis mul on mõistlik teha checkout
Õpetaja: Ee Vaadata, Oma koodifaile panna korra server käima Vaata, kas üldse kopileerub, et ma. Ma leian niimoodi selle koha ülesse. Vaata, mis mulle meeldib, et. Noh, vaata, siin ongi see, et mida tihedamini. Seda parem teil endal on.
Õpetaja: Miks inimesed võibolla liiga tihedalt ei viitsi kommitida on on see, ka et nad ei taha hästi panna Nagu neid message kogu aeg. Iga kord kui teed kommitti, siis päriselus peaks panema mingi väikse message, I, et mis ma tegin,
Õpetaja: sa võid siis hakata tegema seda jama ka, et see ei piisa. Paned mingi Working progress. Üks ja Working progress kaks ja nii edasi. On ju
Õpetaja: Aga Siis sa ei ole väga informatiivne. Nagu selles mõttes. Seda on tüütu ka leida, Et Ee, kipud ikka tegema niimoodi, et teed nagu mingisuguse loogilise osa. Ära siis, Davai. Ma teen committe ära ja panen mingi nime ka sellele peale. Aga kuidas elu on paremaks läinud Cloud Code Ile saab anda ülesandeks. Vaata, et tee minu eest.
Õpetaja: Vaata, Ta vaatab ja ta ise selle pealt genereerib sulle. Vaata, mida sa siin Selle muudatusega tegid niimoodi. Näiteks minu kodust projektis, kui ma teen.
Õpetaja: No ma ütlen üldse, et nagu lõpus tõi nagu Commit Branch Pull Request
Õpetaja: Bush pilve. Merch, Kustuta vanad haarud. Ära. Mine Asteri peale
Õpetaja: ei tee. Vot sellepärast ongi tegelikult. Hea. Kui nad need skill Id on, et Kuule, ma unusta ära, et neil ei ole. Agent
Õpetaja: Meil ei ole koodigeneraatorit. Saab igast programme käivitada. Saab vaadata kõike, teha onju Ee, et Ma. Ma ei usu, et ma enam Production is viitsiksin. Teha nagu mingisugust niukest jama. Ma teeks kindlalt skill I
Õpetaja: täpselt nii, nagu seal, On vaja veelgi parem. Nagu ma propoosiks nagu. Kas me teeksime mingi standard lähenemise
Õpetaja: Noh, Skill, on ju see kataloog saab jagada ju, Vaata, et kõigil on need samad skill Id ju?
Õpetaja: Noh, ma tegin uue Skill I. Kas keegi ei tee Skill I, kui mõnus on tänapäeval Võibolla üldse ühist joont hoida. Esiteks, kõik need. Hoia sellist käekirja. Ära seda tee. Ära toda tee, et enam ei ole nagu seda ka Vaata, et ee. Arendajad ise peavad nii hullult vaeva nägema, et nad hoiaksid sama käekirja nagu koodibaasis.
Õpetaja: Et ee, noh, ikka. Sa ütled loomulikult, peab. Aga tegelikult, kui Claudio ehitab iga kord implementatsiooni nende samade reeglite alustel, siis peaks tulema enamvähem. Sama Tulemus on ju? No mingi väikse variatsiooniga. Kindlasti võib seal tulla, aga suures pildis.
Õpetaja: Ja kõik need tegevused asjad.
Õpetaja: No kui hea oleks mingi rukki talle. Tegelikult, öelda, et kui Sa hakkad tegema seda asja või? Vaata seda? Skill. Ja lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Ee. Kui ma praegu siin. Ee, selles kustutan ära. Selle Marter, B viis Ja siis, noh, kõik teise peal võid järgmist. Noh, ei näegi enam seda. Ja ongi kõik.
Õpetaja: Ei, sa saad. Kui sa remoodis kustutad ära, Siis Ta peab sealt ära minema. Kui ta ei põrka tagasi, et mingi. Ta ei saa seda käsku niiöelda. See, et mingisugune konflikt tekib, Või mis iganes. Vaata mingi permission asi või? Ee, kui ta kustutab ära, siis on pilves läinud
Õpetaja: see on kõik. Ee, keegi, kellel veel See on näiteks kui ta varem Näiteks keegi on sinu Marteni niiöelda haru endale arvutisse Checkout I teinud, siis tal mingisugune asi on sellest veel alles sellest, kui ta tegi. Vaata, noh, et sa ei saa öelda, et kustuta ära tema arvutist. Vaata, See ei toimi, on ju Aga pilvest on see kadunud.
Õpetaja: Ja Ja Remodi all järgmise kaob see kõiget ära on ju on
Õpetaja: Ja ja
Õpetaja: et, ee, ja ma ütlen ka, et kui te ei oleks seda teinud ja te oleks hakanud lokalt hakata, kustuma lokalharu hakata Kustutama? Ta näeb peegeldusest, et remoodis on see alles siis ta alati küsib seda. Ka Track Branch.
Õpetaja: Sest et alati on nagu see. Vaata, kui sa kustutad nagu mingi haru ära, Siis tal on nagu küsimus. Nagu, et. Noh, seda ei ole. Ju siis ka pilves vaja. Ja Vastupidi vastupidi ka, eks? Ei ole Sealt Kustutad ära Miski ei trigeda otseselt, et kustuta. Ära vaata,
Õpetaja: kui need update Id ja asjad vähemalt noolega, näitab et sa, oled maas. Või ees ja nii edasi, on ju siis siis seda seda tagasisidet ta ei anna, vaata, et. Ee. Kuule, sul on siin lokali all mingisugune Haru, mida pilles enam pole. Ma pole jälle midagi, mida mingi skill I alla ei saaks panna. Vaata, et jooksutad, et kas mul on Kõik nagu,
Õpetaja: Okei, See tuleks rohkem nagu teemaks Vaata, kui te tegeleksite. Võibolla ühes projektis, nagu mingi päris mitme erineva asjaga, nagu mingi mitu taaski. Ja
Õpetaja: et kuidagi ütleme. Ma ei näe nagu erilist pointi niukest teha. Sa saad teha. Vaata, nagu, et et, noh, loogiline on ikka Pigem pigem see. Vaata, et iga kord, kui sa Merchid midagi ära vaata, siis. Ee, see arenduse haaru. Sa lihtsalt kustutad ära, vaata, on ju. Ja Thats it.
Õpetaja: Kas keegi siis? Ma ütlen, et kes lõpuks seda nuppu vajutab? Pilves mörts
Õpetaja: ja siis, ee, niiöelda. Ee, Lhv Sse Näiteks polnudki arendaja, enam,
Õpetaja: vaid see oli taas testija. Kuna ta oli lihtsalt järjekorras see, et kui arendajad on arenduse ära teinud, Cold Review On vaadanud, et näeb okei välja. Loetav ja testi on selle ära testinud, et see, töötab, onju? Poolt, on ee antud et et kohe, Kui on valmis, võite Merch Ida või? Ootame release. Mis iganes, et. Noh, testeja teeb oma töö ära siis
Õpetaja: mõttetu põrgatada seda Developerile tagasi, Et Merch I ära, on ju? Millal see põrkub Tagasi On see, kui ta näeb enne ees, on Merch konflikt
Õpetaja: siis seda siis on nagu Vaata, see, et Mastar on edasi läinud ja mingid konfliktid, siis on arendaja. Rida, on ju testeja? Ei hakka nagu, Noh, ta ei Tunne seda koodi nii hästi, onju?
Õpetaja: Aa, arendaja saab paremini selle asja korda teha. Siis tead siis arendaja. Ütleme, kui see on ära testitud Ja sa teed Merchid niiöelda Master kõige uuema seisu endale sinna arendusharusse. See tuli läheb roheliseks. Siis juba arendaja. Paneks, et Merch ja Delik,
Õpetaja: Noh, see on ka. Jälle. Vaata, ma võin rääkida. Vaata, kuidas näiteks Lhv S. Oli. Aga kuidas mujal on, on ju? Kuule, me oleme üle aja läinud. Nüüd, onju? Aa, mis me lubasime. Läheme lõunale.
Õpetaja: Ma ei ole mitte midagi teha.
Õpetaja: Neliteist null viis. Oota, kõrv, Ma panen Rekordi stoppi. Mida mul oleneb?
Õpetaja: Kas rekordi või rekordi?
Õpetaja: Stop Recording, Oota.